I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the republic for which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Thank you.
So our first item of business is to swear in our new member.
And so if Jayden Gray will come forward, I will swear you in right here.
So please raise your right hand.
Okay.
I, J.J.
Dengrae, do solemnly swear that I will support and defend the Constitution of the United States against all enemies, foreign and domestic.
That I will bear true faith and allegiance.
To the Constitution of the United States.
And the Constitution of the State of California.
That I take this obligation freely.
Without any mental reservation.
Or purpose of evasion.
And that I will well and faithfully discharge
and that I will well and faithfully discharge the duties upon which I am about to enter.
The duties upon which I'm about to enter.
Thank you, congratulations.
Alright, so we will...
Now begin with the report of the superintendent.
Tom Torlakson is at an international conference of importance in Ireland and so the chief deputy will produce it.
Thank you, President Chris.
Yes, Superintendent Torleyson is in Ireland at an international meeting on accountability, continuous improvement and well-being.
So I'll be sitting in for the superintendent today, be with you.
And tomorrow, you'll get the A-team with Deputy Superintendent Carrick Ashley, who will be joining you for the meeting.
So Superintendent Torleson had an extremely busy summer and really wants to congratulate and extend appreciation to all the parents, students, and educators around the state for everything that happened over the summer and the fantastic opening of school that we've had throughout the state of California.
A couple items that I wanted to highlight for the superintendent.
One, I'm hoping that board members and members of the public saw that Superintendent Torreson appointed Dr. Thelma Melendez de Santa Anna as the new State Administrator for Englewood Unified.
We're so delighted that Dr. Melendez applied for the position and has taken on that role and she started on August 15th.
She's got a challenging assignment ahead of her and we're asking everyone to lend her a hand as she moves forward and we're expecting really, really great things from Dr. Melendez in Inglewood.
You know, traditionally summertime has been a time when we just kind of took a break in education, but that isn't really the case anymore.
And Superintendent Torrelson wants to really thank all of California's expanded learning programs for the great summer programs that were offered throughout the summer.
He had the opportunity to visit expanded learning programs in Roble Elementary here in Sac City and also at
Robert F. Kennedy Community Schools in Los Angeles Unified in August.
And the superintendent feels that expanded learning programs are incredibly important and has also recently taken a position that we're hoping others will join against the president's proposed budget cuts for particularly Title IV-B and in other areas that relate to preparing our students to succeed and thrive.
And in
In July, the superintendent had the chance to host State Superintendent Chris Reichtel from the state of Washington here in California.
And we're looking at some joint action between Washington, Oregon, and California and of the West Coast block, if you will, in relationship to taking a strong stance in support of some of our critical federal programs and their funding.
So look for that coming out soon.
The superintendent also took an active stand around some of the events, the unfortunate events of the summer.
The first being the unfortunate events that occurred in Charlottesville.
And I just want to read a quote from him where he said, we must remind California school community in our nation that our great state respects, celebrates, and embraces our incredibly diverse population.
We denounce religious intolerance,
racism, and any and all forms of discrimination.
We know in California that diversity is our strength and we have to take a great stand against it.
And he particularly encouraged educators to review a really great blog post from the Learning Policy Institute called Moving Forward from Charlottesville.
The superintendent has also taken a very strong stand, uniting with other state leaders against the federal decision to rescind DACA.
And he noted, I wanted to let all those students know that the American dream remains safe and secure in California.
Our great state will continue supporting these terrific students and their families.
And the superintendent has called on Congress to swiftly restore the DACA program.
As many of you know, and we'll be hearing about later today, our Department of Education is engaging in a very active program of realignment to support LCFF priorities.
One of those activities is some of the internal work that we're doing, which we call CDE Team Advancement.
and just wanted to note a really great event coming up on September 22nd, and there's some flyers around the room, which we're calling our CDE Back-to-School Festival.
We're going to have a whole series of incredible professional learning events here in the building.
We hashtag it for CDE by CDE.
So if you ever want to know why you should have your next romance with cowpats, the Back-to-School Festival is your chance to learn.
But another really key event will be building on the superintendent's initiative around safe havens.
And the superintendent has asked districts around the state of California to declare themselves as safe havens.
And so far, over 100 school districts have done that, representing more than 2.7 million students.
But we now find ourselves in a place where as important and critical as that work is, that we need to move what we're calling beyond safe havens to really work on the kinds of safe and supportive school environments that will make all families and students feel safe and appreciated.
So as part of the Back to School Festival,
On September 22nd, we're hosting a special conference that will be a strand within the Back to School Festival called Beyond Safe Havens.
And the superintendent is delighted to announce that Attorney General Javier Becerra, Sacramento Mayor Dale Steinberg will be in attendance on that day.
We're going to have a fantastic panel right here in this room.
Dr. Ortiz-Lacon will be joining us as part of that panel.
The event itself is basically sold out at this point, but it will be streamed online.
And the link for that, it's actually the same link that's used for streaming these board meetings.
In fact, if you ever want to link into an event that's being held in this room that's being streamed, it's always the same link and it's up on the posters.
So, last but not least, just wanted to end up on some incredibly good news as we start today's meeting.
I hope that everyone had a chance to take a look at this recent research report from Research Triangle International, which showed college eligibility in the state of California at an all-time high.
Not just growing, not just getting stronger, but at an all-time high.
that related both to CSU and to UC.
So, for example, in 2007, the state of California had 46,000 students who were eligible for UC.
By 2015, that number had grown to 60,000, so a growth of over 30%.
Similar numbers were present for CSU.
2007, 114,000.
175,000 in 2015, so a 53% growth rate.
But the good news doesn't stop there.
We're all committed to closing our achievement gaps and the data showed some really dramatic shrinkage
in the gaps around college eligibility.
So going back to that 2007-2015 comparison, in 2007 the eligibility gap for CSU between white and Latino students was 14.6 percent.
14.6 percent.
By 2015 that had dropped to 7.9.
So some real evidence of going down, not anywhere near where we want it to be, but some evidence of getting smaller.
Similarly, for white and African American students, eligibility for CSU in 2007 was 13.1, declining to 9.8 in 2015.
Some evidence that all this work that we're doing, the shifting of resources that we've done through the magnificent local control funding formula is starting to have an impact in our state.
And the superintendent wanted to put that data out to everyone as we as we start the meeting today.
So on behalf of the superintendent, just wanted to thank everyone throughout California for all the great work that's happening as we move the state forward and looking forward to a great meeting today.
Thank you.
So I'll begin with the announcements today.
And our first thing is to, of course, welcome again our new member, Jayden Gray.
He is a senior at James Logan High School, which is New Haven Unified School District in the East Bay on the Southern part.
He is the board representative and class president of the student body.
He is the team captain of the speech and debate team since 2014.
The founder of the Young Democrats Club and student head on the school site council for his high school.
Beyond academics, he is a member of his school's varsity track and field team.
And as a member of Community Action, he is on the Union City Youth Commission and President and Youth Representative on the Union City General Plan Committee.
And since 2016, he has also been an interim clerk in the offices of John L. Burrus.
I don't know when he sleeps, but please join me in welcoming Jayden.
So, I'm also delighted to announce the return to our staff of the State Board of Donna Neville.
And she is entering the State Board Education Office again where she is retired and new.
She previously served in the State Board of Education staff from 2008 to 2009 as Chief Counsel.
And she then left to work at the Office of the State Auditor as Associate Chief Counsel and then as Chief Counsel when she retired.
Prior to joining State Board in 2008, she had worked in the Office of the Legislative Council as Deputy Legal Counsel for the Legislature.
And she will be working primarily on legal issues but other public policy issues.
Donna, why don't you stand up so we can see who you are and please join me in welcoming.
I'd also like to acknowledge the contributions of Amber Alexander who has done a fantastic job in managing our local control funding formula projects for the State Board of Education staff this year.
Amber decided to return to the Department of Finance where she will work on career and technical education and special education fiscal issues.
Please join me in thanking Amber for all of her hard work.
And if you come up, I have a certificate of appreciation for your service.
So we always see members of the Department of Finance, so this will not be a goodbye at all in that sense.
I'd like to announce that the State Board of Education recently sent out recruitment notices to fill vacancies on several of our commissions, including the California Practitioners Advisory Group, the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools,
the Instructional Quality Commission, and next year's student board member.
So, please visit the State Board of Education webpage to look at those things.
One change in the agenda, item 23 has been removed from the agenda.
That was scheduled at the end of today, Wednesday, removed by the Chief Deputy of California Department of Education.
So, we will not be taking up item 23.
Spanish interpreter services will be available on Wednesday.
We have three public hearings, items 19, 20, 21.
We have regular consent items that we'll take up later in the day.
Proposed waiver consent items also.
I want to announce to board members that the letters from the public are in your electronic red folder, which I'm sure all of you have seen.
The State Board of Education meeting can be assessed fully by electronic agenda.
We have one copy in the lobby.
All speakers, please sign in at the table just outside this room.
Binders are on the table with separate pages for each item number.
Sign on the page that identifies the item number on which you would like to speak and help ensure that we can keep track of all speakers.
Item 22 is a general public comment item for items not specifically listed on the board's agenda.
If you wish to give the board anything, please provide 25 copies to Amy Bubico, who's sitting right down there in the front on my left-hand side.
And please, speakers, introduce yourself as to who you are.
And there is additional seating with TV monitors outside of this room in 11,000, room 11,003.
So, with that, we're
going to run the meeting with one minute limits on speakers, except on item four, where five people who come together will get three minutes.
So with those items of information out of the way, we're ready for item one.
and this is a CD performance and progress update on our Smarter Balanced Assessment and the online reporting system for the Smarter Balanced Assessment.
Michelle Center will present for the California Department of Education.
Good morning, President Kirst, board members, Deputy Superintendent Price, I'm Michelle Center, Director of the Assessment Development and Administration Division here at the department.
The item before you, item one, requires no action on your part today, and I will be sharing a few highlights from that item, though the item before you does have additional detail on topics that are just not part of the presentation.
As you know, through our online reporting system, districts have had access to their own scores for many months.
At this time each year, we also post score results to our public website.
We plan to do that public reporting in September.
While the public results have not been posted to that site yet, please note that we are confident in the accuracy of the student results that have been given to districts, schools, parents, and students.
We take the accuracy of our public reporting site very seriously and have a process by which we invite our LEAs to preview their data.
Once that preview period is complete, we will schedule the public release for later this month.
The CDE will be providing you, our board members, with results of the statewide assessment via an October information memorandum.
While the public release of our summatives is one piece of information, it's also important to note that we also provide information to our educators in California through our interim assessment reporting system, which is a different reporting system than what they use for our summative assessments.
As a reminder, more than 7 million interim assessments were given in the 16-17 school year in California across more than 1,500 LEAs.
This is far greater than the number of summative assessments and goes to illustrate the impact that the interim reporting system can have for our districts, schools, educators, and students.
The CDE has worked collaboratively with Smarter Balanced and several California districts to make enhancements to that system, which was launched on September 5th.
My staff, led by Jessica Valdez, and several California districts deserve kudos for their work on this important project.
And I think when you see it demonstrated today, you will also feel excited about the enhancements that we have made to that site.
I will be inviting a couple guest speakers to join me today.
First, I'm going to welcome to the podium Mr. Moses George.
He is the student testing and assessment specialist from Los Angeles Unified School District.
He is here today to share his district's experience participating in the development of that interim assessment reporting system and how he sees this new reporting system helping teachers guide instruction.
Mr. George.
Good morning, everybody.
President Christ, members of the board and Chief Deputy Superintendent Price.
Thank you very much for this honor.
My name is Moses George.
And as Michelle said, I represent the Los Angeles Unified School District.
It's great teachers and students.
And it's an honor to be able to speak and share a few minutes of our experience with the interim assessments and the interim assessment reporting system and the enhancements.
Over the past three years,
Our teachers and staff in Los Angeles Unified School District have found great value in using the interim assessments as a tool that has informed teachers practice and as a tool that students have had the opportunity to use to experience the Smarter Balanced assessments throughout the entire year.
We have gone as far as every year ensuring that all of our schools have a trained CAS testing coordinator,
that has been able to guide all of our schools through the use of the interim assessments and through the use of the scoring system that then produces the data that the interim assessment reporting system gives to our teachers.
Throughout the past three years, even with the limitations of the data that was generated with the initial or previous interim assessment reporting system, our teachers and schools found great value in using the interim assessments.
The value was such
that at many of our schools, we found teachers and teams of teachers that were actually manually going deeper into the results that they received and the work that the students were doing in the interim assessments to disaggregate the data themselves and to find deeper value on their own through their own time because of the value that they saw in the interim assessments.
Upon hearing about the enhancements that Michelle and her team were wanting to create,
and having been contacted to take part, we were certain that our staffs, our teachers, and our stakeholders would want to be part of giving input into the enhancements.
And sure enough, as soon as we put out the word, we had an abundance of individuals from all stakeholder groups that were eager to share of their experiences and of the enhancements that they thought that would be beneficial to the Interim Assessment Reporting System.
We reached out and received information and feedback from our stakeholders from elementary, middle, and high school, from our local districts, from instructional leaders at the district offices, and from all, we gained great, great information that we were then able to share with Michelle and her team.
Going forward, we have absolutely no doubts that what we have already seen with the new enhancements, that our staffs, our teachers are going to be ecstatic when they start to be trained and be able to use these new enhancements from the reporting system.
From what before, they used to get a
below standard, at standard, or above standard as the data that they would be able to have to now being able to see at a claim level or at a standard at a target level
and the answers that the kids gave to the actual question and to then be able to see the written response that the student gave and be able to work with it and with the students.
These are the kind of enhancements to the reporting system that we are certain that our teachers are going to use to even greater benefits in the work that they are doing with their students on a daily basis.
We want to thank you greatly.
for this opportunity to be part of the development of this enhanced reporting system.
And we want to eagerly say that we want to continue the collaboration in further developing this tool that we are certain is going to become the state-of-the-art formative assessment tool that our teachers have so wanted and needed to have in order to be able to do the quality of job that they want to do for their students.
We thank you and for this opportunity.
Thank you.
So I'd like to thank Mr. George as well as all of those that participated at LA Unified as well as other California districts.
This has really been a project, a long-term project.
It started back in 2015 and we knew when we rolled out the interim reporting system what the number one request was from Teachers in California.
And that was for them to see the actual responses of their students.
So we went into this project knowing that that was the number one request, but we didn't stop there.
And there are additional enhancements beyond that in the system.
So next, I'd like to welcome Tony Alpert.
He's the executive director of the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium.
He's going to share with you the enhancements and some screenshots of the system through a demonstration.
President Kirst, members of the board, and Deputy Price, thank you for the opportunity to talk with you.
I am Tony Elpert, now a very proud UC slug, now that the consortium has moved to the University of Santa Cruz College of Extension.
A banana slug, sorry, a very specific type of slug.
So I think Mr. George really gave the important information about the enhancements, and that is that the process by which they were developed was through collaboration with local educators, significantly from California, but also from across the consortium.
and with significant input from Michelle and her staff that is absolutely vital to our success.
And in addition, the board was involved in approving funding that then helped ETS provide data, which then is inserted into the system.
So the collaboration goes well beyond
any single individual, well beyond a school, well beyond a single state.
There are many people that need to be a part of this in order to make it successful, so I want to express my gratitude for everyone involved.
So as Michelle described, we actually started this process way back in December 2015 as a public agency.
As you know, things take a little bit of time to get moving.
And it's not just because of the logistical processes of procurement.
When we were deciding to release an RFP, we engage all of our members and ask, what do they need?
and they ask their stakeholders.
So that communication is happening continuously on a lot of different projects.
And in this case, it really resulted in a contract that began work in fall of 2016 in collaboration with another partner, Fairway Technologies.
So the department staff and staff from LEAs and schools work closely with Smarter Balanced to address questions like which data and information should be available, how should the information be arranged in the screen so it's easy to use,
How would an educator move through the system?
So where would she start and where would she move after she had answered one question?
And really get that impact or that focus from teachers about giving the information that they need in the manner that they need it when they need it.
And then, of course, user acceptance testing, asking those educators to confirm that what they said should be in the system is actually in the system, which is an important part.
And then we'll follow up with teachers after that to find out if what we thought we were doing actually helped them do what they need to do.
So I think Mr. George described many of the enhancements, so I'll run through them briefly.
One of the most important is that teachers can actually see the item that was presented to the students and see the students' response, each student's response embedded in that item.
Thank you.
So the, and the, sorry.
Can you see it up there, folks?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's fine.
What?
Okay.
Thank you.
So, and that's the true promise of the interim assessments, which we describe as non-public and non-secure.
That is, we don't want the items to be posted publicly on websites so that teachers have the option of administering them as novel tasks.
But we want teachers to have the flexibility to administer them as standardized tests or to administer them interactively with their students, projecting them up on the board.
And we want teachers to be able to look at the items themselves and how students responded to that with the additional context necessary to help them make more comprehensive evaluations of what students know and can do.
As a prerequisite to that, teachers need to have access to their specific students and the tests that their students took.
So a big portion of the enhancement is something we call student groups, where someone authorized by the district, probably delegated to the school, that has access to all the personally identifiable information for students, very restricted access.
those folks then delegate access to individual kids with specific labels, which might be classroom names, it might be periods, it might be programs like AVID, whatever clustering label they want to organize students into groups that then they can analyze the performance of those students.
Then we wanted to be able to give an overview of the item, the results, across the test and within the test, so allowing teachers to dig in quickly to see which items students performed well on and which ones they might have struggled with.
And then the most important, probably the one that we're most proud of, is the work to connect the information in the interim assessment, the performance of students on interim assessment tests, to resources in the digital library that help guide teachers on what their next steps might be.
So the work is not nearly complete.
We have a whole bunch of enhancements scheduled for release in March.
That includes a distractor analysis for what's called non-constructive response.
So as you know, we have a variety of item types in Smarter Balanced.
Some of them are very complex in terms of what the plausible answers a student might be.
So those aren't necessarily as easy to display in terms of a distractor analysis and to comprehensively described the wrong answers that students chose.
But for those multiple choice items where a distractor analysis is appropriate, we'll have some additional functionality release incorporated into the system to support that analysis.
We're going to be looking at longitudinal data displays, which is very complex in the interim assessment because of the flexibility that I mentioned previously.
So teachers are able to code whether or not the assessments were administered in a standardized or more flexible fashion.
They have the flexibility to administer the interim assessments throughout the year.
You can imagine that within a school year, interpreting growth or change over time with all that flexibility is difficult.
And then you can imagine data over multiple years where those tests might not have been administered by the particular teacher, passing on all the context necessary to make good decisions about those results.
over time is even more complex.
So we're going to tread cautiously and we're not going to release it until we're confident that your teachers can give us good advice about how to make that data workable.
And then an additional element to that is allowing the current school to see a test that were administered in a different school.
And that's a pretty complex data transfer and needs to be attended to very carefully as well.
And then we'll talk a little bit about the more robust links to the digital library.
So I'll go through some of these screenshots pretty quickly.
We wanted to make sure we allocated sufficient time to your questions and didn't want to do a live demonstration because that's just always a little bit risky.
So here's an example of creating custom groups.
You can see in this case, Tina has third, fourth, and fifth graders, and she split her class into A and B. And the subjects that she has access to are math and ELA.
So there's a lot of flexibility in this system that can give teachers access to the specific students and the specific data that is most appropriate for them to see.
A very comprehensive set of filters that allow teachers to hone in on subgroups of students within groups to be able to identify the performance of students that they're particularly concerned about, all in an effort to improve teaching and learning and close achievement gaps, which is, it's the moral imperative that we all share.
Because of the flexibility of the interims, each interim is designed to be administered, interim block is designed to be administered within approximately one class period.
Sometimes students will take the same test, or different students within the same class will take the same test on different days.
So to be able to look at all the students together, we needed to give a functionality to the teacher to be able to group tests together dynamically.
So teachers will be able to identify the test, the particular test that was administered, in this case, in this example, fractions.
She could see that some tests were administered on January 26th, some tests were administered on January 24th,
She is able to highlight both of those and look at the composite performance of those students across those two testing events.
She can look at the average scale score, the standard error of the mean, which is the appropriate error statistic for groups of students, the total number of students that are included in that count, and then the distribution of student scores in the categories that Mr. George referred to earlier.
In the second example, there are even more tests.
You can see that the number of students has increased, the average scale score has changed, and of course the distribution of student scores is also dynamically presented.
When teachers want to drill in a little bit further,
They can go into a particular test, they can look at the item number, the question that was presented to the student, the target and claim that that item is aligned to, and the claim, as you may recall, is a collection of a cluster of standards
that is designed to represent the more holistic way in which we expect teachers to combine those standards as part of instruction, and they're more conducive to measurement.
And so we want to retain the coherence of the standards while still giving the details necessary to make good decisions about whether or not students have mastered the information that they need to know.
We provide then three levels of item difficulty because a lot of the information that we're providing, or most of the information we're providing, is in raw scores.
So you'll see to the right, the student scores, they're integers, 0, 1, 1 or 2.
And those are the raw scores or the items.
As I think you're aware, we create scale scores through a very complex process.
Those scale scores give a difficulty value to the items that are on a spectrum of student performance.
So that adjusts, that gives the information about if a student got it right, but it was an easy item, it puts that into context more consistently.
But for the interim assessment, we want to give teachers that more detailed information that might be in the raw score.
but at the risk that they may misinterpret a student getting it right without knowing the difficulty of the item.
So students may get the item right, but it was an easy item.
They may have gotten an item wrong, but it may have been more difficult.
So we provide all that information to add to her portfolio of understanding.
And as additional context, we also provide the standard to which the items align.
We selected many of the standards to which the item is aligned, but for many of these items, it's a subset because the targets are so holistic in many cases.
that there are many standards to which the item could legitimately be aligned, but the item writers are asked to identify sometimes the primary standards, and so those are the ones that are included on the report.
Further to the right, you'll see the student raw score, the maximum possible for that item, and then the correctness is the ratio between the two.
That allows teachers to sort by correctness and takes then into account a value of one out of
a possible max of one versus a value of one out of a possible max of two.
So helping teachers hone in on where students might have struggled a little bit more clearly.
On the next slide, you can see an example of how an item, and this is a fabricated item because we don't want to violate the security status of the interim on a live statewide stream.
This is an example in which the student's actual response, in this case, the student chose C, is shown in the context of the actual item itself.
And for text-based responses, teachers will actually see the text that the student typed in.
That will be shown in the context of the item as well.
The teacher can see the rubric, if it's appropriate, applicable to the item, that is the basis for how the score is derived, and then some additional item information including a more descriptive, comprehensive description of the target to which the item is aligned, the depth of knowledge, a lot of additional information that might help the teacher build in her understanding of what her students know and can do.
The link to the instructional resources is really exciting.
So at this point, when teachers click on that green box, it brings up a Word document which will describe the comprehensive set of resources that her peers suggest to her might be appropriate based on the performance of students in her class on that test.
So as an example, a student that did really well on revising text,
might be ready for enhancement.
And there are resources in the digital library and suggestions in this Word document that would help the teacher engage in that enrichment process.
Likewise, if the student is far below the standard, there might be suggestions for retooling or additional supports also located in the digital library that would help her increase her students' learning.
So right now there's about 15 of those out of the 100 IABs, associated IABs.
We engage with educators, several from California, but across the country to work on the remaining 90 or so resources that we will add into the digital library.
And that's an amazing process which allows teachers to look at the standards, look at the tasks, talk with each other about how they would interpret the results if a student is high or low performing, and then dig into the digital library and add their collective wisdom, which is then made available to their peers to help them use that information to actually change their practice and help their students learn more.
We expect that in the next phase of enhancements, those links will appear directly in the library.
We also, rather than in a Word document, we also expect that LEAs will be able to customize the links that they want their teachers to see so that they can add their own unique expertise or their own unique resources that they want their teachers to see based on the performance of students on these tests.
And with that, I can answer any questions you might have or I'm sure Mr. George and Michelle Center are available as well.
Well, thank you for that.
Are there board member questions?
Comments?
Board member Rucker?
Well, good morning, Tony.
It's nice to see you.
Nice to see you.
I just want to say as an advertisement, I'm looking forward to going to a project that you have going on later this fall.
And I wanted to ask you to share a little information about that afterwards.
But my particular question to you is how much of the guidance or the information that goes out to the test coordinators will give the kind of detail of information
for them and for the guidance that you're giving to teachers, how has that been updated so they understand not only the new functionality, but they have a clear understanding of what their options are for using the interim assessments.
Because of some interpretations of our statutes that you have nothing to do with, many districts have used the interim assessments like scheduled benchmarks and not giving teachers the flexibility
to use your program in the way that it was intended and that has had some unintended outcomes and concerns that are being raised that you're addressing.
But what I'm curious about is in making these changes, does that help or do you believe based on the feedback you're getting right now that that's going to aid districts in understanding that they have greater flexibility to use the tools in the way you intended and do you believe that's going to change
the level of engagement that classrooms can have on this.
Thank you for the question.
So our goal in enhancing the reporting system is to empower teachers to use the data from the interim assessments and empower them to administer the assessments to improve student learning.
So what we've heard from many educators in California is now that these enhancements are out, districts will be more likely to encourage their teachers to use the system.
So I think there will be a motivation to address the issue of access and flexibility, perhaps a little bit more than there has in the past.
We have worked with ETS to create an interpretive guide to help teachers understand how they might use this, the results, to change their instructional practice.
It's more focused on best practices and the utility of the information that's available.
It doesn't get at the administrative flexibility necessarily to which you're referring.
But we also have a comprehensive user manual that Fairway Technologies address, which is also getting at the logistics.
I think I probably need to defer to the department about addressing some of the different interpretations of statute that the teachers might be dealing with.
In terms of your first question, I'm looking forward to your participation in that workshop as well.
That is the next stage of these digital library connections.
So it is this process of really building a set of experts, teachers, building their capacity to understand the measures and then asking them to collaborate with each other on giving guidance to their peers on what are appropriate next steps.
which based on our pilots and our first administration of this event in September, we're hearing that from teachers that this is an amazing professional learning opportunity.
So I think you're really going to enjoy that.
And what we're also doing at that event is we're looking at setting new additional cut scores for grade 9 and grade 10.
So as long as we're bringing a whole bunch of educators together and asking them to talk about the standards,
We wanted to take the opportunity to give some additional information that teachers might use when they're administering interim assessments in grades other than 11.
For your purposes, for some of our other states that have elected to administer the assessment, the summative assessment at an earlier grade, we're providing that resource for them as well.
So it's a lot of things going on.
The reason why I asked that question is that it's related to the second question I wanted to ask you, and it's concerning the digital library.
Knowing that we had a rough start with getting teachers signed up and involved with the digital library, now that more teachers across a collection of grade spans are looking
at the content, what is the plan that you have for building out the instructional resource there?
Because teachers, as they're beginning, educators, let me change that, educators, as they're beginning to look in the resources in the library, and not just in the teachers and the grades, the subjects tested, but people from other content areas who are also looking there,
One of the things that they are seeing is that it is kind of narrow, not only for the types of instructional resources there, but for the grade spans or the topics that are covered.
So what is the plan for, I know we have a cadre of folks who are working on some of that content, but now that the access is getting wider and we're seeing better use and more frequency of use, what is the plan for building out that content?
So the consortium has been working with its members for over a year on the adoption of a strategic plan.
We do anticipate that in October we will have an in-person vote at what we call our collaboration conference.
and embedded that as numerous strategies, several of which relate to the digital library.
What we do expect is that once that plan is adopted, that members will then, will endorse by virtue of adoption of that plan, the development of more specific interim assessments.
Either, right now we have interim assessments that cover four to five targets in some cases across 15 items.
We will still have some of those that we'll call multi-target interim assessments, especially in ELA.
Some of them are just not conducive.
Some of those content elements are not conducive to being measured separately and would be potentially harmful to do so.
But we will also then deploy many new interim assessments that we'll call single-target IABs, which are much more focused.
Rather than in an after-the-fact manner connecting those interim assessments to the digital library, we expect that we'll co-develop resources in the digital library as we're developing the interim assessments to make that connection embedded and explicit.
Thank you very much.
I just want to close by telling you thank you and also acknowledging I've had a lot of support from Dr. Kirst in having conversations with you.
But I want to just say that you have a lot of very smart folks around the country that I've had a chance to talk to.
about the work you're doing, not only in building out these applications for the new reporting functions and developing the interactive guide, but also for doing the work to expand the system and to make the system more functional and to meet the needs of the teachers.
So I want to thank you for making those folks available to talk to me.
including me in some of those planning conversations.
It's been a great opportunity and I have learned so much about the system.
But I just have to say, and I want to make sure I say it publicly, you have some very creative and very smart folks doing the work on this.
It's not a bunch of testing nerds sitting there being fascinated by what the machine can do.
They really do want to think about teaching and learning
and what the educators as an end user, what their environment looks like.
So it's been really nice to get a chance to talk to them and to work with them on this.
Thank you.
And I know they appreciate working with you.
I do want to take the opportunity to thank Gail Pagano and Jackie King on my staff who have been pouring their lifeblood into this system.
So it is
truly the result of a lot of love and care, and as you describe, an emphasis on helping teachers help students.
The workshops are happening at the end of October and the beginning of November, so I think we're trying to figure out with you where to optimize your meeting.
Other comments by board members?
Board Member Sun.
Hi.
As an end user, I'm very excited about these enhancements and I can't wait to start on them this year with our school.
I was actually hoping to hear a little bit more from Mr. George about how your teachers piloted, how many, how it was administered, how many times.
And what you found might have been some effective practices with these enhancements?
In regards to the original or the enhancements?
Enhancements.
So, it's been very limited up to now how much we have done work with the enhancements.
We were very much engaged with the UAT phase.
We had teachers and groups of educators come
and take part in looking at the items, the mock-ups, and then give feedback to us that we then funneled.
Prior to that, the original interim assessment system and reporting features are district-wide.
The millions that Michelle referenced, I would venture to say our district accounted for many, many millions of those assessments having been given and more so the work that the teachers were doing on their own to disaggregate the data paper-wise really showed the value of the system to the point where they were investing of their professional development time to do it themselves.
They were giving interim assessments two, three times the same one as a pre, post,
and then after intervention type of tool.
And so now the work that those same teachers did when they looked at the enhancements is what starting this week, we are starting our trainings for our teachers district-wide on the use of the enhancements this week.
And so we will first train a cadre of 800 school coordinators on the use of the enhancements that will then funnel down to all the teachers at those 800 schools.
And how much time would you say was saved with the enhancements and not having to sort out the data manually and do all that?
So, for example, yes, that's a wonderful question.
So, for example, one teacher would easily take, oh, an hour and a half to disaggregate the data from one assessment for one small class of, say, 30 students.
That might not sound like a lot, but when you look at the amount of professional development time that teachers have,
An hour and a half is a huge amount of an investment of their time into just disaggregating the data where they will now be able to see in a matter of five minutes of grouping their students that are theirs into the reporting system and being able to see.
So easily, per interim assessment, a teacher is going to save easily an hour's worth of work in just getting the data for their students grouped into one format where they can see it.
And that's just one small example.
of the savings of time that the system will bring to teachers, that they could then invest in the second phase of determining what they need to put into practice to address the deficiencies or the areas of weakness of the data.
And that, again, for a teacher, an hour's worth of time that they don't have to spend doing that work with the data, and they can spend doing the work of, what do I need to do to help my students in that area, is tremendous.
And that has been a barrier of more fully utilizing those interim assessments.
So I'm really excited about this.
Definitely so, likewise.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Congratulations on this.
I know my husband's going to be thrilled to know about these enhancements.
I do have two questions.
One has to do with the advanced filters, which I really like.
And I'm wondering if this is already done because I would love to see RFEP as one of the filters added.
And slide six.
Reclassified.
Sorry.
So yes, these filters are currently available.
I don't think the reclassification data is included in the current set of data that ETS transmits along with the interim.
So we'd have to have a conversation with the department and then ETS about what would it take to integrate that.
And I'm not sure that that's associated with the data originally.
So it might be a little bit more complex to match it all.
together.
I missed some of what you said, Member Rucker.
So, we do have agreements to transfer data between these entities.
So, we are covered by that via our contracts and written agreements.
So, we can look at the data that we transfer and see if it's in there.
If not, we also could advise people in the meantime to utilize their grouping feature that they can set up themselves in order to look at that group, but we will take that back.
Thank you.
Because I know that that's one of sort of the commitments that we made here to continue monitoring our reclassified students.
And then the second question is rollout.
So it seems like LAUSD is definitely running with this, but when can other districts expect to get training?
So I think Tony mentioned some of the materials that Smarter is working on collaboratively with us and with ETS.
In addition to that, we will be rolling out our CASP institutes and this will be a focus of the CASP institutes.
We also will be talking about this at our annual North-South meeting where we train about a thousand
coordinators in California.
Those begin at the end of this month.
So we will be utilizing various professional development and learning opportunities.
We also have a clinic that's available.
And then the post-test workshop.
Right, so we, it's almost like I have a mini professional learning, you know, segment of my division now.
And so we will be touching on this in those various settings.
In addition to showing this and talking about it,
We always take the opportunity to address the concern that Member Rucker brought up earlier about the intended purpose and the value that we see in this system and how that is really most valuable when you allow your educators to make those decisions.
Okay, Board Member Sun.
Just a quick technical question.
The grouping ability for the, is it at the site level or is it at the district level?
Yeah, so the delegation of authority happens from the LAA to the site.
Okay, so a site coordinator can do, for example, if a site wanted to set up groups by teacher, by classroom, they could do that.
Okay, so they can do that.
Great.
Okay, no further questions and we're ready for public comment.
Would Doug McRae please line up?
Good morning, I'm Doug McRae.
I'm a retired testing nerd from Monterey I submitted a handout for this item for your electronic folder last Friday providing 2017 summative results for 13 Consortium states to provide context for California's pending release of results.
I now have information for four additional states so I have 17 of the 21 using
consortium states.
Focusing on gains between 2016 and 2017, it's notable that all Smarter Balanced states except one have negative overall gain scores, with the exception of one zero gain score, while all park states except one have half positive.
overall gains.
This is a rather stark finding and begs the question whether the Smarter Balanced results are due to student or school performance or if they reflect a problem with the 2017 Smarter Balanced tests.
I would think the latter and I'd speculate that may be due to changes involving the Computer Adaptive Item Bank 2017 summative tests.
Be happy to answer questions on this context information.
Okay that and a board member
Go ahead.
Board Member Holliday.
The answer to the last question confused me though that Member Sung asked.
The decision about grouping the students can happen at the teacher level.
That is, is that correct?
Michelle?
We'll have to have somebody answer that.
So, in order to protect individual students' information, someone is authorized to access all, an individual has to be authorized to access all plausible students, and that individual then allocates groups to specific teachers that may have a more restricted access.
OK, so the filters are a shortcut to this process, perhaps.
But at the same time, if an individual teacher wants to have a better understanding of how their students are performing based upon the composition of her classroom, right?
She wants to know the kids who live on Oak Street, how are they doing versus the kids that live on Elm Street, right?
So then she would have to go through the LEA coordinator or some other... Or a site coordinator.
Or a site coordinator in order to have them provide that for her.
But that still is possible to do that.
Yeah, there's no minimum number of groups.
Okay.
So it's an extra step, but she can get to what she really wants.
And that's the important part.
Yes.
Okay.
Board Member Burr on this item.
So Michelle, I think, are you finished with the presentation?
Okay.
I just wasn't sure where we were in the... But I do, I actually do have a question for you or maybe it's a comment and I'm not quite sure it's on this item, but I'm going to take a shot at it.
First, I also want to congratulate, add my comments to member Rucker, to both Tony, the consortium, and all of our partners, ETS, and everybody on your staff, because I think, as you heard, especially from people on the ground who actually use this, this is going to be an enormous improvement.
So, congratulations for that.
I also want to say how much I appreciate the department's attention to the accuracy of our test results and understand that that's the reason why they're not being presented right now and are going to come later.
But I just have a comment about kind of living in the past a little bit about test results and how in our prior accountability system, test results were the be-all and end-all.
And so we had like a big hoop-dee-doo about it.
whether it was positive or negative.
And I would just like us to look at in the future when we do the dashboard release, this is a preview of Cindy's item, that we release results for all of our indicators at the same time, if that's at all possible.
Because I think
Because I know we do graduation rates separately.
We do suspension.
I assume we're going to do chronic absenteeism.
But I think for our public and especially our parents and our community members to say, here's what the whole picture looks like at one time, it would be better than sort of having a big hoopty-doo again about test results.
Sometimes I think it continues to reinforce that that's all we care about and that's not the case.
Member Burr, please do know that we've had that exact conversation internally and we are talking about that and we want to make sure that we are sending consistent messages to the field about the value of multiple measures and so you know whether or not we release the assessment results separate or when we do the dashboard in the future
It's important to always have that message there, and we definitely are deliberate in that, but we have also considered the approach that you mentioned.
Board Member Sun.
Before we end this item, I thank you Board Member Burr for reminding us of that, that this is the test results is one data point.
And it's a data point that is not the end and it just speaks to it.
It's the beginning of what we can do to support our students.
And to that, I really want to express my appreciation to Michelle, your team,
In getting the test results out to the sites and the LEAs so quickly, we were getting our results in June.
And we had the vast majority June, July, they trickled in.
And we were able to start the school year with good data on where our students, how our students performed to help us start the interventions and to work with our students moving into the very beginning of the school year.
We never had that under the old system.
So it's great to be able to have that and be able to have utilized that data right away.
So we have a fresh start.
I think what's important about that, Member Sun is that, you know, you had no prohibition about using those results.
Districts are not waiting for us to release the results on our public website to use the data.
They are using the data now.
They have been using the data.
Yeah, that's very good clarification.
Go ahead.
Thank you so much for all the work that you're doing and thinking about this in the spirit of formative assessments and that scoring has been the issue.
So this efficiency that you've, I mean the time in scoring is what I mean, but the efficiency that you've done is really a hallmark of the effort that you and your team have put together.
So in thinking about, you know, the PLC process, the professional learning community of teachers gathering around the data and looking at it, there was probably a window of time when districts at the beginning looked at the interims, looked at the digital library, took a peek, and then decided to not do it at that time.
So I'm assuming that there's a cadre of users and there's a base number for that.
And there's also a group, a large group probably, that aren't using that.
And so in your rebranding or in your rollout,
really think about not only how to let current consumers know about it, but how do we, and I know through the statewide meetings and so forth, how do we get other districts who have, who either took a peek and decided they had something else that this is really about.
a viable tool.
And so that's just something to think about in terms of that campaign of really getting districts to see the value and see it as a formative opportunity.
So thank you so much.
So I don't know what the usage is.
That would be interesting to know.
It depends on which vehicle you're talking about.
In terms of the digital library, it's very difficult to determine usage because you could have a single lead teacher who's actually doing the access that is actually implementing something for an entire grade.
And so those numbers are a little more difficult to get in terms of the digital library.
But in terms of interim assessments, I presented some numbers for you.
So, that is being widely used.
I think that we have a particular group in California, it's called our Regional Assessment Network, which is made up of county leads and we meet with them regularly and I think this is an important topic that I will bring to them about how they could assist us and really reaching out to those districts that may have decided not to use those based on the prior reporting system and make sure that everyone knows about these new enhancements and have that decision-making opportunity again.
All right.
I think that ends that item.
I'm very impressed with the expertise on this board in terms of getting into this in depth.
I'm learning a lot from the members.
Okay.
We're on to item two.
And that is the recommended action and update on the development of our accountability system.
When we approved the accountability system required by LCFF, the board also approved an annual review process for considering improvements.
The California dashboard was field tested this past spring.
And this fall will be our first operational year under accountability system.
So, this is the update on the first annual review and we will have recommendations and actions on revisions and the calculations of the state indicators.
So, Cindy Kazanis is here to present.
And then we'll hear from our liaisons on this.
Go ahead.
Thank you, President Kurst and members of the board and Chief Deputy Price.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I'm Cindy Kazanis, the Director of the Analysis Measurement and Accountability Reporting Division.
I see today as sort of a culmination of a year-long process.
Last September, you approved the metrics of the dashboard and you asked us to develop a work plan that we needed to get a lot of things done by
this first year of operational results for the dashboard.
So for the last year, we have engaged with numerous stakeholders.
We have put together three different work groups.
We've actually overworked our technical design group this year.
We actually, I think, doubled or tripled their meetings.
But everybody really stepped up to the plate.
And I want to acknowledge the work of Jenny Singh and her staff.
Jonathan Eisler of my staff, Randy Bunnell, their leadership and the team of my division has been phenomenal.
And we have a lot of work to do prior to December.
So I won't tell you the work is done.
The work is ongoing.
You're going to hear that in a couple slides.
But we also have partners throughout this department and we couldn't do it without our program experts.
And so you're going to hear from a couple of them today as well as I present this item.
So to get us started, there are nine attachments that were in your item.
And some of them were shorter than others.
But we will go through most of them individually.
So I won't walk through them in this overview slide.
But of the nine attachments, there are going to be five actions.
So the actions that we're going to ask you to take is on the English Learner Progress Indicator, on the Academic Indicator, the Career and College Indicator,
And for small populations, we're going to bring you a proposal as well that Jenny is going to walk through.
And then finally, we're going to ask you to take action on something you considered in July, which was the dashboard alternative school status.
You will not be taking action on the academic indicator as far as inclusion of 2016-17 Smarter Balanced scores, nor will you be taking action on the chronic absenteeism data.
Those are two points of data that we've only gotten within the last couple of weeks.
We need time to work through the issues around our, you know, we need to do our analysis.
We also want to take that to our technical design group.
in late October, and we will be engaging with stakeholders as time permits on these as well.
So those are two pieces that I'm previewing for you that we will pick up in November.
And more critically, we can't actually release the dashboard publicly until you make decisions on both of those indicators.
So I want to emphasize that too.
So attachment one, it covers the English Learner Progress Indicator.
And my colleague Veronica Aguilar from our English Learner Support Division provided you an excellent overview two meetings ago back in May.
I know there was a couple of you we have.
Our student member is new, but I think member Valdez may have been out as well.
But we did provide you a really, like I said, detailed overview.
So I'm not going to spend as much time on this, but I do want to cover the key points.
So, last July, in adopting what we are calling the LP, you asked us to come in a workgroup of experts to talk about reporting long-term English learner data for accountability purposes in this indicator.
So, we put together a workgroup.
We brought them together in person several times in Sacramento.
We also provided you updates throughout the workgroup meeting and then maybe provided you the culmination of their recommendations.
What we also put forward to the CPAC, those same recommendations, into our technical design group.
And you can see on this slide, the recommendation is simply to provide extra credit for LTELs in the LP who advance at least one level on the California English Language Development Test.
They also supported providing additional EL and LTEL data reports in DataQuest and on the dashboard.
So with that recommendation, the formula looks a little different than in the spring dashboard.
The green, which is the addition, is again adding LTEL CELT test takers who increased at least one level on the CELT.
What this will affect, and I like this slide a lot, but I want to caution you, this is using old data.
So this is using the Spring Dashboard, how this would affect those particular schools.
We would actually see schools change in color, a total of 63 schools would change in color.
by adding this extra credit to the formula.
So this could be lower or it could be higher with the fall dashboard.
But we know that it helps at least 63 and for that I think that the workgroup and the department thinks it's important to move forward with this recommendation.
The second attachment is regarding the California Alternate Assessments.
California Alternate Assessments are given to students who have the most significant cognitive disability.
So it's our 1% of students.
I do have Kristen Wright in the audience who's prepared to help with this item as well as Michelle Center and technical staff from ETS.
So when you approved in January the academic indicator, you asked us to come back in September to see if we could incorporate the California alternate assessment into the academic indicator.
We've talked to the technical design group a couple of times about being able to do that for this fall.
They've actually recommended postponing this incorporation because they think that there needs to be additional years of operational data.
And so the multi-year rollout of the test design needs to be more complete.
There are also some technical challenges that the technical design group will need to help us overcome.
So between our testing contractor and our assessments division, we've had some discussions about the fact that the reporting structures are different.
So just some technical considerations that we need some more time to examine.
So the recommendation is to
Wait until we have additional years of data to perform simulations and evaluate options for reporting a change for a valid denominator.
So it's going to take us, I think, at least another year to work through this information.
recommendations that we got from the Chair of your Advisory Commission on Special Education was to report out on the scores for these students.
So whether, while they cannot be included at this time, we don't think in the academic indicator, we'd like to see at least an acknowledgement of these students taking an exam that's aligned to our current standards.
So that's the recommendation from the department moving forward for, at least for the alternate assessments incorporation into the academic indicator.
The third attachment and the fourth attachment both cover the college career indicator.
And keep in mind the purpose of this indicator is to emphasize that a high school diploma should represent the completion of a broad course of study and rigorous course of study to prepare students for college and career.
We were pleased to see that nationally we're being recognized for our work in this area.
The Bellwether education partners noted that the college career indicator was a high set.
a high-quality set of accountability indicators that will measure student performance against college career readiness benchmarks.
So, you know, there's a lot of states that are struggling to put this indicator together like we have.
We've been working on this since 2014.
But to be recognized for the metrics that you've approved last September, it's nice to get to recognize that we're headed in the right direction.
With that in mind, we have a couple of pieces we want to talk to you about.
This particular attachment is going to be for action.
And then Donna Wyatt, my colleague from the College Career Transitions Division, will be presenting on the three-year plan.
So last September, we brought to you the indicator for college career.
You approved status cut scores based on our prior assessment, the standardized testing and reporting star early assessment program.
So you had asked us at that time, you knew that the data was old, and we have a new system that's aligned to current standards.
So you asked us to bring this back.
And we are bringing this back, and we're asking you to consider changing the status cut scores.
These next couple of slides give you an idea of what the change looks like and why we're making the change.
So if we think back several years ago when we had STAR EAP, I think it's been three or four years now since we've offered it, it was optional for grade 11 students.
Smarter Balance is required for all grade 11 students.
So we actually have a larger universe of students taking this assessment.
STAR, EAP, and math was only available to students who had completed or were currently enrolled in advanced math courses, whereas Smarter Balanced math is available to all students.
And then EAP was optional, so students could elect to complete the EAP section to receive a determination whether or not they were college career ready, whereas now it's embedded into the assessments.
So all students receive a determination whether they're ready for college.
So those are, I think, really important notables as you think about how different what you approved last September is to this September.
The technical design group, as a result of looking at the new assessment scores for Smarter Balanced for the class of 2016, is suggesting, and the department is recommending as well, that the status cut scores be changed to reflect the first year students who took, again, the Smarter Balanced assessments.
And so what does this look like for the coming year?
Because right now, we will be using the class of 2016 data.
You'll only see in the fall status.
You will not see a performance color because we don't have another year to compare it to the same group of data.
We have not yet processed our cohort.
We have the data, we haven't processed our cohort.
I'll show you on the next couple of slides what this will look like on the dashboard.
We want to make sure that we provide the public with more information than we were able to do in the spring dashboard.
In fact, we want to be able to show
how students were labeled as prepared, because there are five different options of demonstrating preparedness, as well as approaching prepared and not prepared.
So what will next year look like?
The fall 2018 dashboard will actually be able to skip ahead a cohort.
We are automating a report in CALPADS that we've had to do manually all these years for our cohort data.
And by automating that report, it's our intent to be able to put out the data for the cohort in the year that they graduated.
So novel idea, but it's taken us a while to get there.
But what that will mean is we'll actually skip over, we'll be able to leapfrog into 2018.
So you'll see status for class of 2018 compared to class of 2017 for change.
So next fall, the goal is to have a color for this indicator.
And so, again, this is why I think it's so important that we start off with the status this year showing appropriate cut scores for the smarter balance assessments.
So this is what a report may look like in the dashboard.
In this report, we're using a table that looks a little different than we have, I think, it gives in the dashboard in general.
But for this particular sample district, for prepared students, it was almost 50% of their population.
Only 1.5% were prepared based on
career technical education pathway completion.
Majority of them, not the majority, most of them were prepared by showing that they met at least level three standard met on ELA or mathematics for smarter balance.
A small minority was enrolled in dual enrollment, two semesters or three quarters.
And then you can see gradually reaches up to students who were able to demonstrate preparedness by having passing scores on the advanced placement or international baccalaureate tests.
And then finally, that they completed A through G plus something else, because A through G alone does not demonstrate that you're prepared in the college career indicator.
So a different sample district, or it may be the same one, I can't remember where we got this data from, I think we probably made it up, is showing approaching prepared.
So again, you can see the numbers drastically reduced, but there's 20% that are approaching prepared.
So this is just, again, it's a visual for folks to be able to see.
We're teasing out the data because the data by itself of just approaching prepared doesn't, I think, give you a true picture of how students are doing at the high school level.
So that's what this is intended to do.
So with that, I'm going to turn it over to Donna Wyatt to present the three-year plan for the college career indicator.
Thank you, Cindy.
Good morning, President Kurst, Chief Price, board members.
The work in the Career and College Transition Division is focused on two career readiness indicators right now.
The work-based learning and industry certification and stackable credentials.
Work-based learning, the work is identifying the continuum.
We are outreaching to stakeholders, those districts and county offices that have showing or are showing some expertise in work-based learning.
So what are all of those experiences from career awareness all the way up to career preparation and entering the workforce?
So identifying the experiences and then putting indicators to those.
What are the quality indicators for a guest speaker in a classroom?
What are the quality indicators for an internship?
And then finally, what are the outcomes?
What are the differences that we're going to see in those students as they experience and take part in that full continuum of experiences?
With regards to internships, that's really part of the continuum.
Internships are kind of the gold standard.
They are the culminating event to that series of work-based learning experiences.
It's what we work towards in the classroom to get students ready for.
Industry certifications are a combination of working with organizations like NOCTI or CTEX who have those standardized types of assessments.
But it's also about building stackable credentials.
So many industry certifications are not available to students until they're 18 and above.
Well, that's our community college partners.
What can we build in K through 12 that allows students to build their skills, build their knowledge towards that industry certification?
An example might be in a health pathway.
A student enters in 10th grade.
They take a Red Cross certification, CPR certification, layman's course.
11th grade, they might take a CPR course, but now it's for professional rescuers or professional health care providers.
12th grade,
then they're maybe entering into a dual enrollment course in EMT or emergency medical responders.
So it's building that sequence up to the point where the student can then take that industry certification at the age of 18.
Moving on into what's included currently, articulated courses, where school districts and community colleges come together around courses and build the courses together and have agreements that students who take those courses in high school are also earning college credit through oftentimes an exam or perhaps
attaining a certain grade in that course.
The state seal of biliteracy.
The standalone courses we're further exploring, an example of that might be a nursing assistant course.
A semester long course that students take that prepare them with the skills and the knowledge necessary to take the state exam to become a certified nurse assistant.
Well, that has all of the components of a high quality CTE program and a career measure.
But we're not quite ready to take that step yet.
That's coming further down.
And then going further on, military.
Everything from the reserve officer training, ROTC, to acceptance to the military.
It's not currently collected in CALPADS, but we do collect it as part of our Perkins grant.
It is one of the indicators that we collect for completion of a CTE sequence.
So the other thing I wanted to note with the College Career Indicator is we've engaged our Alternative Schools Task Force to think about ways that alternative schools could also demonstrate preparedness for a college career.
You know, oftentimes they may only have six months or a year with a student, but that is valuable time.
And in fact,
I think we heard an anecdotal story that they have more internships or they have higher participation in dual enrollment than traditional schools.
So we are finding out a wealth of information from that Alternative Schools Task Force.
And so in relation to college career, I wanted to make sure that you were aware that we've been also focused on what we're going to bring forward to you a year from now in terms of the Alternative Schools Indicator.
And then the other piece, too, is that we've brought this
this information as well to the Advisory Commission on Special Education because again the same concerns with different populations of students being able to demonstrate preparedness.
These may not be the metrics that we would advise that we use for those populations.
So we are being cognizant of the fact that we do have a
percentage of the students that are enrolled in our alternative schools.
And so as we develop out this three-year plan, we will also keep that in mind moving forward.
So with that, I wanted to move on to the schools with small populations and Jenny Singh of the Academic Accountability Unit will be presenting this piece.
Good morning, everyone.
So I'm going to present the schools with small populations.
So you may recall that when we first started presenting simulations and results to the board in regards to the indicators, we had a lot of stakeholders raise concerns about schools with small end size being over-identified in the red performance level.
And, of course, we produced disseminations and we saw this as well.
So, we agreed that we would look at ways of addressing this issue.
Now, this isn't anything new.
We did this for AYP and we did it for API.
We had alternative methods that we used to hold harmless schools with small in sizes.
So we did look at multiple methodologies, I think four or five different ones, and we brought them to our technical design group.
But as we were also looking at these methodologies, we also realized that schools with small populations were also being over-identified in the blue performance level.
But we didn't have many stakeholders point that out to us.
So we did realize that we had to have a methodology that really did limit the extreme changes on both ends.
And so we are referring to this as the safety net.
So the safety net methodology removes the increase significantly or the decrease significantly change levels.
Now we're only focusing on change, we're not focusing on status.
This is only relevant to change.
So for schools with small populations, they can only receive an increase level, a maintain level, or a decrease level.
So the five by five grid actually becomes a three by five grid.
Schools and districts can still receive any of the five colors, I mean they still can receive all five colors, but their placement on the grid is going to be limited.
So we have an example of what that looks like here.
So we're just removing the decline significantly and the increase significantly and narrowing that box.
You can see you can still receive a red, an orange, a yellow, a green, or a blue.
So we did conduct quite a few analysis to determine if schools with small populations were being over identified in the red and blue performance level.
But we wanted to make sure to conduct that analysis on all the state indicators.
So we did conduct an analysis for all state indicators.
And then we applied the three by five grid to all state indicators because we had that request from our technical design group and from representatives of small schools and small school districts.
So we did present them with that information.
We did the analysis using two end sizes, 150 and 250.
And this was to accommodate the two different requests that we received, one from the TDG and the other from the small school representatives.
So the TDG really felt that it was important that the end size be based on the denominator for each indicator.
And this is really important because our indicators vary.
And in California, we have a very diverse set of schools that serve different grade spans.
We have K-2 schools, we have K-12 schools, we have 7-12 schools.
We have a really diverse set of schools.
So we didn't want to base it on enrollment only.
So you can see here that the denominator is determined differently for each indicator.
For the graduation rate, we have the number of students in the cohort.
For the LP, it's the number of CELT test takers.
For ELA and math, it's the number of valid scores.
Remember, valid scores are based on the number of students who are continuously enrolled.
And then suspension is based on the number of students who are cumulatively enrolled.
And so this can make a difference.
I indicated this in the item itself, is that you can have a school that has a very large population.
For instance, there's a pre, starting with primary, preschool all the way to 12th grade.
And this school may have a large population.
It does have a large population, 2,800.
But when you look at grades 9 through 12, the population then drops significantly to 600.
But remember, the graduation rate is based on a cohort.
So you're only looking at one grade.
So you're looking at those students who first entered ninth grade.
and then if they completed their, received a diploma by the end of four years.
So the number drastically shrinks.
So for this school, we're talking about 134 students in the cohort and they would then be eligible for the three by five.
So the small school stakeholders group and the California Practitioners Advisory Group provided the following feedback on the safety net.
They wanted to use the 3x5 grid only for suspension and graduation rate.
We noticed that this is where the biggest problems were between
small schools and schools that were non-small schools.
We also did look at student groups and we noticed that there wasn't a problem, which is a little surprising, but we wanted to be cautious on moving forward with this.
We can always add in the three by five if we discover that we need it for other indicators or for student groups.
So we decided to start off with suspension and the graduation rate indicators.
And they wanted to use this methodology starting in the fall of 2017 for the release because we have single school districts who are small and we don't want to identify them incorrectly for support.
And they did recommend an end size of 250.
The TDG concurred with the first two bullets but recommended an end size of 150 because that's based on our statistical analysis, our chi-square and our z-score analysis.
And so that is the recommendation that we're bringing forth and with that I'd be happy to answer any questions Okay, I think we're ready then for questions on any aspect of this Sorry, we do have two more slides to go and then we'll take questions at the very end.
I apologize So the last two rather last three pieces this is this particular one attachment 7 is the last of the
action items.
And in July of 2017, this last board meeting, you did approve the criteria for the dashboard alternate school status, DAS, which replaces the alternative accountability school model, ASAM.
Following your decision, actually, I think two days later, we got an inquiry from a colleague who said that one of the new definitions singled out students with disabilities
or rather disability category, which was emotionally disturbed students.
And they thought that it was inappropriate and suggested we take the criteria back again to the Advisory Commission on Special Education.
Keep in mind we had taken this criteria to them in June and somehow everybody missed this.
So I know that member Sandoval was present but there was a robust discussion at the Advisory Commission on Special Education and the members did want to recommend to you that this category be removed and the department does agree with the commission on that particular recommendation.
We are currently collecting applications for DAS.
They are due to the department October 6th.
At this point, we are not seeing any schools that would not be eligible just based on removal of this criteria.
They oftentimes are multiple ways to get to the 70% threshold that you adopted back in July.
And with that, there's just two more slides to present.
Jeff Breshears will present attachment eight, and then I'll present attachment nine.
Good morning, Jeff Pachears, the Director of the Local Agency Systems Support Office.
Just a real quick update on the local indicators for Priority 6 and 7.
Priority 6, the School Climate Conditions and Climate Work Group have been working and meeting to further develop the school conditions and climate measures in our system.
They've taken a lot of stakeholder feedback.
They presented a memorandum in June, have taken that feedback.
They're going to meet again in the 25th of this month and then present findings.
They've also presented to CPAG and have received a lot of feedback from their work and where they're moving forward on these recommendations.
We'll present a memorandum in October and I think they're bringing forth a recommendation in November.
For Priority 7, we anticipate coming to you next in November, the next meeting, and ask for you to approve the inclusion of the local indicator for Priority 7 access to a broad course of study.
With that, I have you approve a standard very similar to the other local indicator standards that you have, and then also show you a draft of the local indicator self-reflection tool for Priority 7.
From that,
We will take that if you approve and we're moving forward through November through March, I mean February, we'll engage in stakeholder feedback to further develop and fine tune that self-reflection tool for priority seven and then bring that hopefully final tool back to you in March for the inclusion in the fall 18 dashboard.
Thanks.
Excellent.
And then to finish off, we do have a dashboard release coming.
We are looking, our end goal is to get it out the week of November 27th.
In order to meet that goal, we are approaching our private preview a little differently than we did this past spring.
We are anticipating that we can do a rolling weekly release of indicators.
So we're looking at two per week, starting with the first week of November.
And we think that by doing this rolling release to LEAs, it'll get them time to get comfortable with the data.
We are thinking at this time that the first two would be the graduation cohort and the college career indicators to really focus on the information that they may not have seen before or focused on in spring.
Again, depending on your actions in your November meeting on the academic and chronic absenteeism indicators, we would then do a very quick turnaround before Thanksgiving and get that final set of data out.
So as we think about the launch and the next item you're going to hear, I wanted to let you know that we do talk among staff on a regular basis.
And we realize that the systems of support is now
is now real and the dashboard release needs to be coordinated with how systems of support and the language around that gets out.
So we are talking about a coordinated communications plan moving forward for this November release.
The other piece I wanted to mention is that other organizations are stepping up to the plate and doing outreach.
I think last meeting I mentioned to you that the
that the CDE Foundation had some funding and has put together some parent resources and so this flyer is the first of those resources and I don't think it's yet publicly posted but we'll try to get it up on our website.
because we are trying to build out our parent tab on the accountability website.
But it is nice to see others who have different sets of expertise than us sometimes in communicating to the field to get information out.
So with that, I
I also wanted to let you know that we are, in addition to Michelle, going to numerous conferences this fall.
We will be on the circuit talking about the dashboard and talking about the decisions that you're making today.
Everybody is very eager in the field to learn about what November brings for them in the fall dashboard.
So with that, President Christ, we have finished the presentation.
Okay.
Well, that's quite an update.
So we're ready for board member questions or comments on these technical items.
Perhaps our liaisons ought to start.
Board member Strauss is one of them.
Board member Burr is the other because you've heard this as well and been over.
A lot of it's pretty technical.
So I want to first comment on the college and career indicator as a former high school principal.
I feel like the
the components that make up the college and career indicator are really important to help inform high school staffs and community and how we work together to improve college and career readiness.
And so I just want to compliment the data set that is available.
We did present it at CPAG and also I've presented it at Santa Barbara and San Bernardino County superintendents and to a college career
collaborating committee in Riverside.
And people were particularly pleased with the different data sets that you are able, so that districts are going to be able to click and go deeper into the data and really see who's A to G ready and how you actually calculated it.
So I think that that alone, it's a wonderful indicator, but it doesn't tell you everything unless you unpack it.
to try to deal with the different components.
So just a compliment on the ability.
And I think as Member Bernier said when we met with staff is that it's not done yet, but it's definitely ready to get out there and to be used.
So just a positive comment on that one.
And then also on the small schools,
since more than half of our districts are really small.
And as I talked to superintendents, they wanted us to remember and not to forget the smalls.
And so I think they're particularly appreciative of the safety net calculation.
And at least as I presented just in the last week to them.
So again, I think those are in trying to improve our overall dashboard and our indicators, making them reliable, I think is actually really, really important.
And then to support the English learner progress indicator and the additional, because we're asking districts to really focus on English learners and to help students get reclassified and support them, the fact that we're rewarding and reinforcing students that make the progress, I think that's an important support as well.
So those are some general comments that may have some more after that, but maybe Member Burr would like to add.
Thank you.
Yeah, I would just echo what board member Strauss said and also just to say this is what continuous learning looks like, right?
We made this commitment that we would be reviewing this carefully and I just really want to commend Cindy and Jenny and Michelle and everybody who's involved in this that they're very good listeners.
They hear what people are telling them about issues that are important and while this seems very technical and some of it is very technical,
It's a reflection of them being very good listeners and understanding that if we want to make this work and we want people to feel that it's transparent and that it's actually measuring what it's supposed to be measuring, we have to have this level of attention.
So I really, really appreciate that.
Also, just to reinforce what Board Member Strauss said about small schools, that's going to be especially important as we talk about the next item.
Because when we start talking about systems of support, the level of support that small LEAs need is very different than what Los Angeles Unified needs.
And I know there's this tendency that people want us to standardize and say everybody should do A, B, C.
It just doesn't work in every setting.
So this is actually a very good indication of why it doesn't, that when you pull apart the data, it just doesn't work with small populations.
So anyway, I want to have an opportunity to hear from people about our stakeholders' input.
But again, thank you very much.
I really appreciate all the work you've done.
And I had one more thing to add.
So as I present the College and Career Indicator out to stakeholders in the field in those three counties that I talked about, I made it really clear that we still have some work ahead of us on the College and Career Indicator.
So I appreciated the ones that you're still working on.
I also believe high school readiness is an indicator that you're talking about as well.
And also the field really is concerned that we have not, they accept that we haven't finished at the highly prepared area yet.
But I've assured them that that is an area that we still are evaluating.
And also that in looking at what career tech course taking patterns are, apparently there's some issues on standardization of what inputs people put into the CALPADS.
So I assured them that we are aware of that and that we are going.
So I think when we get done summarizing before after the comments,
to clarify the continued work we have to do since we haven't resolved all the career technical preparation as whether it's several courses on a capstone project, where the certifications are going to be, where do internships fit in, and that we feel like it's ready for the first round to
to practice and work with, but we know it's not complete yet and that we want to deal with the highly prepared and complete some of those.
So maybe at the end, we might summarize still some of the tasks that you're clear about that we still need to do.
Thanks.
Okay, Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Thank you for the presentation.
Yes, I also want to echo on some of the concerns that I read from some of the letters that came in in regards to the college career readiness indicator and in particular when we will have a well-prepared level.
So we offer a three-year plan, but we never really commit to a timeline for it.
So I think it is important for us to say by, you know, certain year we will have it in place.
The other thing that I've said it a couple of times before, the participation rate, I see that now we're moving into a local indicator for access to course study, broad course study.
So I want to ask about... Yeah, I'm sorry.
Be patient.
I want to ask about the local indicators because my concern is I think it's such, for me, who is having access, what student groups have access is critical.
And if we move it from this indicator and we put it at the local level and we haven't really, I don't know how many people have actually submitted data, how many LEAs on the local indicators.
And I do believe that we need to add some rigor to them if I, you know, met, not met.
For me, that doesn't tell me enough as somebody who's a parent and somebody who's a policymaker and somebody that's an educator that cares.
So, that is my concern.
Met, not met, for who?
Who met it?
Who had access?
Right?
So, it would leave a lot of questions for me.
I do believe that we need to, for the sake of equity, really track that carefully and put it in a robust indicator.
And the other thing is looking at additional measures like GPA was something that was mentioned.
Are we moving more students to the prepared, nearly prepared, the different levels?
I'm sorry, I have a million notes in front of me.
Also showing that removing students should be, there should be an incentive for that.
And I heard that loud and clear from some of the letters and I agree.
But if you could answer the question about local indicator and also GPA and some other measures and when we will have a well-prepared category.
I can't answer the well-prepared category, but the local indicator, we're looking at just in draft form.
So the met, not met is the standard of whether or not they have gone through the standard.
And the standard has, they collected the data at the local level, discussed it, and then presented it to their local board.
And that's the met, not met.
The local indicator is really just very, very rough draft form and has room for development.
The hope and the desire for the local indicators is really to serve as a catalyst at the local level to discuss those needs as they are unique to those areas and to dive those out.
The met not met is the decision that the board made and that would be for you to change and to look at.
But the draft, like I said, we'll bring a draft to you in November and get your feedback and move from there as robust and rigorous as you folks would like it to be.
with people submitting information on the local indicators, LEAs.
So, fall, I mean, in the spring it has been voluntarily and I don't have, the last number I saw was about 150 LEAs and we have been pushed out and I don't know if anybody has updated numbers, but that was the last I heard.
Excuse me.
I'm pushing it out though then and those again were field tests and be able to move forward and they would
be permanent and fall, so we're pushing that out.
In fact, we're writing just an update now to get it out to the field just to remind them it's time and encouraging them to do so.
I think the other staff, you have other questions.
Jeff can't answer all of the questions you raised.
Jeff is heading up the local indicators.
And since my office deals with statewide data, we are focused on the statewide indicators.
So I appreciate my colleague coming up to help me.
The college and career indicator, you had some questions on.
Yes.
Our timeline for well-prepared and also consideration of including the GPA, which I know in the past people have argued it's not really calibrated across the state.
But we do have the data and, you know, to an extent, people will use it.
I mean, it may not be calibrated, but that's how students are getting into college.
So.
I'll take the latter one first.
It's not currently in our three-year plan because it's not data that is, as you say, there is a wide range of how LEAs report this.
So it's something that we would have to actually create a standardization for in order for it to be valid and reliable at the state level.
And that, I think, will take time.
bit of time.
I cannot commit to you on when we'll get a well-prepared piece either.
We do have a three-year plan in place and as measures get added to the CCI and we develop out existing courses in CALPADS to support that, we need to train our CALPADS staff to get those
data right.
And so I think that Member Strauss was mentioning the fact that our CALPADS district leads are getting trained right now on inputting data.
We still have concerns with data quality and you're going to hear a lot about that when I come back in November with our
with our chronic absenteeism indicator.
In fact, we didn't have 100% of district submit information to us for that particular data set.
So I have concerns as well that I don't have 100% of our LEAs submitting data to us on something that is very important, which you've all deemed as very important.
You've put it as an indicator in our system.
So I think we have a ways to go, but as far as committing to a time, I wanna be in a more comfortable place in the data quality before I bring you a firm date that I can commit to.
Okay, Board Member Rucker.
Okay, so I want to begin also by adding my kudos and congratulations to not only the amount of work that's been done, but what's actually been accomplished.
I have to tell you quite frankly, three years ago when we started down this road on not only implementing the LCAP and figuring out those regs and writing the template, I really was lost.
in what the process was going to look like to develop this accountability system.
And despite the fact a lot of work has been done to create a system that truly does have, meet the multiple in multiple measures, so that it's not multiple assessments, but multiple types of indicators.
I remain sensitive to the criticism that this accountability system as being implemented
is still loosey-goosey.
And so part of this loosey-gooseyness is related to the fact that for accountability purposes and the purposes of identifying schools that are subject to intervention or that could be identified as among the lowest performing schools, we have multiple indicators that over multiple different types of timelines are in various stages of being fully developed and fully implemented.
but the clock for identifying these schools has started ticking.
And so I do have that particular concern and I want to understand, for example, when the data elements for the dashboard are rolled out in November, how will schools understand what their status looks like based on the fact that some of the elements in the data dashboard
are not fully fleshed out, but will in some way contribute to informing the state's decision on what the status of those schools are.
And that's a question we're going to have to live with right now, and we may know more about that
when we come back for the board meeting in November.
So, that's not a question you have to ask to answer today, but I want to put that out there because that's a concern that I have.
The second concern that I have is related to some other work that's going on right now.
Along with two other members on this board, I was appointed by Dr. Kirst to be part of the California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee.
during our last meeting, we took a look at the student data systems from several statewide agencies, the UCs, the CSUs, the community colleges, and they actually have existing data about workforce preparation, but also about student course taking that actually could inform some of our indicators.
And so one of the questions I asked at the end of that particular meeting
is not only why is their data system better, but how come we can't use that information since our criteria for the data points that we're supposed to use to build out our indicator is existing databases.
So there are some existing data systems from the community colleges, from the CSUs, from the UCs that tell us more about the courses our students are taking, about the access
to a broad course of study, particularly that our seniors have received as part of the work that these systems are doing to receive these students matriculating into their program.
They know more about those schools than our current data system has the capacity to report.
So, again, that's not a question you have to answer today, but I did propose this question and there were staff who were in this room today that I gave that question to.
I would like to know, as part of this plan for building out over the next three years, the college and career indicator,
and developing the information that we have to collect on student course taking as it relates to CTE courses, there are other data systems that have that information.
And I want to make sure that we're taking advantage of the type of information and data analysis that those other systems have used.
So that's the second question you don't have to answer.
Now, the third question that you don't have to answer today.
Perhaps, just on the second question, because the last meeting, I think you probed me on this too, and the McCall-Kerlander study with the CDE, she has data from CSU, she has data from the community colleges and that five-year grant from IES, from the federal government will help us get there.
That is the exact intent of that grant.
So, we just had a conversation with her earlier this week about getting data from EDD and
um while we're
We're not there yet.
That is one of our vehicles for getting at that question that you keep probing us on.
And she's being sweet.
What she's really trying to tell you is I've been a bit of a nag.
So the last question I would like to have an answer to and it concerns the student score report.
With each successive assessment cycle and with as we've done more work now on developing and preparing
the dashboard to send out to the public, some of the information that's on our student score report is no longer at sync with the kind of information that parents can now see when they look at the dashboard.
And I realize that the geography on the two pages we actually have on the student score report is, you know,
a bone of contention, more serious than figuring out where state boundaries and borders are actually going to be.
But I would suggest, particularly as it relates to the college readiness indicator or as it relates to for students who have career technical education,
information that's going, that they've taken courses on.
There may need to be some consideration on what to say about what the indicator is saying or because since Smarter Balanced does do with grade 11,
a score, a report about the student's readiness and we're continuing to make adjustments on what that definition is that maybe we, there needs to be a plan for looking at whether or not, is there a plan or have you thought that we might need to update or do something to revise the score report.
Maybe I can take it from the accountability piece first.
The college career indicator is meant to be a school and LA level indicator.
At no point have we looked at it being a student level measurement.
And so I think that's something that is very different.
But I will turn it over to Michelle since she is in charge of the real estate section of that two page report you talk about.
So you are correct.
We have been plagued with this problem of real estate on our student reports for many years.
And so while I'm not prepared to talk about it today, in January, I will be coming back to this board and we will be having a conversation that addresses that particular problem.
I knew that's what you were going to say.
That's why I wanted to ask that question.
Thank you.
Board member Sun.
I think this is going to be for Jenny.
I'm all about the small schools.
So I just had a little bit of some technical questions regarding the three by five.
Okay.
So first of all, thank you so much.
I know I've been a broken record with regards to this small schools, small LEAs.
And so I appreciate the work that the TDG and your staff are doing to make sure that we don't get that volatility.
So but just on the technical end, when it shrinks to three by five, is it a
Is the scale shrinking?
I just I'm kind of curious how technically it works or you're just taking the two ends out?
We're just we're just taking the two ends out for change only And that's where the volatility comes in because if you look at the suspension for elementaries a 1% change in suspension I believe it's 1% is is
So if you increase suspension rate by 1%, that is the increased...
Suspension always messes me up.
So if you have a small school for the suspension and it's a 1% change, you could actually go from a green to an orange.
Because if you only have 100 students, that 1% could be one student.
So one student is really making a large swing from a green to an orange.
So when we eliminate the two ends, then we're reducing that significant swing.
So one student can't force a school from a green to an orange or a green to a yellow.
Okay.
And so I appreciate as we get more data, we'll continue looking at this system and seeing how that works.
I am surprised that it didn't impact student groups or individual student groups.
That just seems a little bit counterintuitive.
It is counterintuitive, but that's what the data showed us.
And as I mentioned, we wanted to be very cautious with moving forward with this.
We didn't have as much time.
We don't have multiple years of data to look at.
So we wanted to be cautious moving forward with this is when we get more data in, it may change and we'll come back and address it when it does.
Right.
And I'm just looking for a commitment that will continue, of course, refining this as well as other indicators and as we get more and more data in.
I think, I think that was all I have for it.
Thanks.
First of all, I just want to say thank you so much to the work that has been done by everyone in the work group, but also the TDG and really doing the analysis.
So I think this is really not just about the numbers, it's about the story that the numbers tell.
And so as LEAs and schools begin to look at all of this work.
So my question has to do with the broad course of study actually with Jeff.
And so I know that statutorily they just have to go through the process at the local level and indicate whether or not they've done the process and that's met or not met.
Is there any, are there any plans to look at what people are beginning to post?
I know it was a pilot in the spring, but those kinds of descriptions that are going into there, because I think LEAs would like
to see qualitatively are there suggestions instead of you know going shopping to see well what did another district put in or what is I think more direction would be helpful to LEAs just to see or sampling so that it's not sort of
just dependent upon the LEA's talent or luck of what they put in, I think it would be helpful.
So it's about transparency.
Is there any opportunity for feedback to LEAs or is that just something that gets posted out on the World Wide Web and it's up to the local consumers or parents to give feedback?
Currently on the local indicators, I believe it is what they post in the dashboard and what they show there.
Any direction or any assistance that we can provide moving forward, we're certainly receptive to looking at that and what needs LEAs would need and request to provide that.
So maybe some kind of sampling in the future might be helpful to LEAs.
Just a suggestion.
Thanks.
Board member Holliday.
To follow up on Member Sung's comments about the small schools, first of all, thank you very, very much for all the people, all of you who did so much work to analyze this and to make this recommendation.
I want to make sure everyone understands that what this will do is not change the data, will not change the facts, will not change the reality, but instead simply reduce the hyperbole.
And the fact is that it in many ways will actually help a small school understand more realistically what happened in the previous year, what the change has been.
It is not concealing the fact that suspension rates went up or down.
It's reducing the hyperbole and that's a good thing.
Board Member Sandoval.
I have a question and just some clarification on the California alternate assessment recommendation.
And I understand it's not ready yet for inclusion for accountability purposes.
But I do know that we are committed to being accountable for each and every student.
And so the recommendation is to report out the results of the status.
But we still need more time to evaluate options and run simulations about how to incorporate that into the full accountability system.
So if you could just describe a little bit about the plan in the next year to get to that place.
Sure.
So I think what we are proposing is that similar to the grade 11 results that you asked us to put as a separate data point on the dashboard, we would do that for the California Alternate Assessment so that, again,
parents that have students that participate in it are seeing their students' progress as part of their overall school's progress.
But in terms of what lies ahead of us, not only will our technical design group be looking at this, I'm sure we'll be working with Michelle's
technical group as well on the assessment side and again our testing contractor to make sure that we do this right.
We want to be very thoughtful about this.
We don't want to force something to occur that may not be valid and reliable.
So, you know, as the test has yet another year of operation and we can look at how we can merge those results into something that we do in accountability, which is look at status and then change.
We look at year-over-year change.
We want to make sure that we do this correctly.
So over the next year, we'll take yet another look at that data and we'll engage with those technical groups to make sure that, to see if we can do this for next year.
And I think engaging the Advisory Commission on Special Education to the degree possible is very valuable because they meet frequently, have the depth of expertise, and I know we're very committed to seeing the evolution into one system that serves all of our students.
So thank you for, again, for being a great listener.
The entire team, everyone who's working on it, I'm very grateful.
Thank you.
And I know Michelle's presented to them several times, and I think we've been at every meeting since last year.
So we are now a standing item on the commission's agenda.
So I appreciate that feedback.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
I have a question on the small schools and I thank you for clarifying that the 2,800 was a SPAM school because when I read the item, I reacted.
I'm like, are we really allowing people to capture to get the safety net if they had mass dropouts with the 2,800 high school?
So thank you for making that and I hope it's very clear that that has to be the denominator so that, you know, it's not confused.
There was a couple of folks that raised the, that suggested that we also do something similar for LEAs looking at not only the school site level, but considering something similar for LEAs.
And I'm wondering if there has been any discussions about that.
Yes, the small and size would apply to schools and LEAs because we do have single school districts out there.
So it would be applied to LEAs too.
And charter schools, of course, who are considered LEAs under the system.
Thank you.
Thank you, President Cruz.
Just wanted to add on a quick supplement to Mr. Brashear's response to the questions around local indicators from board member Ortiz-Licona, board member Valdez.
And just to recap the earlier piece of Mr. Brashear's presentation where the school conditions and climate work group, which has been working really hard on priority six, will be putting out an information memorandum in October.
and then hoping to come back to the board in November with some very extensive recommendations around priority six, both related to measurement, but also fundamentally the work group has been grappling with the concept of support, which links into our next item or item three around system of support.
And the superintendent has also begun to convene in relation to priority three, parental involvement and ad hoc work groups as we move and not wind down, but as we complete the work of the school conditions and climate work group, we're hoping to then move into priority three and do the same kind of intensive look and bring back to you some recommendations.
Okay.
I think that concludes the board questions.
So before public comment, I think we need a break.
So let's come back at 10 of 11.
Okay, the State Board will reconvene.
We're ready for public comment on item two.
Amy, please.
Do we have the people?
The following people are for public comment.
Would the following speakers please line up for public comment.
Celia Jaffe, Doug McCray, Mary Perry, Martha Diaz, Roberto Villamontes, Shelly Watley, Colin Miller, Martha Alvarez, Sheldon Smith, Liz Guillen, Brian Riveras, and Terry Burns.
Parent Teacher Association.
I want to talk about some of the local indicators.
I want to appreciate the comments by members Ortiz, Lacone, Rucker, and Valdez about these.
The broad course of study, access to a broad course of study, I'm happy that the board will be looking at this indicator and standards for it because the access to a complete education for all children is at the baseline of what we should be providing.
We suggest that the board members look at the California Arts Education Data Project, which summarizes arts course offerings around the state using CALPADS data as sort of a model of what kinds of data collection is presently available using CALPADS.
We also want to appreciate the work of the School Conditions and Climate Work Group, which we participated in as members and in the stakeholder feedback session.
But dearest to our heart, parent and family engagement.
We're hoping to get standards and definition of that in statute soon.
Thank you.
Good morning, Terry Burns, California School Boards Association.
We particularly want to thank the work for the work on the small schools indicator.
We think that that is incredibly valuable and important.
We're pleased with that.
We look forward to your action to have chronic absence in this year's the fall dashboard.
We think that's very important as well.
Finally, on the local indicators, we have concern that school climate work group is talking about having district survey every year.
We think that is to mandate that is too often.
It's costly, it's timely, and it doesn't give us time to actually implement the changes that we see as a result of those surveys.
Thank you.
Good morning, Mary Perry, California State PTA.
And I really want to focus on the dashboard as it applies to high school accountability.
The California State PTA still sees that reporting incomplete as long as there isn't a separate indicator around SBAC scores for 11th graders.
And we hope that in the spirit of continuous improvement and exploration, that that remains on the agenda.
As far as the CCI components, college and career is a higher benchmark than college or career and needs to be part of the consideration for how that well-prepared category is defined.
And we have confidence that that continues to be a consideration.
In addition, I see military participation as a possible inclusion in the CCI
We have the National Student Clearinghouse data, which would be a cost to the state, but is another way to get post-secondary information about our students and really needs to be considered as well.
Thank you.
Good morning, Colin Miller with the California Charter Schools Association.
I just want to make a couple comments on the CCI indicator.
We've done some preliminary runs of the data based on the 13-14 data that's available, and we see a significant over-representation of charter schools in the red on that.
It's very severe.
And we know that the item didn't really give you that kind of information.
We're concerned that you're being asked to vote on cut scores when you haven't seen those kind of breakdown in the data.
And we would definitely encourage you to request that the design group and CD go back and look at this, run this data so we can really see what's behind it.
It's hard to know what's behind it because we don't have all the data, but we have some ideas about why that's why
charters are being so significantly overrepresented and we could get into those conversations, but we did want to alert you to this.
We're really concerned that the dashboards will come out without the backup data on this information, particularly around the four-year cohort grad rate data being used instead of just all grads.
There's a number of issues, so we could go into it, but very concerned about the data being released with this huge overrepresentation.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Sheila Whitley representing California Teachers Association.
CTA represents appreciates the board and department's ongoing efforts to design and implement a truly integrated statewide system of accountability and support.
We recommend authentic engagement with stakeholders in advance of your November meeting around the issues of chronic absenteeism.
Secondly we're also concerned that
The local indicators are being neglected both at the state levels and in local implementation.
The holistic and multidimensional promise of LCFF and LCAP accountability system is largely built on these indicators, but they remain essentially unchanged despite assurances that they were interim measures.
Therefore, we urge the board to direct staff to develop options beyond the not met for two years provision that would incentivize LEAs to meaningfully implement the local indicators.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Doug McRae, a retired educational testing measurement specialist from Monterey.
The recommendations for the five technical revisions for the fall dashboard that were just discussed are all okay as far as I can see.
I submitted brief notes on these five revisions to your electronic folder last week.
My general comment is that California's new accountability system is still in an early stage of development, that multiple measures framework is okay, but it suffers from lack of maturity for many of the indicators that feed into that framework.
I was pleased to hear concerns from the accountability staff this morning on the quality of the data in many cases.
It's likely to be 2020 before California has a robust statewide accountability system due to the quality of the currently available indicator data.
Thank you.
Good morning, Roberto Vida Montes with the Learning Policy Institute.
I would like to offer the following comments on some of these indicators.
With the English Learner Progress Indicator, LPI supports the revision to the indicator formula to include long-term English learners by providing extra credit for LTELs that advance at least one level on the CELT.
We believe that it's appropriate for our accountability system to focus on helping LTELs make meaningful progress towards English proficiency.
With the College and Career Indicator, we applaud the adoption of the CCI
And we appreciate the three-year timeline for refining the CCI.
We hope that this work will also include the addition of a well-prepared category.
Given the importance of school climate and conditions to academic success, we support the use of high-quality climate surveys for students, staff, and parents.
We recommend that California respect the use of local surveys that are valid and reliable, but that they cover some common constructs such as student safety, belonging, and social-emotional learning.
Lastly, we support the continued development of additional local indicators, including broad courses of study and parent involvement.
Measuring state priorities in these areas will strengthen school performance, offering rich curriculum and involving parents for both central aspects of schooling.
And we hope with the parent involvement indicator,
that it could be refined over time with the recommendations from the Family Engagement Working Group.
Thank you.
Good morning, Marta Alvarez on behalf of AXA, the Association of California School Administrators.
I'll keep my comments high level.
You received comments specifically to the different indicators on our letter.
We want to be mindful and really appreciative of the work that CDE and SBE has undertaken on this evolving system.
We just wanted to provide some comments regarding this system that will continue to evolve over the next several years.
We are concerned that somehow there's a lot of changes being made and so we want to be mindful we have been asking for some of those changes.
We appreciate you have been listening to the field but we're also now talking about adding you know the school climate indicator surveys on an annual basis potentially.
We're talking about adding priority number seven on course access.
So somehow finding that balance is really important so that the field really
embraces the system of multiple measures, but how to ensure that we provide the adequate training that administrators need to understand the technical details, how they can read the data to be able to inform what they need to do at the local level, how it involves their LCAP process.
And so we just really wanted to elevate those comments to the top because we want those administrators to be able to embrace this system, but too many changes at once may make them just wait for it, you know, three years from now.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Sheldon Smith.
I'm the assistant superintendent, San Luis Obispo County Office of Education, as well as with the Association of California School Administrators.
I appreciate the board's pursuit for improving the dashboard.
My fear, and with apologies to Voltaire, that the pursuit of the perfect is the enemy of the good.
I say this because the dashboard becomes more, as the dashboard becomes more complex, it makes it more difficult to convey those complexities to the field.
Essentially, it's hard to explain dashboard details when the dashboard details change.
I ask that for every change, please ensure that school administrators who work with the dashboard, that they have the user-friendly information to convey to parents, the community, to community members who support our kids.
Thank you.
President Kirst and members of the board.
Brian Rivas speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
We think the work on the indicators is coming along nicely.
I have a couple of recommendations for you with regard to the college and career readiness indicator.
We would agree with member Ortiz-Licon.
It could be made even more valuable if we added a category of well-prepared so that we could capture data on who's ready for college and career as opposed to simply one or the other.
We like the work on developing the local standards to measure access to a broad course of study and suggest that you take a look at making that indicator even stronger through the collection of quantitative data so we can see more precisely who's accessing particular types of coursework.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
We appreciate very much the hard work that's been done to get us to this point and agree very much with Member Burr about and Member Rucker about just how incredible it is.
We appreciate that the timeline now includes work on priority seven for broad course access and we would agree with Member Ortiz-Licn that it should be a robust indicator.
beyond met, not met, and why can't we make it a state indicator?
On the climate indicator, we look forward to that conversation in the next board meeting.
We think that it needs to be strong.
We need to make it clear that climate is a priority, just like the other state priorities.
And the assessment of it needs to happen just like the other state priorities on an annual basis.
For college and career indicator, we're disappointed that there's not plans to include attributes related to quality, some type of certification or oversight of the career pathway.
Thank you.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, and I'm representing the California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
And my comment is specific on the long-term English learners.
We support the inclusion of English language proficiency growth of LTELs in the ELPI.
indicator.
We believe that including this as a new metric will incentivize LEAs to address the language and academic needs of our long-term English learners.
However, we would like to take it a step further and we would like to see this data in the dashboard as well in order to have LEAs to adequately address the needs of English learners by using that data.
Thank you.
Good morning, Shelly Spiegel-Coleman from Californians Together.
We're really pleased the fact that we are going to start looking at priority seven, access to broad course of study and curriculum.
Because when we talk about it as a course of study, a course, then we're only really, it ends up being a discussion about secondary, whether kids are getting into certain courses.
And of course, a broad course of study begins in kindergarten.
And we really need to look at indicators.
You know, we're short on indicators for elementary.
And so I think we really need to look at them.
And in many respects, the curriculum at our elementary level over the last 12 to 15 years has become very narrow.
And so this indicator could really send a message
to our elementary schools about making sure that students get science, social science, art, a broad course of study.
So looking at percentage of students that have a full day kindergarten, percentage of students by subgroup that really get this broad course of study over a week's period in a school, looking at what Brian said, some qualitative data in terms of meeting and not meeting, we think is really critical.
Thank you so much.
Good morning, LeAngela Reed on behalf of the Small School Districts Association.
I want to thank the board for their attention to Smalls.
If I named all of you who've made comments in support of Smalls, I wouldn't have any time left, but I want to thank you all.
for doing so and keeping them at the forefront.
The work with CDE with the small working group, working group of smalls has been tremendous.
We do support the move to the three by five.
We think that will address the flexibility, the volatility issues.
We, some of our folks really were focused on the 250, but in conversations with CDE, we see 150 is the way to start.
But we appreciate that they're going to keep this as an ongoing conversation as they have on a number of issues.
With regard to the college and career readiness, we very much appreciate the work moving forward on that.
And the comments of member Rucker relative to the joint task force ask that as we work with the community colleges, they look at those articulation agreements, which are faculty to faculty rather than institution to institution.
I think we can have a lot more bridges if we address that.
Save our comments for school time, but I want to just thank you again for the tremendous work in this moving forward.
Okay, that concludes the public comments.
So I think we're ready for a motion.
Board member Strauss.
So I would like to make a motion, including the following.
For the ELPI, the LP, add a full count to the ELPI status numerator for each long-term English learner LTEL student who advances at least one level on the annual CELT test as detailed in Attachment 1.
For the academic indicator, delay the incorporation of the alternative assessment in the academic indicator and direct CDE staff to report CAA data in the dashboard.
For the college and career indicator, revise the cut scores for status based on the 2016-17 Smarter Balanced assessment results for grade 11 students.
For small populations, apply the 3x5 grid at the indicator level based on the number of students included in each specific indicator rather than at a school level based on the number of students enrolled and support the recommendation for the end size of 150 due to statistical validity and reliability.
And for the DASS, remove the Criterion 7, Emotionally Disturbed Students from Eligibility criteria.
Second.
Okay, it's been moved and seconded.
Discussion.
Board member Holliday.
I do not have any of the data regarding what the representative from the California Charter Schools Association indicated that there seems to be an over-representation that doesn't seem logical.
I would appreciate if the department could look into those data points and try to better understand if there is some anomaly there that needs to be corrected or whether or not that's not an issue.
But I certainly support the motion.
Go ahead.
We can definitely bring back that data.
We didn't have time to analyze it in the short period of time, but we can bring it back.
And you had also indicated that you are still looking at the current year or fall 2017 data.
I mean, sorry, spring 2017 testing data as well that you'll be incorporating.
So it sounds like what the Charter Schools Association had some older data as well.
The way I understood the Charter School Association comment was based on the 3x5 chart.
Perhaps I was misunderstood.
But if it's on the 3x5 chart, we're only looking at two indicators, suspension rate and graduation rate.
For suspension rate, we are behind on our data.
So we will be catching up.
If you can just look into that.
It was on the CCI.
OK.
We can look at all the indicators.
Okay.
Any further discussion by the board?
Not.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay.
That looks to be unanimous.
I want to remind board members to turn off your speakers when you're finished because it's causing problems with the audio feed for the people trying to watch us from a distance.
So we're now on to item three, which is the system of state and local support.
And we have several presentations on this and then we'll talk, deliberate on this as well.
So I guess the Department of Education will lead off and introduce our guests as well.
Good morning.
I am so excited to be here.
I'm Melanie Sheppey.
I'm the director of the Improvement and Accountability Division at the California Department of Education.
I heard, I already brought, all right, I was listening, Board Member Strauss.
I'm bringing the energy.
I'm really, I'm just excited to be in front of you and with my colleagues.
Today I am joined by my colleagues from SSESA, El Dorado County Office of Education, Sacramento County Office of Education, Kern County Office of Education, CCEE and WestEd.
We are here to provide the board an update on the statewide system of support and specifically thinking about the support that's already underway for the 2017-2018 school year.
Thinking about the 2017-2018 school year, many of you know California's teachers and students have already started.
And last time I was up here, I promised I would get in some of my Greenleaf Scholars.
So the picture you see on the screen is a representation of the Greenleaf Scholars.
They are already celebrating growth and progress, even though they've been in school for a month.
As many of you know, the summer slide, every second counts.
So I just wanted to orient us in the urgency that I know you all feel about making sure we're providing support for our districts and schools.
And it's with this sense of urgency and requests from board members and the public that today we're going to focus on the support that is already underway for California's districts and schools.
We'll begin with discussing the shifts in California's approach to improvement, what we've learned from previous school and district change efforts, and the stakeholder feedback that we've collected from district teams in August.
Then we'll discuss the features of the California system of support, which you will hear mentioned and weaved throughout the specific presentations from my colleagues.
We have further developed the larger framework for support, given your feedback and your discussion at the July State Board meeting.
continued stakeholder feedback, and the collaboration through the cross-agency team.
However, for today's presentation, that's not the focus.
I wanted to make sure we brought together teams from across California to showcase and highlight the support that's already underway.
I've worked very hard to make it a quick, seamless transition.
And hopefully, all of our prep has paid off.
Thanks, Melanie.
So, good morning, President Kirst, members of the State Board, Chief Deputy Price.
I'm Jason Willis with the California Comprehensive Center at WestEd.
We're helping to facilitate the design and cross-agency collaboration around the system of support.
So, as Melanie has mentioned, today is about what will be happening in the 17-18 school year to support our LEAs.
that are in need of technical assistance.
So before my colleagues dive in a little bit deeper, I want to take a moment to put today's conversation in context.
Over the preceding months, there's been a growing crescendo about the system of support, what it is and what it'll do.
Today's presentation and associated board item offers further definition.
And I would also caution that while we seek to know exactly what it will be, that we not lose sight of what experience and research tells us, that building this system of support reflective of our LCFF principles will be neither easy or expedient.
The stated goal for the system of support is the first signal of this magnanimous shift that is required of anyone that would label themselves as a support provider in California's public education system.
Many of the key phrases you can see in the goal statement, building capacity, sustaining improvement, effectively addressing inequities, echo the spirit of LCFF, but more importantly suggest that practitioners and the support providers that support them are engaged in continuous improvement.
This term of continuous improvement has been frequently used in our vocabulary over the last couple of years.
In fact, the July state board items mentioned the term nearly three times.
A small if not powerful signal that this is the way that we want to achieve improvement for all 6.2 million of our kiddos in California.
And as a former senior district leader, I've wrestled a lot, as I know many of my colleagues have, between taking the time to build a system that will endure and addressing the urgency that students currently do not have access to the opportunities that they deserve.
An important understanding is that when continuous improvement is implemented well, both of these outcomes are achieved.
Just not in the manner that we collectively know today.
A small example of this is the data by which we use to establish an answer to the question, are we improving?
While the dashboard offers us the summative long-term trend necessary for California schools, we understand that it's inadequate to determine progress on a week-to-week basis in our classrooms, on a month-to-month basis in our schools, in our central offices.
Hence, our conversations must evolve from simply looking at summative measures to defining, collecting, and analyzing, and responding to interim measures that surface the progress on a much more rapid basis.
As a closely associated term of capacity is used with our discussions of this system of support, it may perhaps suggest that studying and understanding the way that adults are changing and growing their mindsets, skills, and abilities is a place to pay attention to.
So Follin recently mentioned in a report that he released, quote, we know we don't want in this state.
The shifts that you see on the screen affirm what we are moving away from on the left-hand side and articulates what we want in the future.
While it's easy and elegant to put this on a screen, this work of making this shift cannot be understated.
Einstein says it best.
Significant problems we face today cannot be solved at the same level of thinking in which they were used to create.
In that spirit, let me take a moment to just expand on some of these shifts.
Number one, the first shift speaks to the way in which support providers approach, engage, and interact with LEAs.
As you will hear later, there's an acknowledgment that these relationships between support providers and LEAs need to evolve significantly.
The second shift is illustrative of moving away from the structures of previous state intervention programs such as IIUSP, HPSG, and SIG.
This shift entails support providers generate garnering empathy for the challenges and complexities that local practitioners face, and taking this stance appropriately leads to key challenges and opportunities that are at the heart of what matters most for our local communities.
I want to touch for just a moment on Attachment 1, which was a review that many of my colleagues did at WestEd around the research and evidence of previous improvement efforts here in California.
Overall, our survey of evaluation and research reports have shown a positive impact, but not one that has been sustained over time.
Again, I will reference you back to our goal around sustained improvement.
In fact, often many small advantage that was demonstrated during the program participation dissipated after program completion.
Flowing from this are several recommendations of particular note.
You can see on that first recommendation that one, it's a recognition that our school systems are dynamic and complex webs of interactive loops rather than compartmentalized units following clear chains of command.
Hence, we must acknowledge that reality and shape the approach accordingly.
And the second recommendation takes me to the analogy of Goldilocks, that striking the balance is really essential here in understanding that we need to be able to customize to the needs of our LEAs, but understand that if we are going to grow as a system in California, that we need to be able to surface and bring along with us lessons that can be applied across these other systems.
So in addition to what we can learn from research and from previous efforts, we also know that local educators and stakeholders have lived experiences that inform what they need from our system of support.
So, in addition to the last CPAC meetings, we also collected feedback from district teams throughout August.
And we tried to identify teams that have been a part of improvement efforts in the past or potentially could be a part of improvement efforts in the future.
The purpose of these stakeholder engagements was not only to talk about what does support mean to them and what will they need, but also to review and reflect on the overall California accountability and continuous improvement system.
You'll be able to see parallels between the research that Jason just did a quick overview on and the shifts and change efforts with what stakeholders are saying they need.
Just a few bullets on this slide about that.
One interesting thing that we wanted to do in August was pilot different ways of getting stakeholder feedback.
So we partnered with Kern.
Thank you so much, Kern.
And we did a hybrid in-person virtual feedback session where my staff were beamed in virtually to
Kern County in one of the meetings they had and they were able to get feedback from over a hundred leaders in the different Districts in Kern County.
We really wanted to use August to pilot some different ways of getting feedback So then over the next three months we could make sure that we're doing we're using as many different innovative methods as possible and are Doing it in collaboration with other agencies so that we can build that relationship I now have such a strong I have a stronger relationship with Kern and both organizations got to hear that feedback It wasn't just you know CDE and
isolation.
So moving forward, we'll build off what we learned from the August sessions to create a broader approach that continues to partner with other agencies.
We will make sure that we engage with teachers, families, and community members in addition to staff at schools and districts.
And ideally our questions will evolve and we'll be able to ask folks, so how is it going?
How is the support that you're engaged with working?
And be able to use that as a feedback loop so that we can continue to make sure our support is responsive.
I also look forward to working with other agencies.
Many have already reached out to talk about how we could do something collaborative in the upcoming months.
So, another part of the framing that I want to briefly discuss are some of the elements that the cross-agency scene has started to develop.
You can see four of them listed here.
I want to focus primarily on bullets three and four.
So, part of the development of this, one, is derived from statute, two, is derived from the conversations that these cross-agencies
teams have been having about what's going to be necessary, again, holding that balance between being able to create customization for our LEAs, but also able to create a standardized approach, particularly in some of the early goings of things like, for example, pathways to support and assistance, that initial outreach to LEAs.
So when we think about needs assessment analysis of our student outcomes, one of Peter Senge's quotes actually comes very closely to mind when thinking about this.
That more often than not, as a system's efforts makes underlying structures clear through a needs assessment, members of the group that are involved in trying to identify those needs have met moments of despair, vulnerabilities, limited understandings, infallibilities about what's happened in the past.
But actually, things are getting better.
People see formally undiscussable problems rising to the surface, suddenly being put on the table for a pretty honest conversation.
And they realize how their old beloved ways of thinking about their system and their work have actually created the current problems, and discover that clearly there's an issue to be addressed, and that those around the table are the start of making steps towards that progress.
The fourth bullet as it is, the support to districts and schools to improve student outcomes.
This is clearly the heart of this system.
And I want to make two points on this fourth element.
And again, my colleagues will expand on some of this work a little bit later in the presentation.
Number one, that as has been implied through the goal characteristics and shifts and support, that we should not and cannot be our typical version of stand and deliver training.
It requires more of both those supporting our practitioners and the practitioners themselves.
And second, that LEA's needs, very significantly intense, the type, function, design, and delivery of the sport are going to look different across our LEAs.
And to note that this is not something that we are particularly good at here in California.
So having recognized that need, we know it is an issue, we are going to have to be able to take it head on.
And therefore, that we need to try some ways in which to provide this differentiated support, observe what that progress looks like, then rigorously assess how to get better at it.
That we're not going to be able to take and bite off the entire apple, but if we start in a place and see what we learn working together collectively, that progress will come sooner than we think.
Now, I know you love hearing me and Jason.
We went over this presentation many times on our commutes, Tom.
It's true.
But sadly, we will now step aside.
And we want to create the space for our colleagues across California to share and highlight what their actual work looks like for the fall.
Throughout the presentations, you'll see evidence of the shifts that Jason mentioned in the beginning and the elements of support that he talked about later.
First, we'll have Peter Birdsall and Ed Manansala discuss the county office coordinated approach to support.
Then we'll have Mary Barlow and Dave Gordon, and each of them will highlight the work of their county office of education.
Then Socorro Shields and Stephanie Gregson will come up to discuss the focus of CDE and CCE.
At the end, you will have me again, but this time not with Jason, it will be Socorro.
Socorro and I will discuss the next steps for the cross-agency team, and then open it up to any questions to you.
So, first up, can I please have Peter Birdsall and Ed Manasalla.
Make sure I know how to run this.
Yep, great.
Well, thank you, Peter Birdsall, Executive Director of CCESA, the County Superintendents Association.
I was asked just to give a real quick flyby on the collective effort of the County Superintendents to support implementation of LCAP and LCFF.
The first two items you see there are actually now institutionalized as part of the system.
As you know, LCFF was not just a new accountability system, but it was a whole new funding system.
And districts and counties needed a way to project what their revenues would be.
It was the CBOs from the counties that worked with the Department of Finance, Department of Education, developed what's now called the LCFF calculator.
That is now embedded in FCMAT.
They maintain that as a mechanism to project the revenue as part of the budget fiscal process.
We also annually develop the LCAP approval manual, which is more of a technical document.
It's not the continuous improvement discussion, but it's what's required of the LCAP, what are the expectations, what are the criteria for review and approval.
We update that regularly and share it with districts, parents, community groups, etc.
So, there's a common understanding.
14-15 was a difficult year for us, to be honest, because counties were expected to repurpose some of their funding to support this effort.
But at the same time, the law required that we continue spending money on some of the existing categoricals.
So, that created some tensions, you can imagine.
Fortunately, by 15-16, that was largely resolved and every county was able to start
hiring the staff, putting in place the support systems for their school districts.
So that set us up fortunately for 16-17, which was a critical year because that's the year the State Board adopted the rubrics and the dashboard and the revised template.
I think the key thing for my part of the presentation is that the counties view it as their responsibility to work with and support every school district in the state, train them on these requirements, support them through the process.
So, we're the ones that reach to every school district.
So, what we did to support that is we did four full days of training.
These are not repeats, not the second same as first.
They built on each other so you got a deeper and deeper level of collaboration and understanding.
It says here all county offices are 51 county offices of education to review and approve school district LCAPs.
So, we made sure there were teams there from every one of those 51 counties.
So, they were all there for all those meetings to work together going through that process.
The material was collaboratively developed, not only among the counties, but also was reviewed in advance with staff from the State Board and the Department.
And in fact, staff from the State Board and the Department helped with some of the presentations.
And then finally, CC, we're really happy they were able to fund some county lead in each county, in each region rather.
to support work across the 11 CCESS regions and also help with communications between the local level and the state.
So now moving to 17-18, obviously technical assistance.
We all know now that the requirements are going to come into play for counties to provide technical assistance.
We are extremely supportive and pleased with the cross-agency strategies put in place as being facilitated by state board staff.
It's really helping bring people together in terms of a clear communication and plan for supporting this.
Like everybody else, we're trying to make sure we make the move from a compliance mindset to continuous improvement.
So, the workshops we're doing this time is sort of an operating system here now.
We're doing workshops over several months, three of them, September through January.
All the counties are involved, we also have school staff involved and also CC, State Board, Department, etc.
focusing on continuous improvement and what does that mean.
Carnegie Foundation is helping us on that because they have a strong track record of applying improvement science to K-12 education systems.
And these workshops are co-sponsored by CCE.
So the idea of collaboration, all counties reaching all school districts, I think we now have a system in place to support that model.
So I was asked to, like I said, do a flyby.
I'll be happy to answer more questions, but I'd like to turn now to Ed Monticella from El Dorado County.
Thank you.
They're convened by the State Board of Education, but it's a staff, State Board, Department of Education, CCESA, CCEE, and WestEd.
So those are the organizations that are working together collaboratively to make sure we have a system of support for all the different, as Sue mentioned, diversity of school districts out there.
Good morning, President Kirst, members of the State Board of Education and Chief Deputy Glenn Price.
My name is Ed Madonsel.
I'm the County Superintendent of El Dorado County.
And this morning, I'm just going to briefly share with you how in El Dorado County we're shifting our delivery and support system with our districts.
And I do want to note that County Superintendents Dave Gordon and Mary Barlow will provide a greater detail of how counties are delivering a comprehensive support system in the midst of the change.
So just to provide greater perspective and context, in El Dorado County, there are 15 school districts.
We do have multiple small districts with 100 students or less and districts that are in the thousands.
You can picture El Dorado Hills on the western part of the county to South Lake Tahoe.
and we're very diverse in nature.
Back in 13-14 when LCFF was being implemented, there was just some overarching questions that were being raised amongst our leaders and schools.
So one in particular was how are we best going to use the LCAP to continue with the areas of improvement that we focused on.
So
For example, Chris Hoffman, current superintendent in Elk Grove, was the superintendent at Eldorado Union High School District at the time, and he saw that as an opportunity to focus on a few goals, on the areas that they were already zeroing in on.
Yet, with that said, there was still that sense of ambivalence and ensuring that districts were aware that we are going to go through a process
But how do we continue to maintain a steadfast focus on improving instruction and learning during these entire shifts?
So a lot of change was occurring during that time.
We did see, even in the first two years of implementation, a focus on achievement, specifically around math and ELA.
But even most recently, themes that we're seeing in our LCAPs are now starting to focus around social-emotional learning.
and how can we provide greater comprehensive supports around our students with needs ultimately to achieve higher levels.
When we look at the change over the last four years, it is very complex.
And while we could look at change from LCFF and the implementation of LCAP, we want to give you a sense of what change looks like even at the leadership level in El Dorado County.
So when I began at the county office in June 2013 to today, there are 11 new district superintendents out of the 15.
So there's significant change that we're talking about around our system, but also with the leaders, which then leads our county office to raise the question, how do we create a collaborative support structure that could manage even leadership change
in the midst of this complex change, which then led to even an example around the implementation of Common Core, specifically around math.
So while we were implementing LCAP in 13-14 and providing that training, there was a discussion around, are we going to move, again, a complex system of districts that feed into each other?
How are we going to approach integrated math or traditional math?
And that was a very hot topic.
What became evident is we did not have the learning support structure or collaborative structure to go in depth.
But LCFF, through this dialogue around the transformation of
change and support around our districts has led us to a rural professional learning network where we meet across our districts once a month.
And that has been a great place to identify problems of practice.
And the most recent problem of practice that we've been working on this last year is the improvement of math instructional strategies and looking at mindset.
So with that said, let me conclude.
You know, when I was a principal or a district superintendent prior to LCFF, there were times where I felt like I was shielding or buffering classrooms or schools from a punitive accountability standpoint in order that they can focus on just deep collaboration and focusing on instruction and learning.
In contrast, last week after our Rural Professional Learning Network,
We had a superintendent by the name of Marcy Guthrie who said, I'm very thankful for these new collaborative support structures across districts because it allows me to look at some of the most challenging problems of practice in a safe environment.
So I think we are on track as a state and it's reflected in our county.
Thank you.
Good morning, members of the board, Dr. Price.
I am Dave Gordon, the County Superintendent in Sacramento County.
And first of all, I want to give a shout out to your staff at the State Board, the CDE staff, the CCE staff, the CESSA staff,
They have created a tremendous collaborative environment of problem solving to get to this point in shaping the system of support.
There's a long way to go to perfect it, but I think they have served you well in creating the climate where it can be developed.
It's been a very, very collaborative process.
And I remember back to when we talked about standards implementation two or three years ago, they've done exactly the same thing.
with that and Tom Adams and all of his staff and Carrick Ashley have done a wonderful job of rolling out framework.
So, it's a great environment.
Sacramento is 240,000 students in the county, but we have six of our districts range from 63,000 students to 15,000 students.
The other seven range from
about 5,000 down to our two little districts or 400 students and 244 students.
You wouldn't think in a metropolis like Sacramento, we'd have that range as member Burr mentioned.
So, our effort is to really support and customize support along the wide range of the needs of all of those districts.
So,
We have in the county a range of very, very strong support services.
And just to mention a few, we have customized professional development.
We have a principal credential program which trains about 80 or 90 principals a year.
We have now a teacher intern program where we're training math and science, single subject teachers, multiple subject elementary teachers.
And we just started last year a mild moderate special education credential program.
So we're trying to help districts in that way.
We have a host of other services, but we have taken the approach that the heart of the matter
is supporting and enhancing top quality first teaching classroom by classroom by classroom.
And that starts with where do you get the teachers?
How do you prepare them?
And how do you continue their professional development?
And again, the stability, as Superintendent Mananzalo mentioned, the stability of leadership
in a district can't be understated in developing and sustaining those systems.
So we also work with our districts.
And I'm proud to say two years ago, we, for the first time, we didn't change a single superintendent out of our 13 districts.
So move on to the next slide, please.
Oh, I guess I've got to do that.
Thank you.
So again, our services are completely customized to schools.
And as you can see on this slide, we focus on empowering continuous improvement in each school community because we think not just of the school district and its staff, but the whole community around the school district and how can they work in support.
And I'll get to
And I'll get to that in a moment.
So again, we lead with a sustained focus on improved teaching and learning in the classrooms.
We have a sophisticated data system.
Each of our districts has bought into the core
data system so we have an enhanced data system which uses the state data but can go beyond that to assist our districts.
Community-based services and resources are very much taken into account.
and we have a collaborative learning network of superintendents and other staff within our county.
But I hasten to say, and this is an issue that's come up a number of times, a number of our districts are fruitfully engaged with other providers, other statewide networks, and receive support from all over the state.
And that's a great asset to us
because that learning that they get feeds back into helping our other districts within our county and also within our region, the 10-county region around Sacramento.
And I should point out one of those networks is the Labor Management Collaborative, which has brought some tremendous ideas to us.
And once again, we lead with promoting high-quality teaching and learning.
And the final slide I'll mention is we decided based on our strong focus on equity that we would create a unique pilot in our county with our most needy community, which is the Robla School District, which is a district of about 2,100.
of our most needy students in the county and with strong support from our county board of education and encouragement from them, we've created a pilot which is founded on let's do whatever it takes.
to help the youngsters in this district be successful.
And what that speaks to is the need for a powerful set of support services.
So we partnered with the United Way and a host of other community partners.
And we're also working on health, nutrition,
housing, tutoring and a variety of other services that are brought to the district.
But again, as you see in Robla's LCAP goals, the core is top quality classroom instruction.
So I will stop there and turn it over to Mary.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate the opportunity to be here, President Kirst, Deputy Price, and of course, distinguished members of the board, so many of you that I've had an opportunity to observe.
Being a part of this cross-agency collaborative has really made a difference to the work in Kern County.
We've learned so much in a very short period of time.
What I want to do today is frame for you a little bit about Kern County first,
and so that you can understand our model and how it was arrived at.
Kern County is the third largest county in California.
It covers 8,000 square miles.
We have 47 school districts.
Some districts have as few as eight students.
Some districts are the largest high school district in the state, Kern High School District, the largest elementary school district, Bakersfield City School District,
with over 38,000 students.
So we're talking about a wide range.
We are a microcosm of the state of California.
We have very rural districts, we have urban districts.
We serve over 185,000 students, K-12.
Of those students, about 72% are eligible for free and reduced lunch, so they have some low income issues that they bring to school, some real challenges.
In addition to that, 22% of our students are English language learners and we know that in over 20 of our districts have unduplicated counts of over 85%.
We have the eighth largest population of foster students in our county, so it is a very challenging
demographic, but more importantly, because we're so widespread, we have to look at it a little bit more creatively in how we support those school district superintendents.
Keep in mind of those 47 school districts, 21 of them have fewer than 1,000 students,
14 of those superintendents also serve as principals.
So that means the structure that our county office prepares to support those situations will look very different than it might in another county office.
Okay, that is also why there is such an urgency.
You might look at the data from the recently released CASP results, Smarter Balance, and you can see very clearly on the California School Dashboard that we have a long way to go.
Our gap is greater than the rest of the state of California, and we have a sense of urgency, and we do not want to waste a year.
We really want to see some great progress for our students.
And so we are embracing and learning from our colleagues across the state.
We've spent a lot of time in other county offices, finding out what they're doing and taking it back to our office and making it work for us.
Since 2014, we began hosting workshops really focusing on what is authentic community engagement?
How do we bring in the voices that are not traditionally heard at the table?
How do we hear from parents who have students with disabilities, English language learners, those folks who are low income who cannot come to school during regular working hours and really need support?
So we focused quite a bit on that as well as transparency with the ultimate goal
of improving student engagement and student outcomes.
To do that, we assigned teams.
So we took three different approaches.
We assigned former superintendents who are retired to work with school districts.
We have about five of them, so essentially 10 apiece.
And they work with them on policy issues as well as parent engagement and community engagement issues.
We have a fiscal person who works with our school districts related to actually making sure the dollars are going to the students that they are intended to go to.
So really making sure that those services are additional and improved for those students.
The final thing is we put a curriculum expert in place for each and every school district.
So that team of three works with school district leaders.
We went out to the sites, met with them in their offices, looked at their school sites, and really got a clear idea of the context under which they were operating.
And so from that, we met with the 47 school districts at the time.
And we said, what do we need to do differently as a county office?
And we started restructuring.
When we restructured, we looked at not only those teams that were created because of the trusting relationship that would happen over time, but we looked at how we delivered professional development, how we delivered any type of support, and did that need to look a little bit differently?
And yes, in fact, it did.
There are some things that we stopped providing.
There are some things that we then redirected those dollars, those resources in that time to providing what the district said they needed.
Through that effort, we created a collaborative working team that looks at such things as multi-tiered systems of support.
school community partnerships, the migrant program, the career technical education division, and together created a strategic plan so that we could align all of our efforts to meet the needs of our school districts in their context.
We have an advisory board of superintendents who we meet with and at each iteration of our plan we ask them if we're getting it right.
What are we not doing?
What is it that we need to do differently?
Is this approach working?
Consistent with the message from York with the State Board of Education and in working in alignment with the CDE and with CCE as a pilot, we've learned that
Similar to what Fullen has said, we need to tailor our responses to look at a continuous improvement process.
Start where the district is and provide all supports that they can continuously improve from wherever they are.
So in order to do that, we hired Michael Fullen.
We worked with Innovate Ed.
We brought in five new district representatives, former district level superintendents and assistant superintendents of instruction who had good experience with change and affecting change across school districts.
And we assigned them to the school district teams.
So in fact, now we have an expert in change who is working side by side with the district as they identify their needs to improve their systems and align their systems to better support teaching and learning in the classroom.
That work through Michael Fullen and Innovate Ed was also aligned with cognitive coaching that was supplied to our internal team and the new pedagogies for deeper learning.
So we recognize it's not just our districts.
We need to develop our own capacity internally to be able to deliver support.
We don't have all the answers, but we sure do know that we have colleagues in the field who can provide us with answers and support.
And so that's the evolution of where we now arrive, which is the model of support before you.
So the guiding principles of this model of support is that it's based on localized, contextualized needs of our LEAs.
Again, we're going to them.
Sometimes they come to us in a large group, but we're spending time at their site with them.
We're focusing on building their capacity.
We're co-learning with them.
And we're looking at data, and we're using research-based practices.
We found very quickly that we have a lot of expertise within our county that we can call upon.
And so we now through our monthly meetings with such folks as our instructional leaders, our principals, and our district superintendents, we provide them the opportunity to share their best practices so that we can learn from one another.
And then we team those districts together.
So as you've seen here in the model of support, there are six areas that we focus on.
I'll share that on the next slide.
But you can also see that it's differentiated depending upon whether or not a district will in fact be eligible.
In our early modeling with the data from last year, we believe we will have nine out of our 47 who would potentially be eligible for support differentiated assistance in this next year.
And we want to be positioned to be able to do that.
We want to be positioned to be able to find them the resources that they need to be successful.
So building the capacity of our LEAs is our highest priority.
We've been piloting this and we've been researching it.
We did it three times so far.
The first time we did it, we conducted a pilot with three districts and we learned a lot from that experience.
A lot of looking in the mirror and finding out sometimes it's about our own expectations for children and changing adult behavior.
And then when we piloted it with ourselves, thank you to our friends from CCEE who recognized we should go through that same painful experience that we're asking our districts to go through.
And I will tell you that looking at yourself in the mirror and what you need to do differently,
was a very good exercise and that is exactly what we're going through now.
We're going to pilot it a third time here this fall with our internal programs, meaning our student programs, alternative education, special education, to learn to really facilitate that practice and have empathy with our districts.
And what that means is we're better prepared now in the fall with the release of the dashboard than in January to start that practice with all of our school districts that are identified as eligible and those who choose to.
You might notice on that prior model that it had support in all those six areas which you see on the screen in front of you.
It is expected that our office will be providing a level of support to all 47 districts in those categories.
It will be more intense if they're eligible.
It is expected that all members of the professional learning team within our office, whether it be the management consultant working on policy, whether it be somebody helping with finance, or whether it be somebody delivering professional development, bases it upon the needs of the district.
That the district has self-identified and that data demonstrate are absolutely needed.
So we're really coming alongside the districts, we're working with them as partners, and we expect that co-learning to really be productive.
Anecdotally, I want to share a few comments and then I'll wrap it up.
Things that our district superintendents have said.
This feels like PLCs for superintendents.
It seems like all 47 of our districts are different schools and we're working together as one district.
They feel like they're not competing against one another, but in fact, they're competing against themselves to improve.
They enjoy learning from one another more than having someone else come in and share with them, so it's somebody who's in the same boat.
And they like pooling their resources, particularly our very small schools, so that they can bring in outside experts, and that's what we hope to facilitate.
And at the end of the day, no matter where a child lives, no matter what circumstances they were born in, we want them to be successful, productive, and contributing citizens.
And that's our goal in Kern County.
That's my summary.
Good morning President Kirsch, Board Members, Chief Deputy Price.
My name is Stephanie Gregson and I've been working at the California Department of Education for the past 15 months as the Director of the Curriculum Frameworks and Instructional Resources Division.
Prior to this I was a K-12 Director of Curriculum at a local school district and a K-8 Principal.
I'm extremely honored and privileged to discuss the support CDE is providing to our local education agencies.
I'd like to start with looking at the various resources, strategies, and support CDE provides with the focus on improving instruction for all students.
Particularly, CDE supports tailored to locally identified needs and support using a collaborative approach.
Now, it would be impossible to display all of the support CDE provides as it is an exhaustive list.
Instead, I'd like to focus on just a few of the supports in the area of staffing, teaching and learning, and climate that are directly affecting the classroom to improve instruction.
We all know the benefits, as researcher Jim Collins would say, of having the right people on the bus.
In other words, quality teaching, quality staffing, can lead to a positive impact on student success.
CDE helps local education agencies engage their teachers and administrators in increasing their professional knowledge.
Among our many resources, the Quality Schools Framework is just one that offers timely, vetted tools and practices to guide effective planning, policy, expenditure, and instructional decisions at all schools and districts.
Topics can include assessment, culture and climate, curriculum, equity, family and community, engagement, instruction, leaders, professional learning, resource alignment, and teachers.
Something that is near and dear to my heart is the area of teaching and learning.
CDE provides guidance on the implementation of the California state standards through many avenues but most specifically the curriculum frameworks.
CDE offers many resources and professional learning opportunities to help teachers and administrators glean the knowledge of the curriculum frameworks and enhance their instructional practices.
CDE also supports districts in their decisions of adopting instructional resources that are aligned to the state standards and curriculum frameworks and that would best meet the needs of their students.
We know the climate within each school can be critical for student success.
There are many layers that contribute to climate.
The spectrum ranges from school attendance, student engagement, to expanded learning opportunities.
CDE offers hands-on support for school attendance through prevention, early identification, and intervention.
Support for high-quality expanded learning opportunities is also provided by the CDE, working in conjunction with our local and regional partners.
This was an extremely small and brief sampling of the support CDE offers.
The array of current CDE support offered to all local education agencies focuses on improving student performance at the local education and school level.
That includes recognition of success and the ability for our LEAs to share promising practices while complementing and supporting the local planning and accountability process.
At the beginning of this year, CDE realized the potential of realigning the divisions and branches to enhance coordinated support and model after how school districts are organized.
The realignment afforded CDE the opportunity to engage in collaborative practices to provide integrated and coordinated support to our local education agencies of California.
The realignment was realized on July 1st, 2017.
However, the realignment is not static, but will be refined through a defined continuous improvement process.
I am personally excited about the realignment for many reasons, but I'll briefly talk about two.
First, the realignment provides the opportunity for all divisions that affect teaching and learning to work collaboratively together and provide cohesion in our work.
This means that special education and expanded learning have joined the teaching and learning support branch.
Second, the realignment has allowed me to co-lead the CDE team that is engaged in a continuous improvement practice to ensure our coordinated and integrated support to our local education agencies can be as successful as possible.
Finally, CDE's goal is to consistently provide support that impacts teaching and learning through integrated support.
The LCAP, LCAP addendum process, and the dashboard are tools that allow the CDE to participate in internal continuous improvement process that mirrors that of which we are expecting our local education agencies to engage in.
CDE will take specific steps internally to A, enhance our communication across divisions in the department,
B, develop a coordinated professional learning system.
C, engage in a continuous improvement practice at all levels to support integrated actions.
And D, align our CDE cross-action teams for coordination within a statewide system of support.
Each student deserves to live, work, and thrive in a multicultural, multilingual, and highly connected world.
California believes that educators want to excel and trust them to improve when given the proper supports.
We also believe that local schools and districts will improve when empowered to determine how to best utilize resources for continuous improvement.
CDE itself is engaging in a continuous improvement process to constantly be able to provide support and guidance to allow our local education agencies to make informed decisions to meet their local needs and positively impact the teaching and learning of all of our California students.
Good morning, board members, President Kirst and Deputy Price.
My name is Socorro Shields, and I am representing the work of the California Collaborative today.
I'm thankful for the collaborative work and being a part of it that's begun at the state level, all in service to supporting LEAs with LCFF implementation, continuous improvement, and equity and excellence for every student in our state.
You've previously heard from my colleagues Josh Daniels and Ish Rayaru details of the professional development experiences of the CCE.
At that same time, you heard the foundational beliefs that underpin all of our work and are echoed in LCFF.
With great respect for the local level, we are committed to informed and empowered engagement in system level problem solving, resulting ultimately in increased student achievement.
Through our 57 networks and 10 plus pilots, we are learning what type of unique support LEAs need to reach their goals with the expertise and resources they have or need to have.
We are intentional and purposeful.
in unpacking the way in which the individuals in that organization are making sense of the new LCSFF context and the ways in which their current skills need to be enhanced to maximize the entire effort.
This working theory of action reflects the ultimate goals of our work and reveals the great emphasis we place on the LEAs themselves, the stakeholders themselves,
solving their own problems and developing the best decision-making muscles for their organization and ultimately for the students they serve.
Our early learnings really stress the tension that staffs and communities may experience in both focusing while at the same time meeting the wide needs and all important aspects of students for their success.
Empowering stakeholders in collaboration throughout the continuous improvement process is still something all our LEAs are learning to do well.
As with our new dashboard, it is important to consider both status and change.
and to know the great strides LEAs have made while simultaneously understanding that there might never be a finally there.
We are extremely conscious of the great responsibility for this opportunity to be different and what's afforded to us by LCFF to affect every level of leadership in our school systems, including teachers, parents, and our students themselves.
We are intentional in our exploration of what work brings all of these experts, innovators, and compassionate professionals together.
that are in the communities and organizations themselves that bring success to every student.
Identifying, creating the right conditions for LEAs to find their own success is our journey.
As shared,
In this item and many previous items that you've heard, LEAs are working to focus, align, and break silos for the sake of students.
We as supporters of LEAs, be that whether we're state agencies or any other working with districts, also need to work to figure out how we come together in an integrated fashion while working with districts.
The responsibility of integration and coherence is not just for LEAs alone, but for all of us working with them.
Breaking down our own fiefdoms, our own proprietary notions, is a shift.
but an important one if we are to make this work for students.
Believing that LEAs can and must figure out their own way to strong systems, serving and supporting students and families may seem like a frightening experience.
But as we've heard today from our synthesis of past experiences in this state, working alongside LEAs rather than dictating change holds the most hope for sustained systems level work.
We have to diligently work in cooperation and in collaboration to figure out what that looks like, commit ourselves, as you heard from Mary and others, to continuously improve, make sure we are empowering and engaging all of our stakeholders, similar to the work that LEAs themselves are doing, and commit to change and be the new and improved services and leave no LCFF opportunity on the table.
So, I know we started this item talking about how we were zooming in to highlight support for Fall 2017-18.
We're ending zooming out to show you the focus of what the cross-agency group is going to continue to collaborate on and engage with stakeholders with.
So, Socorro just had the first two questions on this slide.
We have...
Really, for bullet number two, it's my favorite.
How can California encourage partnerships?
And then you see all the different stakeholders listed after that.
And so the group will continue to think about how can California encourage partnerships among county office of education, professional associations, LEAs, institutes of higher education, research organizations.
We tried not to leave anyone out.
Private providers and others to connect LEAs and schools with resources and supports responsive to locally identified needs.
The next slide continues to talk about the focus and what the work that the cross-agency team will continue to collaborate on.
Finally, next steps, we want to make sure that we're continuing to gather feedback from local educators and that what we're asking them evolves.
And that's what I mentioned in the beginning.
We go from what's the support that you need to how is the support that you're getting going and how can we feed that back into the system as a feedback loop.
We're also going to continue to coordinate and align the work of each agency through the cross-agency group mentioned earlier.
And also, we want to use an update on the system of support to continue to highlight the work from the field.
So, for November State Board meeting, we'd like to bring the Orange County Office of Education to talk about their work with MTSS and SUMS, just as an example.
So, if you have any examples of who you'd like to hear from, let me know, msheppey at cde.ca.gov.
You'll probably know where to find me.
And in that, this concludes our presentation.
I wanted to, the principal meeting wanted all my presenters to come up and have two rows so that you could answer questions from any of them.
But the logistics in me said that that wasn't going to work.
So we're open for questions.
You can ask any of the presenters that came before you.
Before we do that, we're going to take a break and let the board members get lunch, which is out there and bring it back.
So let's come back at 15 after.
So the board will reconvene and we're ready for board questions.
Let me start with our liaisons, member Burr and member Strauss, in terms of what you would want to say or questions you want to ask.
And then we'll go around the board.
Well, first, I just want to... I'm not sure people are listening.
What?
Oh, the board will reconvene.
Thank you.
First, I just want to express my appreciation to all of our presenters.
I always find it very helpful to hear, especially from our on the ground folks, the county superintendents and the work that they're doing.
So I think that was helpful, very illuminating about how their practice has shifted.
I also really want to thank the department staff and the board staff and the collaborative staff for their efforts to pull together.
And really, I also want to do a shout out to the actual item.
I appreciate the PowerPoint, but
The item was written, we went through several iterations, and I bless you, Melanie, for being a good listener and making the, I think, some good improvements.
But fundamentally, what we're trying to do here has shifted, which is the big message I think we're trying to get here.
And as I said in the earlier item, I feel like people still want to snap back to let's have a standard way, let's have a recipe, let's go into every district irrespective of whether they have six kids or 60,000 kids and tell them what to do.
And that just hasn't worked.
And one part of the item that I found especially helpful was the review of the research, which I think Jason mentioned.
And so we've got pretty clear evidence that it doesn't work to go in and try to work at the school level.
This is a preview from my comments when we get to ESSA.
Does not work at the school level, not an effective way to deal with it.
But so we need to really do something very different in terms of providing support.
And the fact that we're having this big feedback loop and actually asking folks what would help you to improve student outcomes is brilliant.
And so I'm very, very glad for that.
I guess the one thing I wanted to ask, and while Socorro's up there, I will ask the question, because, you know, I am also serving on the collaborative board, so I've had a lot of up-close and personal interaction with the CCE staff, which has been fantastic, and feel like I have a more, a deeper knowledge, as does Glenn, because the department is intimately involved in this as well.
about the work that is underway because in some ways where we are piloting, we use that we are working with pilot districts and with a pilot county office.
Mary Barlow from Kern County gave a fantastic example of the fruition of that work.
But we also have 57, I'm looking at Josh if I get the right number, professional, as Josh tries to run out of the room, professional learning networks.
So we're doing some of this work already, and I just wanted to have Socorro and maybe Josh talk a little bit more specifically about that and some of the lessons that we're learning already that's being brought to this work.
Thank you.
Yes, so the CC, those are two major veins of the work being done with the collaborative.
And both of them really start from that place of the district has to find their own answers.
So, for example, with the pilots,
that really is forming a relationship with them, understanding who they are, serving as organizational thought partners, and asking very probing questions, giving them the gift of time to step back and reflect on the work they're doing, the data they have.
the resources they have in their district, giving them the opportunity to hear from their stakeholders, questions about what's going well, what's in the way, what should come next, and really look at that information from a different perspective.
So, for example, Mary Barlow shared our work with Kern really is about they have a beautiful idea about what they want to do and it's strong and it's powerful.
And we are other voices and ears in the room to say, so when you said that, what did that mean?
What would that look like?
And just probing them further on their own ideas so they can come to refinement that matters to them and they can learn from their own experiences.
create the best experience they have for their districts and all the different types of districts that they will serve through whatever process they land themselves on.
And one of the very important things with those pilot experiences is there isn't a right or wrong answer with us.
So when the, and we have had many people from the district say, well, what do you want us to do?
And while
It could be easy to slip back into that state and say, well, clearly, you should be doing A, B, or C. The power comes in the district, the LEA themselves, seeing a way to move forward in something they all believe in, with all voices in the room, hearing and thinking about the problems they face, plus the expertise they already have.
Where are their strengths?
Where are their shining stars?
For example, a district we're working with in the Central Valley, they have in their dashboard some definite areas of focus, but they also have some definite areas of pride.
And one of the things they're doing as a result of not just working with us, so to claim that this is the CC alone really would be
a shortcoming because they work closely with their own county office and they themselves are a learning and growing and improving organization.
So, but one of the things they will do as a result of kind of where they are in the continuous improvement process is they're going to talk
to high school teachers who are by far exceeding the rest of the district in math and really unpack what is happening in here with the union and really think about, so if these are the types of experience and resources that made this group, that allowed this group to excel, how can we create those conditions across the district?
In the networks, for example, with 57 of them, they also are from the ground up.
So they weren't topics that we said everybody has to talk about, but they were self-formed in areas around topics that matter to them.
When we entered this work 18 months ago, one of the things we saw was that there were lots of emerging collaborative efforts and network efforts.
But one of the things is that they seem to be happening in isolation.
So in our framework of networks, not only are there the 57 networks, but they become networks themselves, so that those aren't individual pods of improvement, but they're amplifying and multiplying across each other, and that they're learning from each other, and that that is intentional.
That's not by accident.
expert people really doing a lot of that work, connecting them together, and that amplifies, again, the synergy that's possible from people solving their own problems.
As you heard from others before, part of that solution-solving comes from hearing what other people are doing and not to replicate it.
but to allow that to form a seed in the organization itself and be contextualized and perfected in that local context to make meaning for people.
One of the things we've all experienced is that a neighbor district, for example, as a former superintendent, a neighbor district had a tremendous growth spurt with using
And then you try and just plop in whatever into the district and it doesn't work because people didn't believe in it.
They weren't part of the process.
That actually isn't the problem you needed to solve anyway.
So it really is about what our district's doing.
How are the adults in that organization behaving, making decisions, making changes that matter to them.
And so the work of the CCE really is giving people time to think about that, to talk about that.
and connecting them in very purposeful and intentional ways to allow them to have the confidence to move forward in those decisions.
So, I have several areas.
I just so appreciate the full presentation.
So, I just want to group several comments.
First, to thank CDE and Stephanie and Deputy Superintendent Price for the reorganization of CDE and that alignment.
I think there's actually some charts out in the hallway on it.
And I think that really kind of shows to really rethink the resources
This is a big building.
There's a lot of people here and just thinking about how all the pieces work together.
So, I thought that was pretty helpful.
I did, I have several areas.
So, let me go first to the cross-agency work.
I know that WestEd and Jason and the team have been working really hard to try to bring all the different agencies together.
And I know there's a timeline and that there's some things that there, but I wonder if, is Jason still in the room?
Could you, I mean, is it, I have a bunch of things, but I just think that's helpful in thinking about all the different groups and what the kind of specifics.
And you, I think you did talk about the nonprofits as well, if I believe.
I'm not sure.
But anyway, so just a few more specifics on the cross agency work and how all that is coming together and what we're likely to see as you develop this when it comes back to the board.
That's my first part.
So let me offer just some of the logistics.
These were included in the item, but I'll kind of raise them for the sake of those tuned in today.
So the cross-agency team meets on a bimonthly basis.
They're basically on the off months from the state board meetings.
The intention is to be able to do work in the intervening time between the state board meetings and then use this forum as an opportunity to inform both the public and the board, most specifically about the progress that we're making.
As the board item describes, there are essentially two tracks that are being developed by the individuals in the collaboration.
The work that's happening for 17-18, which we'll continue to talk about even as we get into implementation, and then some of the further design work.
So when we basically stand up the rest of the system,
in the 2018-19 year, what are some of the significant conversations that we need to have to talk about everything from how the agencies are coordinating with one another to understanding how we're raising lessons learned out of the work that they're doing with individual school districts that have been identified or ones that may be on the horizon.
The other thing that I will note that I think is really important, and this is also very reflective in what we see in research and in practice and what practitioners know is really important when you're trying to make these kinds of significant change efforts, is that relationships really matter.
And one of the things that this and these types of convenings have allowed is for these group of individuals who are extraordinarily busy,
have a lot of very big, gnarly problems sitting in front of them to be able to take the time and space to think about this challenge collectively.
And that matters a lot, I know, to both individuals in the room and to the agencies themselves as we step forward.
So hopefully, Member Strauss, that addresses your question.
Thanks, Jason.
I'm a district in Santa Clara County.
Which one of you do I pick?
You know, how does it work?
Do I call up WestEd or do I pick from the provider I like?
or how does this, you know, I know it's coordinated, but I don't know who's doing what and how I reach out.
What are the logistics of it?
Yes, it's a great question, President Kirst.
So, first and foremost, WestEd's kind of role in this is really just to facilitate the state agencies on the work.
As one of the, I don't know if the slides are still up,
But the third to last slide that we had presented some of those key questions actually addresses this directly.
So in statute, there are currently, we've identified currently three pathways that LEAs kind of move into assistance.
One, they're identified through the list that, you know, everyone's been discussing and talking about.
Second, the county can say, you know, there's something in the LCAP that we would want to go deeper with this school district on and kind of move them into assistance in that way.
Or, as the case has been with some of the work that CCE has done, the district raises their hand and says, hey, you know, we need some support.
We'd like, you know, to get some help.
So currently, those are the three pathways.
And currently, the state agencies are working through those conversations, both in how they are thinking about coordinating their support to those districts with a primary kind of pass through the counties.
But these set of questions on this slide get to your exact point, President Kurtz, which is how do we think about involving the rest of the capacity that we have in this state, which
is deep and pretty vast in a way that is coordinated and is able to address the needs of districts.
Because as we've, you know, had our discussions, I think it's a fair statement to say that the state agencies alone and the capacity they have is not going to be enough to make the kinds of improvements that this board and the state is aspiring to do through the LCFF.
Go ahead then, I'm sorry I interrupted.
So just to continue on sort of parts of this presentation, I really appreciated first Peter talking about the coordination of the counties.
I actually was fortunate to attend one out at SCOE where you had all the LCFF teams from all the counties and really observed what I thought was quality professional development and norming and collaborative work across teams and with teams.
So I support that continued work.
As we know, all school districts aren't created equal in all counties and different sizes and shapes of distances that people have to travel to get the support.
So just to support that work.
And then to our three county superintendents, Ed and Dave and Mary, who came.
And kind of listening to the differentiation, I pulled up the current list while Mary was talking just to look at some names of districts that are so little.
and realizing capacity issues.
And Socorro was sharing with me that there are capacity, there's some capacity in different places, but just thinking about scale of a district of 50 or 100 kids versus a district of 15,000 students.
And so I'm interested in the lessons you're learning because people are saying, I know I'm going to be read in these areas.
I know I'm going to need help.
I've been a district that's had help before.
How is the help looking different?
And I know the global thing about differentiating, asking people what they need.
But are there things where you say, look, your English learners are really struggling, or your math skills are so low that obviously your teachers need to understand some of the content, or are you finding just a breadth of opportunity to talk about all different kinds of things?
I'm not sure which county it goes to, but I know Mary and Dave and Ed talked about all different ways you're trying to work with these
And I think that's certainly a concern for us that we have personalized support that helps move all our subgroups forward in this arena.
Thank you.
If I may, I'll go ahead and start.
Under our model of support, we know that there are six different major elements.
Professional learning.
Professional learning is all about looking at the individual needs of each district.
And we are bringing them together dependent upon the students that they serve, the specific target area that they want to improve on.
and then making space in their calendar and our calendar to create cohorts across districts.
So we have principals, a principal learning network that might meet in the evening and on Saturday mornings, they're that committed across seven different districts because they don't have anyone else that they can meet with.
within their own district.
And then they're bringing that learning to their school site students, their school site teachers rather, I apologize.
And so what we're doing is making that work for whatever size they are.
It's not easy, and it means that we have to start with where they are in terms of their knowledge and experience.
And you would be surprised.
In some small districts, we have high levels of sophistication, really very well-versed, very knowledgeable, content-rich leaders, but they don't have time.
And so getting a sub for them
to work with them and create that space and time is important.
So that's one thing.
So as you can see, we have networks, the job-alike networks that I listed.
It goes across a variety.
It's superintendents, CBOs, principals, learning coaches, English language learner networks,
and others, particularly MTSS and PBIS, and those learning communities meet on a monthly basis and that's where the embedded support takes place.
We also, during our lunch periods, because we have the monthly meetings, show promising practices from districts, large or small, and then they can learn from one another and we support
getting substitutes so that those teachers of that particular school site can go visit another school site and see it's a program in operation.
Those are just a couple examples.
Board member Rucker.
Oh, we're still answering.
I think Mary did a fabulous job.
By the way, Ed also serves as a leader at CPAG, so I just thought the board should know that.
I'll go ahead and touch on one item.
You know, I think that when you're speaking to the example of a math teacher may be struggling in a very small district, for example, Indian Diggings in our county has less than 20 students in that school.
The collaborative network that we've developed
has been the mechanism for small districts to be able to meet regularly on these problems of practice, specifically math, as I highlighted in my presentation.
But in that network, it provides an opportunity for our county office to even partner with other individuals that have been focusing on math.
So, for example, Pivot Learning has been working with us in this specific area of math.
In our meeting last week, we brought an individual who's been
you know, a master teacher in respect to math and the work that they've been doing with CORE and what they've been learning from those districts, they brought that right into our learning network.
So these small districts are tapped into the learning that's taking place throughout the state.
My small districts are large compared to theirs.
All right.
So I want to thank everybody who worked together to put this particular item together.
And I want to begin with a comment.
And then I do have some questions.
And in asking the questions, I'll be honest with you, I'm not really sure who it is that the question should be directed to.
So I'm going to suggest if you know the answer, just come on up.
I knew I should have them in just in two rows right here.
I knew it.
And similar to board member Strauss, I have many, many, many, many, many questions.
And I would have liked to have asked them after each successive panel of presenters.
So I'm going to condense or at least attempt to condense the questions down to talk a little bit about
process.
And I want to begin just, I heard a lot of quotes from school change gurus.
I want to give another, I want to offer another quote to this conversation because it's going to frame what my questions are about.
But I'm borrowing not from a school change guru, I'm borrowing from an agitation guru named Frederick Douglass.
Frederick Douglass said struggle doesn't, progress doesn't happen without struggle.
And those who would like to see progress without dealing with agitation want to get crops without plowing the field.
They would like to have the rain without thunder and lightning.
They'd like to see the ocean without having to hear the roar of the waters.
I'm glad to hear all of the work that's being done.
I'm glad to hear all of the schema that's in place.
But what I didn't hear
is what are you struggling with?
This is a significant sea change.
And on Monday, we behaved one way.
On Tuesday, we are now behaving in a different way.
That did not happen without some struggle or some conflict.
So while I did hear from one
county, here's what we're learning.
I did not get a clear understanding what those learnings were based on.
And so there's 58 counties in the state and I live in a county where I didn't hear that that's not that was represented by none of the people who presented today.
So I'm apparently going to the wrong meetings because none of the models of practice
and none of the good things that are happening is being practiced or apparent in the meetings I'm going to.
But further, the stakeholders who spoke to this board on a previous item, their head is someplace else.
Their head in particular is about how the districts are being held accountable for the decisions they are making that seem to be invisible.
particularly as it relates to school climate, or as it relates to the decisions they make about the non-state level indicators.
Those things seem to be invisible to them.
So there's clearly still a struggle about how to do this work, and that struggle is that, the struggle is the difference between the form of the interventions we heard about and the multiple ways and pathways that are being articulated,
I have to congratulate every agency, both the department and the county offices, for the work that they have done to put together the infrastructure to do this.
That's the form.
But what I was disappointed in, and I am using the word disappointed on purpose, is I didn't really hear enough about the function.
I'm glad to hear how superintendents are working together.
But what I keep hearing and what I consistently hear at every board meeting is in some way that collaboration is not trickling down in a meaningful way to stakeholders.
And so I have a series of questions to think about.
And it really is about the function and the agency that these interventions are going to be are going to be implemented with.
When districts make the decision that some intervention or support is required, what is the basis of that decision?
How are stakeholders involved?
And how is consensus developed or arrived at?
Because there's a clear difference between what I'm hearing from superintendents in these presentations for this item and what stakeholders continue to come and say and complain about.
As county offices are doing this work, one of the things that I didn't hear them talking about from any of these presentations is their own sense of agency.
There's a lot of overlapping work that potentially can happen.
And in doing this work, are they doing it as an agent of the state to do the intervention with the school?
Or are they clear that they're trying to do this because it's part of what they view as their evolving role as a county office?
That's not clearly spelled out.
What is their exit strategy?
And how are, what are the flags they're going to use to evaluate their work along the way?
Because I think capacity issues, funding, and budgeting for this activity, I heard only from one agent from CCESA that they're monitoring capacity and funding for this.
because we really don't know how different this is to think through that capacity and to think through how to fund it.
And are we tasking county offices to do things that we fairly haven't given them the capacity both in terms of human capacity as well as funding and resources to make sure they're doing that work.
I didn't hear any county office talking to us about that and they should have.
This was their opportunity to do that today.
And probably because you didn't know I was going to ask that, you probably couldn't tell them to do that.
But I want to make sure that they are having those conversations because without being mindful of those conversations, we're going to be surprised when these grand schema suddenly stop working or when they leave the school, they stop working because the capacity to continue the work was not sustained.
The other question that I have is more related to, again, the sense of agency among the stakeholder groups.
How are the practitioners, the educators in the classrooms who are carrying out this work and these grand plans and doing this implementing, how are they benefiting from all these multiple meetings and what is the plan for making sure they're just simply not going to meeting, to meeting, to meeting, to meeting
without actually having the opportunity to decide how to parse out what is useful and what is no longer necessary.
What is the evaluation schema for doing that?
I heard nothing about the different levels of evaluation, the different levels of how they are holding themselves internally accountable for the work that they are doing.
I hear them talking about checking in,
But checking in is not the same thing as being accountable.
So while it's safe for me to assume that that's being done, if I don't hear about it, it's also safe for me to assume maybe they haven't thought that through.
And then the last comment or question that I'm going to add to this is,
While it's good, you come to a public forum like this, it's being carried out on the internet.
The temptation is to always talk about the good news.
But I think it is important to talk about where the mistakes are, what the struggles were.
Because when you don't do that,
The people who are in your counties or the people who are in your school, the other stakeholders who are sitting there listening to you, they are going to feel like, well, I must have missed that meeting because that's not my experience.
And I'm saying that because, again, I live in a county.
not among any of those that did a presentation today.
And I have gone to multiple meetings and none of the modeling and none of the activities and interaction and collaboration and spirit of cooperation and engagement is apparent in those meetings.
And so I think it is important to talk about what still needs to be done or deal with the fact that people still don't trust that this process really is a shift to continuous learning because we still have folks in reality who are still waiting for the other shoe to drop.
They still keep looking above their head to see if the sword of Damocles is hanging up there or if it's been placed there yet.
And so I think it's important to talk about those struggles, to talk about those hard conversations, or even to highlight what you know the hard conversations are going to be.
Because again, not hearing what those hard conversations are, either you didn't have them or you don't know what they are.
And that concerns me.
The reason why I'm concerned about all those things goes back to the comment I made earlier.
People still have the impression this is, we have, we're implementing some loosey-goosey process where we're going to get into rooms, contemplate our navel and have a good conversation, get up and leave feeling good because we're collaborating.
But we have not held our excels accountable to make sure change happens.
I want to remind everybody
Schools are failing some students.
They are being successful with other students.
It is going to be possible that we will continue to fail the students we have always failed if we do not take time to identify what the hard conversations are, what makes them a hard conversation, and what we did to have those.
And I think when you have successive panels coming,
For me, it would be really important to hear those things.
That's very helpful.
And we'll make sure that we fold that in.
But what I also heard you say, not only just individual counties, but also overall, what's the coordinated approach so that just because you live in one county, you're not getting something different from others.
So I appreciate that feedback.
And I'll make sure when we come back in November, we have that as part of our discussion.
Thank you.
I'd like to continue the comments that Member Rucker made in that there is something.
Well, first of all, thank you to the presenters.
Excellent job.
Really appreciate everything you're doing for the kids and everything you're doing for the state.
There's something very human about this process, though, that is hugely important to face and to talk about.
And we got a glimpse of that, I think, most clearly in the comments from the superintendent from El Dorado.
We have created the system where now we can pinpoint the fact that Billy can't, in the 10th grade, add fractions.
That's great.
That's a wonderful starting point.
But the question is, why?
What's the cause?
And we don't like that word cause, because in almost every educator's mind, parent's mind, kid's mind, it's blame.
Who's to blame?
You know, we can blame Hurricane Irma, and we can blame wildfires, and those are easier to blame.
And no human is the problem.
But in schools,
In family lives, in the process of educating young people, what happens is a result of what people do.
Is a parent to blame?
Is the child to blame?
Is the teacher to blame?
Is the district to blame?
Is on and on and on and on.
Understanding that in order for this system to work, there has to be, as the superintendent said,
a safe zone where admitting weakness, admitting problems, admitting cause is the seed where change can really happen.
And without that really human
beginning point with each individual, it doesn't work.
You can have system upon system upon system and layer upon layer and this pathway and that pathway, but if I sit there as a teacher feeling I'm being blamed,
It doesn't, and I'm not willing to share my weakness, to share my fault, to share what I don't know.
It doesn't work.
School climate is critical to the success of children.
Teacher climate, district climate, adult climate, family and school together climate, adult climate.
That has to be a safe zone.
So to me, the most positive thing I heard today was when the superintendent of El Dorado said that his district superintendents, I believe, have thanked him for creating a safe space where they could speak honestly about that.
To me, that's the elephant in the room.
To me, that's the starting point.
And I'm sorry, it doesn't have a whole lot to do with policy.
It has to do with something I think is more important.
Oh, Board Member Sun.
Thank you.
So I really appreciate the County Superintendents who came up here and presented today.
I happen to spend my career in Sacramento County and Sacramento County has always provided great regional support.
And now hearing this collaboration across different counties and agencies is really inspiring.
So I do have a little bit of a different perspective from this.
So first, I've been involved in a lot of startups, startup organizations, startup schools, startup initiatives.
And there's always a pattern that occurs with startups.
First year, you're enthusiastic.
We're all in it.
We got the vision.
We're moving forward.
And then two, three, and four, it starts getting hard.
Because it's complicated and it's a lot of hard work and what you originally envisioned may not be quite there.
And so it's very easy by year four to get disillusioned.
and feel that, why did we get this?
Is this really going to work?
And question.
And that's not a bad thing.
That's not a bad thing to question and say, hey, what we started out with, is this really the right way?
So I think the pattern that I've seen over and over again is I'm seeing is occurring with our new accountability system.
I can tell you from my experience in a fairly high-performing school, it's changing conversations in my school.
The new system, I now work with my, I think I may have mentioned this before, I now work with my CFO so much more closely in the development of MyGalCap.
It changes the conversation, it changes her perspective of what we do in our school.
So that collaboration there, it changes conversations around
We may have a certain status, but really, are we okay with that or do we need to look at whether we want to grow more or not?
We look at other points of data.
How do we look at different types of data to be able to tell a better story as board member Valdez talked about?
And how do we get to what the bad parts of our story is and how do we fix that?
So I know from my own experience, it changes conversations within my school.
And I also know that conversations that are happening regionally through some of the collaboratives through the county work, it's also changing conversations at that level too.
Now,
I think that when we become, get to a certain point in the change process, we become disillusioned and we forget that there was some momentum.
And what I saw today was not just my own experience, those conversations changing, but from the perspectives of those county superintendents who came up and spoke around the stories of their counties and the work that they're doing with their schools.
So while I appreciate Board Member Rucker's sense of urgency, and I think we need to continue pushing that sense of urgency, the fact that we have folks coming together and having those conversations, the urgency is, OK, when do we stop having the conversation?
We actually do something about it.
And that is the continued work we need to have.
So the reflection, the doubt, some of these things that we're feeling,
I'm okay with, but it doesn't mean we stop.
And in order for us to get to the next level, we need to address those and move forward.
And truly be reflective and honest with ourselves.
So... Board member Burr.
Okay.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
I also want to thank the presenters.
Thank you for sharing some of the best practices in your respective districts.
And I think that it is important for us to understand that there are some models of collaboration, because even though, you know, I also have that sense of urgency where we need to get it back to what board member Rucker once referred to the unit of analysis being the student and at that level.
We also need to understand that not everyone knows how to collaborate.
Not everyone knows how to do that.
And that people are still very much in silo mentality.
And so the fact that you were able to break out of that silo mentality and actually establish networks, that's a huge step forward.
And I think we need that in order to effectively sustain any change.
I came from a school district where I was only there for three years.
It's a large urban school district in Southern California.
And I realize that the bureaucracy is very resilient.
And even when you have good intentions, great models on paper, it doesn't trickle down and it's a lot of work.
So I do think that we need to learn about what are the hard conversations.
The beauty of organizations is that they're comprised of people.
The challenge of organizations is that they're comprised of people.
And some of the work could be as simple as, hey, we didn't know how to analyze data, but now we know.
And we know that we have issues with our English learners.
And we know that we're not properly serving our African-American students, our Latino students, or these achievement gaps.
And we're going to monitor them.
And we're going to show you how we narrow them after we did this network collaborative work.
But there's other issues where you have hardened mindsets that are not shifting.
And that is the root of the problem that it is a hard conversation to have when you have people that simply do not believe that the students in front of them can learn.
And they will always focus on the deficit.
That's a hard conversation to have.
And I think that it's a conversation that few want to engage in because then you have to start interrogating systems of
you know, different institutional systems.
So I would like to see examples of those hard conversations, just like mentioned by Board Member Rucker, and then more quantitative data.
So we push through it and look at the outcome.
And I know that there is great examples, great networks.
The core districts have been referenced here.
They've done some great work.
I would like to see more of that.
I would like to hear conversations about districts that had blind spots, that didn't realize that they were not properly serving some groups.
In the item, I didn't see a lot about achievement gaps as being one of the areas of focus or cultural competence as being one of their interventions.
So I would like us to really see this through a more broad perspective.
It's not just ELA or math.
It's the student subgroups that comprise or that are underperforming in those subject areas.
So that's what I would like to see moving forward.
Thank you.
So I actually had my hand up because I wanted to answer your question about Santa Clara County.
Yeah, but it goes Yeah, it goes exactly to also the the concern that board member Ortiz Lincoln just raised and that is
I want to see this in the context of time.
What we heard about today were all of these agencies preparing for reality, and reality starts in November when Cindy releases the dashboard, right?
Because we remember...
Remember that what we've been doing up till now, and going back to Board Member Sun's comments, we've been building this new airplane.
And now we're ready to fly, right?
Because now we've got the indicators.
Now we've got the criteria by which people get identified.
And at the core of that criteria, and this answers your question, President Kirst,
In the item, and it's on page three of the item, everything is based on student group performance.
That's where we differ from ESSA, importantly.
And we say if an LEA is failing one student subgroup, the counties are required to provide assistance.
So if you're that district in Santa Clara County, and you've got a subgroup or student group that's not performing,
you're going to hear from John Gundry, the superintendent of Santa Clara County, who's going to be there to provide assistance.
And to me, what we saw here were really shining examples of counties gearing up to do that based on what they've been doing in their LCAP reviews, etc.
But knowing that this day was coming when the statute was actually going to kick in and say what has to happen.
and that the spotlight must shine on every student group performance.
So I want to make sure that didn't get lost there because it does sound like it's a lot of relationship building.
It's a lot of trying to figure out how to work with each other, but there's really
force behind it because of the statute and what the statute says.
And as long as those student groups are not performing to where they're expected to and what the levels at which we've approved, there will continue to be ramped up assistance, ultimately leading to, if there's more than three subgroups, the superintendent coming in and could ultimately, the superintendent of public instruction, come in and ultimately put a trustee there.
So that while all of this, the capacity building, which is kind of an overused term,
But creating the networks, creating the collaborative processes are leading up to that so that you can have these very difficult conversations that I know have already started and talking to people who are in LEAs.
But this fall, it's real, right?
Because the data is real.
It's up to date.
We will know where those gaps are and those tough conversations about
what are our challenges and who's responsible for improving what happens with students will occur.
So I just want to make sure, I think we kind of lost the timeline here a little bit, but I also lost the focus on student groups, but that is at the core of this system.
Yeah, let me just, since you answered the question partially, let me make it more complex.
Let's say that I want to, rather than the county, I would like to have the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence come in.
It seems to me I have that right.
So that's one of my questions.
And are they ready to respond?
Is CCE ready to respond to every potential district that might ask them to come in?
Yes, so you definitely have that right.
And that's actually how we got the 10 pilot school districts because they raised their hand and the 57 networks who said, hey, we want to try this out.
We think it will be helpful.
The short version about CCEE is we have to make a request for funding for long term funding to determine
what CCE looks like when it grows up.
And part of the work we've been doing to date is to figure out what the scope of that is.
But under any circumstance, you will get help from the county superintendent.
You can go beyond that and LEAs have all kinds of authority if they want to work with a non-profit, if they want to work with one of their associations.
Many of our networks are
associations, CTA, ACSA, CSBA, all have networks working now.
So there's, I think, a very broad variety of entities with whom you can work if you choose to as an LEA.
Yeah, I just wanted to expand before we go on your comment that
I don't think everybody memorizes LCFF like the two of us.
So in Education Code 52072, it says the superintendent may, with the approval of the State Board, identify school districts in need of intervention.
And that would be one of the ways that would trigger that if the school district did not improve the outcomes for three or more pupil subgroups identified pursuant to this section.
And if the school district has less than three pupil subgroups, all of the school district's pupil subgroups in regard to more than one state or local priority in three out of four consecutive years.
So it's subgroup based.
And it has a timeline for the school districts identified.
The superintendent may, with the approval of the state board, do one or more of the following.
Make changes to local control and accountability plan adopted by the governing board.
develop and impose a budget revision in conjunction with the revisions to the local control and accountability plan.
Stay or rescind an action of that school district because that action is not required by a local collective bargaining agreement.
And lastly, appoint an academic trustee to exercise the powers and authority specified in this section on his or her behalf.
Now, so that is our law.
And, you know, that, so there is some endgame here as well.
And so, in a lot of the dialogue as well about the ESSA plan, it seems to me people don't know there's a state law here.
It is operative and we don't have to wait for Washington to do something.
And our intervention, or not our intervention, but our assistance is coming in school year 2017-2018.
The ESSA law has a much longer string and it goes in 2020-2021.
I would hope by the time that law kicks in, we have a whole lot of experience.
And so that experience will not be revealed in this state plan, which we will take up next time.
So who's next?
Karen.
And thank you so much.
And I just really, really appreciate the district or the county stories.
And it's really giving us a strong framework of experiences that are very, very positive.
I agree that it's hard to come out and say, I failed at this.
I want to talk to you on my radio about it.
But with this whole thing, as we're looking at it, it seems like the state intervention right now, if you're talking about intervention from the LCFF perspective, has more to do with the capacity building model.
And when you look at capacity and you look at Fullen's research in his recent report and thinking about capacity in order to do that, it takes capacity to build capacity.
And we have to look at are all entities ready.
So CCESS's work in helping county offices to calibrate themselves and to build that capacity.
But when you look at, I think there's not a recipe for this, I agree with Sue, but I think there are some fundamental pieces that have to be part of this, whatever this intervention looks like when they're coming forward, whoever's going to be doing it, and if it's interrelated, and looking at, again, I'm going to use Fullen's four drivers.
So if those things are in place, and we heard examples of those today, like setting goals with what Sacramento has about learning, all children learning,
We look at collaborative teams and I have been part of the early implementer.
It's called EAPLAN last year with the professional learning networks.
And then this year we're part of another professional learning network in Riverside County.
There's a lot of power in looking at that problem of practice.
Coinciding with that, that's the collaborative teams.
You've got to deepen the learning.
And so there are constructs that have to happen.
And then finally, you're going to look at that accountability.
And I think what we're ultimately asking for is internal accountability balanced with the external accountability.
The challenge is going to be, again, how that looks in
when you're calling for intervention, what are you calling for intervention for?
I mean, the color's there, but how do you go about providing that?
What does it look like?
So I think we need a little bit clearer direction on that, even though it needs to be open-ended, because it needs to be customized, if that makes sense.
So I think that's one of the things, that we just want to have more clarity, and it's all becoming clearer.
It's just going to get better over time, but that needs to be addressed.
Thank you.
Okay, Board Member Rucker.
Okay, I do want to say just to make sure I wasn't misunderstood.
I'm not saying that the work that they are doing is not important or that I think that they're forgetting something.
What I am saying is the work, the important work that they are doing is not inclusive of all the stakeholders they need to be speaking with, or at least that's not what I heard.
And so again, to quote somebody else named Richard Elmore, if it isn't in the core and it's not apparent that's the work you're doing, you're not doing it.
So I did not, while the comment was made that they are at the beginning, what I heard is this is what we're already doing, not what we're gonna do.
I'm from the South and gonna is an important word.
Gonna means, I'm not doing that right now, but I'm thinking about it.
I didn't hear them say, and that's also Ebonics for those of you who are not aware.
So I didn't hear them say, we're gonna do this.
I heard them saying, we are doing this.
We thought about it and this is what we are doing.
So, yes, it's in the initial stages, but what I'm saying is, I heard you say you thought it through and you were thoughtful and thorough in your thinking through.
And what I'm trying to suggest is, I'm not sure you thought about all of the parts of the system that need to be agitated to do this work.
And I'm also suggesting that you're not thinking through your capacity and what you need to tell the state you need to do and need to have as support from the state yourselves to expand this work and to broaden out and sustain this work.
So while I think what you've done is great, and I realize I'm going to always have to be the naysayer, I'm willing to accept that role, I just want to remind you, you learn things from people who disagree with you too.
So while I may have to be the naysayer and say, I think you did a great job,
But here's what you forgot to think about.
The reason why we have underperforming students, the reason why we have accepted the fact that African-American students are overrepresented in special education, the reason why we forget that the FHA, when it was originally created, didn't allow banks to give mortgages to African-American families, the reason why we accept all those things is that we just simply accept it by salutary neglect.
And so,
I'm woke as I warned you a couple of months ago.
I'm woke and I'm telling you I'm going to help you wake up too.
I appreciate you reiterating that board member Rucker, especially because in thinking about just teachers and how they learn, you don't take your expert teacher that's meeting their student growth goals and they tell the new teacher how they did it.
They go through the process of how they did it and what they struggled with to think about what they want to do next.
And that also just talking about how hard the process is can also just create space for people who are struggling.
to continue to struggle and be like, OK, you struggled too.
I mean, sometimes I talk to Cindy and I'm like, Cindy, so I'm new at the board.
Like, what about this?
And she doesn't tell me do this, this, this.
She talks about how she's presented and learned from all of you and been up here.
So I just appreciate that because I want to make sure we bring that forward in November.
Chief Deputy.
Thank you, President Gerson.
I didn't want to add anything substantive to the conversation except to reiterate the thanks to everyone who made presentations today on behalf of the superintendent and particularly those very busy county superintendents who came to be with us today and share their expertise.
And lastly, I just wanted to make sure that the board members were aware of the really pivotal role that your staff is playing in this work and to thank them and particularly Dave Sapp.
I don't know when you sleep, Dave, but, you know, the
The effort, as Ms.
Sheppy was just bringing forward, to bring this together involves a lot of struggle, and your staff has been playing a really tremendous role in helping it all happen, and it's an exciting moment for California.
So, thank you.
Board Member Valdez.
Just one last question.
As we're thinking about the collaborative and it's been in existence for a short period of time, what lessons have we learned and how do we have evidence of that?
Are there themes coming across?
That would be nice to be able to hear just at the end of the day.
Thank you.
Okay, we're ready for public comment.
No.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
Who's answering the question?
Is this on?
Okay.
Good afternoon.
Josh Daniels, CCEE, Training Director in Outreach.
I will give a couple of comments on some of the work that we're doing to the lessons learned and ask my colleague, if she wants to add anything.
I think
One of the, and I'll try to boil it down to a couple of key points, one of the most valuable things we have seen so far is, and this has echoed a number of comments with the county superintendents have made and Jason Willis and Melanie and others, the value of collaboration and not just one-time collaboration, but ongoing collaboration.
And I'll give a concrete example.
Last year, we did a couple of sets of workshops, and we learned from the fall that there needed to be sort of topic-specific portions of those workshops, so we did breakout sessions.
And we very intentionally, as part of those breakout sessions, combined a county office co-facilitator with a non-county office facilitator.
while there has been interaction between county office staff and non-county office staff within counties and across the state, this was topic specific.
It was coordinated around a particular content area and the feedback we received with that was incredibly helpful both for the county office staff, for the non-county office staff, and also for us learning from the perspectives of each of those folks per that topic.
And so we've tried to sort of
take that lesson and apply it in all of the work that we're doing.
So when we're working with the networks, we don't just have LEAs running networks, we have LEAs and associations and nonprofits running networks.
When we are reviewing content that's submitted to our upcoming content library, we have review teams that are made up of county office staff, but also district staff and charter staff and advocates, you know, and even a couple of parents.
And that has been
One of the, I think, to expand who we think of as our stakeholder pool that really can provide really helpful information and cross-collaboration.
So, there's a lot of other lessons learned, but that's one concrete one I'll offer at this time, and I'm happy to offer others if there's more time.
So just thinking about that, those become fundamental principles of intervention.
And so that's the thing I think we're trying to tease out.
What does intervention look like and what should be those things?
And I think to celebrate what we're doing in California, we're being the research, right?
And so from what's happening, you're creating the framework for what can be.
So thank you.
Thank you.
And Member Rucker, if at any point you want to know about all of the mistakes we've made on this process, I'm happy to talk to you about it because there have been many.
If I may, Mary Barlow, Kern County Superintendent of Schools.
Hi.
So a couple things.
First of all, in looking at our data and how we hold ourselves accountable, we own the data.
We feel that we own the data of our county and all of our students and how they're performing.
And when we saw the disparity, the continued disparity, particularly with African-American students and with our special education population, it was the first thing that came to our attention.
We need to do something very, very different here.
That's the first thing.
In terms of accountability, because we're a pilot of the CCEE, we feel very open and vulnerable.
We invited all of our own district superintendents to sit in and listen to us as we struggled with our own problem of practice.
And that was very vulnerable.
And we learned a lot from them saying to us whether they thought we were on the right track.
But we also have contracted with and in the process of contracting with Hanover Ed to look at whatever it is that we're going to use to measure our own problem of practice and whether or not we're making a difference for all students within our own model.
So that's a little bit of what we're doing.
Most importantly, I wanted to share with you one of our struggles.
So, we recognized early on when I talked about our description of what was going on when we were delivering our initial services that we didn't have the internal capacity to help districts with that continuous improvement process.
We ourselves didn't have enough specialization in that area and that's why we had to go out and hire a new team.
to come in and support us in that effort and train us in that effort.
And we invested almost a year with this new team that we hired.
And in addition to regular work, trust me, we're all working hard too, but going to things like cognitive coaching, new pedagogies for deeper learning with Michael Fullen, working with InnovateEd and working with CSESA and CISC and other entities to figure out what it is that we need to understand to help districts with a continuous improvement process.
we had to change a lot within our own office and how we operate.
So let me tell you that that is, that's vulnerability.
And the struggle that we had inside is it hurt a lot of people.
It hurt a lot of our own staff thinking they were doing a great job for a long time.
And it was not easy to have those courageous conversations.
An example of that, and then I'll leave.
I know I've monopolized a lot of time, but we had a continuous improvement process where we brought three districts together last year.
And we had them spend days working together and talking about their services that they provide with one another and what was going on and why weren't the students succeeding.
And one particular district said,
After they looked in the mirror, they figured out that the problem was themselves.
The leadership decided it was their low expectations of students, English language learners, not wanting to have low expectations of students, but wanting to make excuses for why maybe they weren't accelerating at the same rate as their peers who are non-English learners.
And it was very revealing.
life-changing for them.
They've brought in other teams from other districts to look at their practices in their classroom and they're changing the trajectory for the kids in their organization.
So I would say that is a reflection of lessons learned.
We feel like and others in our organization have said really what we find out is it's us.
The problem is us.
our leadership, our adult behavior, and that's hard to look in the mirror.
So those are some of the most difficult conversations that we're having internally and externally with our districts.
Thank you.
Mary, thank you very much.
I want to tell you there's a Sam Cooke song that's called At Mary's Place.
So I heard, I heard in your voice as you were talking about the people that were hurt by this process.
I heard very much how you own that.
But let me just tell you, I think everybody needs to meet over at Mary's Place.
Now, I think we are ready for public comment.
So have the lineup.
Would the following people please line up.
Celia Jaffe, Mary Perry, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, Shelley Spiegel-Coleman, Rachel Mives, Carla Herrera, Lorraine Richards, Martha Alvarez, Sheldon Smith, Liz Guillen, Sarah Lillis, Brian Rivas, and Rebecca Wu.
Good afternoon, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
In Item 3, Attachment 4, specifically states that the overarching goal of the statewide system of support includes effectively addressing inequities in student opportunities and outcomes.
While disparities in student opportunities and outcomes are specifically stated, there is no mention in the state plan as to the personnel needed to assist LEAs in addressing these disparities.
There is no mention in the state plan of the need for personnel with expertise, experience, and depth of knowledge about evidence-based pedagogy and program elements specific to student subgroups, such as English learners.
Therefore, it is recommended that the state plan make the statement that the system of support should include personnel with expertise, experience, and depth of knowledge on pedagogy as well as program elements for students of groups such as English learners in order to provide appropriate and effective assistance to LEAs in addressing these disparities.
Thank you.
Yes.
Those comments seem more relevant to item four.
We're... I want to remind the remaining speakers that we're talking about item three.
So... Sorry.
Hello again.
Mary Perry from the California State PTA.
And it has been really an interesting journey as we've watched the system of continuous improvement develop.
One person mentioned the fact that November, I think it was you Sue, that November is when the rubber hits the road.
And I want to underscore the importance that in order to build the kind of trust
that we need to be open and avoid that sort of Damocles, that really communicating out and explaining what the heck a system of support is to our parent communities is crucial.
and really developing their capacity to see how family engagement is part of this process, how important they are to the process, how important they are to their children's learning should be part of that communication as well.
And so not losing sight of that with everything that everyone has to do is something that I really urge the board and the agencies to keep in mind.
Hi, good afternoon.
Carla Herrera, retired educator, and I'm from Californians Together, and I'm an alternate member to the EL Roadmap.
So I want to thank you very much for your unanimous adoption of the EL Roadmap as state policy.
However,
The plan for the system of support lacks explicit instructions that utilize and rely on the EL roadmap when addressing inequities resulting in English learners underperformance.
Also absent in the plan is a specific content of the support to be provided to schools and districts.
Any technical assistance, no matter the level of intensity, should rely on content that is research and evidence-based, such as the newly adopted Yale Roadmap and the recent report of the National Academies of Science, Engineering, and Mathematics on the benefits of bilingual education.
It's recommended that the state plan include explicit instructions and that the content of the system of support be evidence and research-based.
By doing so, LEAs and schools will have a better understanding of what to expect and how to effectively use a system of support in order to address inequities resulting in underperformance of ELs.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Shelly Spiegel Coleman, Executive Director of Californians Together.
So to kind of pull together our three comments that we've had here, Martha's comments are really about people who are serving throughout these coordinating agencies that if they're working with the districts, we have to make sure that people who are on the teams
have the expertise in terms of addressing the student groups for which there are inequities.
And having worked in a county office, I know that county office staffs are not equal.
Some have expertise, some have no expertise at all in those areas.
And so that's the kind of personnel we're thinking about.
The other piece that Carla was talking about is that we did adopt a roadmap and it has some principles.
And so I think when
Peter Bertsell talked about the two sides, standardization but local context.
So part of standardization is looking at what do we know is true?
What do we know has effect?
And we adopted a roadmap that was based upon evidence-based research and practices.
And we hope that things like that become part of what these agencies use
when they're working with school districts and they're looking at local context and how that looks in local context will be different, but it's based upon what we know is sound and what we know needs that the board adopted.
And so we're hoping that that finds its way into the work.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Rachel Mavison.
I come before you as a former teacher, state approved date provider, private school principal, superintendent, and now director at a county office of education.
I am a strong advocate of our state's direction in education.
I'd like to suggest the board consider differentiated assistance this year with flexible requirements.
Districts are being held accountable for indicators on a dashboard that are not yet fully developed and using leg data.
Allowing a year of flexible requirements would provide districts an opportunity to focus on improvement instead of shifting templates in a developing dashboard.
COEs can continue to develop a different approach to differentiated assistance working with willing districts and you the CCEE regional leads and stakeholder groups could work to clarify the ambiguity in the statute with implementation in 2018-19.
Fullon notes in his recent report that California is faced with the daunting task of shifting the mindset of a massively complex organization from compliance to continuous improvement.
If from the very onset of our new accountability system, it is unclear, lacks credibility, how are we making strides toward disrupting the compliance narrative and replacing it with a more valuable commitment to implementation?
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Martha Alvarez on behalf of AXA, the Association of California School Administrators.
In addition to echoing the comments made by a prior speaker, I'd like to commend the staff for continuing this discussion with the board and stakeholders to ensure that there's ample opportunity for public comment on this system of support.
We appreciate that there's a distinction between the 17-18 assistance that will happen in the next several months and then the 17-18 and beyond work, which is outlined in our letters, comments to the state board letter.
Regarding 17-18 assistance similar to the prior speaker, we want to encourage the system of support to be focusing on the planning time and that communication needs to be clear to the field and to the parents, the stakeholders, teachers, etc.
so that we don't expect any quick changes halfway through the 17-18 school year and instead continuing to integrate that work in planning for the 18-19 LCAP and those student services.
For the 18-19 school year and beyond, we echo the comments by CPAC and other stakeholder members regarding the customized, individualized support, networks, data analysis, et cetera.
AXA continues to be a partner in this work.
We want to engage you and the staff, and we hope you'll hear from supporting tenants in the future about what's happening on the ground and how their recipients have the support.
Thank you.
Hi my name is Rebecca Donwu credential teacher and we need to require the COEs to do or gonna do to do one of the additional steps that they need to do when they do their civil rights Williams Act County audits for vacancies and miss assignments.
What they need to do is look at all certificated staff including substitutes over a course of a year.
They need to look and find ghost teachers or vacancies that are not reported to them intentionally or not by the districts.
SCOE failed to find this at one public school, so not a charter, in TRUSD in Del Paso for 15 years, an economically disadvantaged school that I worked at.
Twin Rivers had qualified teachers, so not
So not teacher shortages, which is what a grand jury looked into for all the county saying that there were teacher shortages within the county.
That was not the issue in this case.
They were classified as substitutes.
Thank you.
Lorraine Richards, California Teachers Association.
CTA agrees with the statement in attachment four that there is an opportunity to clarify the roles and responsibilities of within the system of support and seeks answers with a focus on the needs of each student.
Ensure that differentiated assistant includes a comprehensive review of all local and state indicators.
educators need or how students basic needs and conditions in and around the school should be addressed.
We recommend asking the representatives of all involved agencies to explain how the system will tangibly integrate all federal and local components into a coherent and cohesive set of supports that focus on the whole child and the whole system factors and support equity of access and opportunities.
We also encourage the state to shed the different labels of level one and level two.
Finally, questions.
How will the agencies be responsible for providing support, clearly and publicly identify the point of contact for accessing the system, and provide the open door for students, parents, and educators and community stakeholders such that the access is not appropriately restricted?
Are there any emerging lessons from the pilot other than the CCE that are ready to be shared?
Thank you.
President Kirst.
Brian Reeves speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
We think that you've got the right people working on the right issues trying to come up with the right solutions but we'd like to see a little more detail and Member Rucker as you were talking it made me think
Low-income communities and communities of color have heard similar promises in the past.
And we feel as advocates, you know, we can go back, you probably know the programs better than I do.
SIG, QEIA, this is the latest thing.
And we feel as advocates for those communities, our role is to press for answers on how all of this talk and work is going to connect directly to moving the needle for students.
those communities.
So we'd like to see more detail on how the work translates into improvement for subgroups.
We like the root cause needs analysis, I believe is what it's called, and we think that it might be strengthened by having an external agency involved.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Sarah Lillis with EdVoice.
And like Mr. Rivas, we are also struggling with a lack of detail.
We understand what we don't want to be.
We understand the larger vision.
We understand what the statute says.
But as President Kerr said, we still don't understand how this is going to work for locals and particularly in supporting subgroups.
And we understand, we appreciate LCFF's focus on subgroups.
At the same time, how are these agencies going to work together?
Mr. Willis said we don't have an answer to that question yet.
And we really hope that the state, that you all as a policymaking body for the state in terms of moving forward beyond the statute, can provide some real guidance as to how we can get
this system to work and all the agencies to work together, not just meet and talk, but actually provide more detail to the public so we now know how it's all going to function.
And particularly, we also echo the comments on focusing on using the tools we do have, like the EL roadmap, and really focusing on English learners and subgroups.
Thanks.
Hello again, Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
Many thanks for this item around the system of support.
Really good to see that one of the steps is a needs assessment and root cause analysis of student outcomes.
Very happy to hear the conversation looking at analysis of the capacities of adults to change.
That is really, I think, one of our most pressing concerns.
Ineffective school leadership, low staff morale, the lack of staff cohesion or apparent in student engagement, severely adverse working conditions, many, many things that have to be addressed before really creating a plan of action.
We talked with staff this week and we raised our hand in terms of interest and desire to work with the department on some of the stakeholder engagement, especially as it relates to community parents and students.
Thank you.
Hello members, this is Swapnil.
I'm here to mainly raise an important point about the IQC.
It's an Instructional Quality Commission and reject the history.
This is the wrong item for this public comment.
This is more appropriate for general public comment.
Okay, thank you.
Good afternoon, Lea Angela Reed on behalf of the Small School Districts Association.
First I want to thank the department and state board staff for their work on this and thank you for the thoughtful conversation.
I appreciate the comments by my colleague Mr. Rivas relative to some of the old programs that make some of us wince and some folks have PTSD.
We still have districts that are in program improvement for perpetuity.
So, but I think the difference is that
Today, we are what you are doing with rather than to.
And I can't understate the importance of that.
Whether it be the stakeholder group that that staff are having here, where everyone is involved and everyone hears each other's comments and so forth to what's going on at the local level and in folks feeling empowered.
None of us know really where we're headed.
I mean, because this is all new.
It's sort of like being in a room full of furniture with the lights out.
You don't know what's there till you hit it.
But we're all moving forward together because we're all involved and all feel empowered.
So I just want to support you in the work that you're doing.
We know the conversations need to be had.
We're willing to have those.
And we thank you.
Board member Ortiz-Lacon.
I have a question of our timeline here because yes, we still obviously there's a lot of details and a lot of questions that we still have in terms of making sure that we have a cadre of experts that are addressing issues as they're identified and that it's experts not just general consultants or general folks that are addressing some of these very specific areas of need of improvement.
We also heard a couple of people reference some of the tools and frameworks that we have, the EO roadmap, and making sure that we mention and reference that.
The monitoring and accountability, where does that fall?
Even with the county offices, if I'm in one
in one county, but I don't want to take services or support from that county.
Am I married to that attendance zone?
Is it like a school that I need to or can I go somewhere else?
And the other thing that happens, and I think we need support from external partners and community-based organizations and nonprofits, but we could also have this
since everyone's mentioning him, innovation overload, where we don't know what the magic sauce actually was.
So what made the difference, right?
And so somebody that's also there to tease out and make sure that not everything's being thrown into the pot, but that it's very deliberate and intentional so that we could then say, this is what worked with this subgroup and this didn't.
So we can't bring that back into the pot.
So all of those details are not here, but I'm assuming that we will eventually add more to this.
And I'm just wondering what that timeline is.
Thank you.
So timeline just specifically on how we'll provide more details about what the support looks like.
So on the first piece, I might have said this earlier, but we want to make sure that we continue to highlight specific counties.
But to go to both of your points from earlier, Board Member Rucker, Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe, we also want to talk about what work are we doing to build the capacity of all counties.
So, we're sat down with SESSA last week and talking about, you know, we have all these stakeholder engagement sessions with people at districts and schools.
Have we really thought about what counties need and what that's going to look like for northern counties versus southern counties?
And how can we at CDE and the other state agencies help understand that need for capacity building?
And I think
So that's just I think we definitely could bring back maybe even a timeline of some of the work that we're planning to do to build out the county support.
But then in November and subsequent meetings, highlighting specific counties, but then also talking about how are we strengthening county capacity in general and giving counties the space to talk about what they need that might be beyond, you know, me and my team.
But I mean, you know, sorry.
So I don't think that answers your question specifically.
But those are two things we can do, and I think, hopefully, as we talk about strengthening counties' capacity, those pieces around how are they using things like EL roadmap, how are they using the curriculum frameworks, what do they need when it comes to data analysis.
Me and my team went to the improvement science training last week put on by Carnegie and SESSA and CCEE, and we talked to some Central Valley counties that said, you know, I know this is my data.
But I don't know how to pull it out.
And it was in the safe space of, hey, you work at CDE, and you seem friendly, and you're asking me what I need.
But we need to be able to say, these are some of the needs, and here's how we can meet them, and maybe here's how we can't.
And so what are we going to do about it?
So I want to be able to bring that forward, too.
Okay, so now we'll move to item four and the S.S.
State Plan.
So I'm going to make a few opening remarks to paint the context a bit.
We deliberately sequenced this agenda so that people got a feel
for the importance of state policy and how it intensifies and relates to federal policy.
And we covered our assessment system.
We covered our dashboard and our indicators and then the system of support.
So very much what you're going to hear in the state plan is something that interacts and reinforces and as best we can, given the two laws, integrates the two systems.
I wanted to mention to the board members for what we're going to be doing next because some of the very important parts of federal aid will be coming after the state plan is approved.
First of all, we need to, we will be notifying local districts that all of their applications for federal aid under all titles are defunct.
They have to reapply.
It is a new law.
The last times they applied, as far as I can tell, was between the years 2003 and 2006.
We were one of the few states that never got a waiver for NCLB, so we operated on NCLB right to the end.
So we will be developing an application process for districts to apply for their federal aid.
These are categorical funds.
They require an application process.
And that will be probably in the form of an addendum to the LCAP.
But having worked on the original applications in 1965 for Title I, I realized the application process can be an important policy lever.
So that is yet to come.
And I think we'll, you know, I just want to highlight that as one thing in this regard.
Second of all, we will be developing with the budget, through the budget process under California state law, the legislature gets into this.
What we are going to do with a set of sides that are in Title I.
and the other titles in the ESSA law.
For example, we must, under ESSA law, withhold as a state 7% of Title I. That is approximately $118 million.
Now, it's quite likely, it seems to me, that some of the system of support for local districts and schools that was mentioned today would be, could be integrated into those
set-asides we have like the 7% set-aside in Title I. We could strengthen that system.
We could decide how to work with it.
We must make all grants to local education agencies under Title I, but we could use intermediaries to fund functions the state thinks are important.
So I think that there is a considerable amount there.
Title III,
Three, I'm sorry, Title II, the teacher profession area, that has a set aside of approximately $6 million.
Through the budget process, we will be making some proposals there.
People have talked about a school leadership initiative.
So that will be, I think, important.
Lastly, there are state set-asides for administration and direct state services.
And we'll be discussing one of those today in Title IV-A.
But there are also state set-asides of 4% or 5% in the other titles.
And only 1% of that can be used for state administration.
So this is direct state services
which could be related to our prior topic of a system of support that would be available for us to allocate again in discussion with the legislature through the budget process.
So, to sum up here, there's a prior, as we look at the ESSA plan, there's a prior state context that we have talked about today
There is an asset plan and then there are significant set of policy levers and discretionary state funds that will come after the state plan is filed.
So, I think the audience and others should understand what I've outlined here, which is a tripartite context.
And on a personal note, it bothers me that a lot of critics, including people from outside the state, look at only our state plan.
And they don't look at all of this context, some of which is, in my view, the third stage of context, the third stage that I outlined is very important as well.
So, I just want to set that scene for us in terms of what we're going to see today.
But I certainly believe the State Plan is important, but that we've got a totality of policy here and we need to view this discussion in the State Plan within that totality.
And the Board has much interesting work left around the issues that have been discussed through the State Plan.
So with no further ado, then I'll have Barbara Murchison who's going to go through the state plan.
So Barbara will explain all the changes that have been made since our last board meeting.
Then we'll have a round robin of any board members who want to speak on any issue.
Then we'll have public comment.
Then we'll have another open board discussion and then we can expect some motions because the CDE will be recommending three motions for us in terms of motions that we have to take.
Board member Ting Sun, who is a federal liaison with me, will present those motions.
So that's our procedure.
Barbara, please proceed.
Thank you, President Kirst.
Good afternoon, Chief Deputy Superintendent Price, board members.
I'm Barbara Murchison, ESSA State Lead here at the Department of Education.
The purpose of this item is to provide you and the public with an update on the development of the Every Student Succeeds Act, or ESSA State Plan.
And here we are.
Today is the day that the CDE is recommending to the board that you approve the ESSA state plan for submission to the United States Department of Education on September 18, 2017.
That is Monday.
Pending board executive director approval of final revisions requested by the board and correction of any typographical errors.
So here is the last timeline I will share with you regarding the S.S.
State Plan.
We've seen a number of timelines since I first stood before you in May 2016, and this is a short one.
In July, you provided the CDE with direction regarding revisions to the S.S.
State Plan.
We made the approved revisions, and on August 8th, provided you with a new draft of the S.S.
State Plan, which I'll refer to as the August draft in an information memorandum.
And in that memo, we asked stakeholders who wanted to provide feedback on the draft to submit their comments to us by August 25th so we could include their feedback in this item.
A summary of that feedback is provided in Attachment 1.
We also reviewed information about the August draft with the California Practitioners Advisory Group during its meeting on August 24th.
And moving down to those last two rows in the table,
We need to submit the plan to ED on Monday, next Monday, September 18th.
So we're bringing the plan to you for approval today.
So here is our recommendation.
The CDE recommends that the board approve the Every Student Succeeds Act state plan for submission to ED on September 18, 2017, pending executive director approval of the final revisions requested by the board and correction of any typographical errors.
We have a few final proposed revisions.
You may have additional proposed revisions to discuss today.
And we are aware of a couple of typographical errors in the document.
So again, that is why we're asking you to approve it pending final revisions that we will make and that your executive director will approve before we submit to the United States Department of Education.
So we have a lot to cover today.
As President Kearse laid out, first I'm going to spend a little time providing some context for the plan, kind of build on some of his opening remarks.
Then we're going to go over some key features in the August draft.
Those of you who were either watching or participating in the CPAG meeting, you'll notice it's going to be very similar to that CPAG meeting where I'm going to talk about what we heard from stakeholders and then talk about
how we made revisions based on that stakeholder feedback.
Then I'm going to present the additional revisions proposed in this item.
So as I mentioned, we put out the August draft, got some feedback from folks, and now I want to talk about the three revisions that are actually in the item and attachment two of the item and walk through those.
And then we're going to take a look at three additional relatively minor proposed revisions that are not in the item.
You just received a handout with those proposed revisions.
I'm going to pause for questions and board discussion a couple of times during this presentation.
People are really excited already about that.
That's great.
But in the interest of time today, I'm not going to go over our whole stakeholder engagement strategy.
Certainly, you are aware of those four formal phases of stakeholder engagement.
There's information about that on the item, plenty on our web pages if people have questions.
Obviously, we're here to talk about that, but we're not going to go into that because we do have a lot of other things to cover today.
So first, let's firmly situate this state plan into the larger California context.
It feels important to put this document into perspective.
I have to say this morning, I woke up thinking about the day to come.
And I had a little flashback to the first time I brought a state plan to this board, and I was thinking about it.
Four of you were actually here when I presented the Common Core State Standards Systems Implementation Plan for California in January of 2012.
And I thought, maybe I'll just grab like a screenshot of me presenting to the board.
And I thought, no, that, you all look great.
But I'm not sure the last five and a half years really treated me quite as well.
So we're not going to do that.
But in thinking about this and in preparing this presentation, I think there's a lot
I think we want more.
We want this to be done.
We want all of the answers about how all of this is going to work.
I think it's useful for all of us to just take a moment, and I'm going to take that moment, to talk about everything that's been going.
This has been a super busy board.
All right, so I'm just going to take a little minute to talk a bit more about the California system.
beyond the SSA plan.
And brace yourselves, because it's been a lot of work.
You really should look more tired.
Since 2010, the board has adopted new content standards for English language arts, English language development, mathematics, science, career technical education, and the model school library standards.
That's a lot of new standards.
There are additional standards underway for visual and performing arts, world language, and computer science right now.
You've also adopted new curriculum frameworks for English language arts, English language development, mathematics, science, and history social science with additional framework development underway for health right now and additional subjects on the near horizon.
You've adopted new instructional materials for ELA, ELD, mathematics, and we anticipate that new materials for history social science will be brought to you for adoption later this year.
Oh, and California has a new assessment system.
That little thing.
With new tests either operational or close to operational for English language arts, mathematics, English language development, and science.
Since 2013, you've also been working to implement the local control funding formula, fundamentally changing how resources are provided to schools and holding local educational agencies accountable for improving student performance.
The LCFF reflects California's commitment to equity, providing additional funds to LEAs to support low-income students, English learners, and foster youth.
California's new LCFF based accountability system focused on performance of 13 distinct statutorily defined student groups.
And we have a new dashboard that reports performance data for all districts, all schools, and all student groups on multiple indicators aligned to LCFF state priorities.
That's a lot of work, all right?
I know you know this, but to write it all down and to say it, I mean, yeah.
So LCFF requires the districts receive additional support if they have one or more student groups struggling across more than one indicator in the accountability system.
As was detailed and discussed in item three, those supports are beginning in earnest this fall.
So all of this is just to say that all of this work began long before the Elementary and Secondary Education Act was reauthorized in December 2015.
And the work will continue well beyond the submission of this ESSA state plan.
Everything accomplished to date has been done in partnership with many, many education stakeholders and future activities will be done in collaboration with stakeholders as well.
My colleagues both here at the department and from other agencies have spent the past few hours sharing some of the work to come to continue building out California's LCFF-based system.
As we move beyond plan development and into implementation of ESSA, we will continue to work together to address many of the ESSA provisions that are not detailed in the ESSA state plan, such as the implementation of the LCAP addendum and how the state will collect school-level expenditure information as required by federal law.
Also, although we are submitting the plan next week, California is free to update the plan as necessary.
For example, we know that there are more details to work out regarding the methodology for identifying the lowest performing 5% of schools.
Those details and other refinements to the system will be provided to ED as necessary as we continue to develop California's system.
So I really like this quote.
I think in one sentence it kind of encapsulates everything we're trying to do.
I've been here since 8.30 listening to items one through three along with you.
And if there is any theme at all, I think it is captured in this quote.
The culture of continuous improvement must infuse all parts of the system.
And I didn't add this bold language.
This language is in, and I'm sorry I didn't identify it earlier, the Superintendent's Accountability and Continuous Improvement Task Force Report, including continuous improvement for the system itself.
That has been the theme all morning, your deep commitment to evaluating and making adjustments and continuously improving the system as it evolves.
That's key to what it is we're trying to do here in California.
So I think just bearing that in mind makes it easier to make the decisions that move us forward.
I know this graphic will make one board member at least very happy.
It also seems really important to put the amount of ESSA funding California receives into our larger context.
So here's a graphic.
This is the graphic in our item, but here it is in full color.
Here's a graphic showing revenue sources for California's K-12 schools.
The relatively small green bands on the top of each of these bar graphs represents the total amount of federal funding that California receives.
For 2017-18, which is, you can see the funding's growing, that's the one on the far right of the slide, approximately $8.1 billion of federal funds are included in California's total $92.5 billion education budget.
It's important to note that ESSA funds represent only about two and a half billion or so of that federal funding.
So we're talking about less than a third of that green band.
That's a very small green band.
I did not say that.
Still, ESSA funds are very important to us because they're meant to support some of our most vulnerable students.
So we are applying for those funds.
That's what this plan is.
It's an application for federal funds.
Anyone who has applied for a grant knows that it's important to answer application questions completely.
And those of us who have read grant applications really appreciate it when applicants are able to respond to questions in a concise manner.
In March, ED provided states with peer review criteria, providing us with an even better idea of exactly what information that they are looking for.
We used those peer review criteria to address the prompts in the grant application as completely and as concisely as possible.
To be determined is not a very strong response for a grant application.
So even though there is a lot of exciting work underway, the plan generally does not include references to work that is not complete.
There are many provisions in the ESSA that are not addressed in the template.
So we didn't provide information regarding those provisions.
And to be very clear, because I'm not sure it's completely understood, this is a state application for funds.
that describes what the state is going to do regarding the specific prompts.
It does not include information about what local educational agencies will do about ESSA.
They will tell us about how they're addressing federal requirements in their LCAP addenda.
So, these should look very familiar.
At the January meeting, you approved this set of guiding principles.
The principles state that our plan will support the creation of a single, coherent, local, state, and federal accountability and continuous improvement system, with state priorities and direction leading, and opportunities in the ESSA leveraged to assist in accomplishing state goals and objectives.
The principles also really reflect our commitment to updating the federal required applications and plans to reinforce and align with state priorities and to use ESSA resources to support the implementation of rigorous standards and the principles of equity, local control, and continuous improvement that drive our LCFF-based system.
California's state plan, I'm happy to report, adheres to these principles.
So with all of that context in mind, let's take a few minutes to review the August draft.
In July, you approved a motion authorizing us to make changes to the May draft to address both the phase four stakeholder feedback and the peer review criteria.
These revisions were made bearing in mind your direction to develop a plan that supports the implementation of LCFF per the guiding principles and with the knowledge that California system will continue to evolve beyond plan approval.
For each one of the plan sections, I'm going to share a little bit about what we heard from stakeholders and the changes that were made based on that feedback.
Two sections, before we get into it, two sections of the May draft of the plan were not changed at all.
Title IV, Part B, the 21st Century Community Learning Centers, and Title V, Part B, Subpart II, Rural and Low-Income School Program.
These sections received very little stakeholder feedback and aren't subject to peer review, so they haven't changed at all since May.
The CDE received quite a bit of feedback regarding the assessment section of the plan, mostly about the California Spanish Assessment, or CSA.
Stakeholders generally support the idea of assessments in multiple languages to support bilingual programs, and some stakeholders would like to see primary language assessments included in the accountability system, but others expressed some concerns about over-testing.
In response to stakeholder feedback, the August draft contains additional language signaling intent to get direction from you regarding the use of a valid and reliable CSA in the accountability system as that test is developed and comes online.
One of, I think, the most gratifying things I heard, I'm not going to talk about stakeholder feedback, but during phase four, we asked folks, what should happen if schools aren't making the improvements we'd like them to make?
And one of the things we heard most from stakeholders that was really wonderful to hear
There's a really strong interest in rewarding progress towards goals rather than punishing lack of progress.
We heard from folks that they liked the all applicable indicators option to identify the lowest performing schools.
And we had a lot of conversation about that 95% participation requirement for the assessments and whether or not the icon was sufficient or not.
People gave us a lot of different ideas about how to address that 95% participation requirement and how to really use that as an opportunity to help people understand more about the importance of testing.
And people had a lot of different opinions around whether it should be a five-year goal or a seven-year goal, kind of a split on that.
So here are the revisions that were made to the plan based on that stakeholder feedback.
The plan reflects the all applicable indicators option for identifying the lowest performing 5% of schools.
It talks about making sure that the identification of schools is tied to the identification of districts in the LCFF-based system.
We now have a plan that reflects our intent to use multiple icons to report assessment participation rate, different icons for different reasons.
Perhaps we're not meeting the participation rate.
And the long-term goal has been set at high status and maintained for change.
And the timeline for meeting long-term goals has been set at seven years.
Stakeholders were very interested in providing feedback on the school support and improvement section of the plan.
And as we just heard, people would really like to have more information about how this is all going to work together.
What are the roles of the collaborative?
What are the roles of the County Office of Education?
How does the CDE, Superintendent of Public Instruction, fit in?
We heard that a lot from folks.
People wanted more information around the resource allocation review and monitoring, and they felt strongly about detailed needs analyses being conducted for identified schools to help identify root causes and how that should be done collaboratively, much as LCF, our LCAPs are developed collaboratively with district schools and community.
There was good support for a regional support system using best practices.
And this notion of really identifying best practices and systems that are making gains to help people to learn from one another and creating of networks.
So, in response to that feedback, we do have, in the August draft, a more complete description of California's statewide system of support with more information around the specific activities and supports at those three levels that have been identified for our system of support, foundational, differentiated, and intensive intervention levels.
There is more information.
Obviously, we're still working out details, but there is more information in the plan.
around the roles of each one of the statutorily required to provide support agencies and how they will work with one another and the field.
There are more details around resource allocation review and monitoring, and there is a commitment in the plan around conducting local needs analyses to determine root causes.
The next section, the access to educators section, when we went out and talked to folks about it, they wanted more clarity around the definitions in that section.
We had proposed to talk about the ineffective teacher requirement later.
Stakeholders felt pretty strongly that we should address it sooner rather than later.
strong support for aligning those definitions to our LCFF state priorities, really taking it and making sure that priority one is really what drives how we look at access to educators, really clarify the distinction, make sure that those definitions are clear, and then to note flexibility afforded to charter schools around the definitions.
People also wanted to be really clear that this statewide or that the educator equity supports would happen within the context of the statewide system of support, not be a separate set of supports outside of the larger system.
So as you look at the August draft, you'll see that that has been, you know, we talked about it in July, but you'll see that that feedback has been taken into account.
The working definition for ineffective teacher that was really focused on LCFF priority one, aligning with the guiding principle to develop a single coherent system.
Really using credentialing statuses, school and district data for credentialing statuses, kind of basis of how we were going to meet that federal requirement.
Talk about how that will continue to evolve as the state system of support evolves.
And also creating very clearly stating that charter schools have flexibility around these definitions.
The next two sections of the plan, the school conditions and school transition sections of the plan, were augmented relatively substantially.
We found that these were two areas where stakeholders had a lot to say, and certainly when we went back and looked at the peer review criteria, we wanted to make sure that we were answering those prompts as completely and thoroughly as we could.
So when we went out and talked to people about the school condition section, people wanted to have more information about the school conditions and climate work group in there, their recommendations, what are they doing, how they're going to be coming up with different surveys.
And people encouraged us to look more clearly at exactly what that prompt
was calling for, which was pretty explicit.
How is the state going to reduce incidents of bullying and harassment?
How is the state going to reduce overuse of discipline practices that remove students from the classroom?
How is the state going to reduce the use of aversive behavioral interventions that compromise student health and safety?
So we went back into the plan, and people also wanted more
reference to parent engagement strategies.
That's something that we've been working on for a long time here in California.
How do we engage our community members and parent members?
So as you look at that section of the plan, you'll see that it now has information about both the school conditions and climate work group and the ad hoc family engagement work group.
And I won't read them all off, but there's a lot of information around a number of key resources and strategies that California already does, California already supports, California already has, and they will be leveraged within the system of support.
School transitions, folks wanted a little bit more highlighting around the career technical education and career pathways and how that will all fit in with the dashboard indicators.
People wanted more information about middle school.
We're one of those states that doesn't really have middle.
We don't focus on middle school as much as some other states do.
It's part of our curriculum.
Sometimes K-8, sometimes no.
People wanted to hear more about middle school.
Certainly the application calls for that.
Folks wanted to talk more about early education and how early education transitions to the K-12 or TK-12 system.
and suggested more data sharing and partnerships between high schools and colleges.
So as you look at the school transition section of the plan, you'll note that there is quite a bit more information about the work underway to promote and expand student access to CTE and career pathways.
We've added information around the career college indicator.
We've added information about the LCAP addendum requirements in folks' local plans.
They will need to talk about how they are supporting those transitions between early ed and or elementary and middle and high.
We've got more information about there about how we support middle school transitions.
And this I think was very important to our early education community.
The plan refers to P-12 system wherever appropriate.
So in this section in particular, but you'll see that sprinkled throughout the plan as appropriate to address the various prompts.
didn't get a lot of feedback on the education of migratory children section, Title I-C.
But people did ask for more details around how the needs of migratory students would be identified and what the outcomes for them would be.
And handily enough, the comprehensive needs assessment, which was finished,
in time to be folded into the August draft of the plan.
So there's more information in there precisely on identifying the needs of migratory students and measurable program objectives and outcomes.
Another program didn't get too much feedback, but we did get feedback on Title 1D, more information about how county offices support this work, more information about providing transition services for students integrating back into schools, and there was just sort of a lot of questions about what is Title 1D.
So we, because it's not something that everyone has, or everyone applies for and uses.
So, some revisions made to this section of the plan, more information regarding the work of county offices, and a little more detail around the purposes and uses of this funding.
On to Title II, Supporting Effective Instruction.
This was a section for which we received quite a bit of feedback.
In the May draft, there was some good intention, but people in general just were like, we need a little bit more detail about what you're going to do.
We want to know more about what you're going to do around the supporting school leaders, that optional 3% set aside.
I think the May draft signaled our intention to reserve those funds, but didn't really talk about what we were going to do with them.
There was a lot of conversation across the state about the importance of supporting educators to provide well-rounded education opportunities.
People called out the quality professional learning standards, said, we have these, why don't we include them in our plan as a frame for our professional learning supports?
And a number of stakeholders wanted us to specifically call out supports for our California subject matter projects.
So as you look at the August draft, you'll see much more detail in that section.
It now references all the state board adopted standards, just because we are committed to a well-rounded, rich education for our students.
So I think that's helpful.
And it does reference now the quality professional learning standards as an important frame for the types of professional learning that we will provide.
We do have more information around that 3% set aside about the objectives, the kind of a broad frame, but more information around how we plan to build out supports for school leaders.
We specifically commit to using Title II Part A funds to support the California subject matter projects.
And we commit to using Title II Part A funds to build the capacity of districts to address their access and equity issues within the statewide system of support.
And there is more specificity.
We went back and looked at the peer review criteria and the prompt.
Well, there's no peer review criteria for Title II, but again, in keeping with completeness, we looked at the prompt and it wanted to know, how are you meeting the needs of these specific groups of kids?
So we got a little less broad and a little more here, some specific resources and strategies the state employs to meet the needs of these specific groups of kids.
Bless you.
Title III, we heard a lot about standardization of entry and exit criteria.
We had a lot of conversations about that.
For the most part, people are very supportive of waiting for new reclassification procedures until after the LPAC is implemented.
We got feedback.
This is another place where folks wanted to see more coordination of early education programs with the TK-12 system.
So we did do that.
And more professional development and resources for teachers and administrators around supporting English learners.
This is something California does quite well.
People wanted to see that in the plan.
So the revisions made, we did provide in the August draft more specificity around the availability of additional tools, toolkits, and guidance documents to support English learners.
And we did change, we included preschool to serve a P-12 system.
Title IV, Student Support and Academic Enrichment Grants.
In general, people tell us more about what you're going to do.
And if we have Title IV, we're going to need some more guidance.
Can you tell us about that guidance?
So what it says in the August draft now is it reflects your July motion.
to have the local education agency sub-grant funding distributed via formula.
That was a decision you made back in July, and it says that we anticipate you to discuss what to do with the state-level activity funds at this meeting today, because that's something we didn't get to in July.
And our last program, McKinney-Vento Education for Homeless Children and Youth Program.
Folks wanted to hear more about homeless preschoolers and what kinds of supports we have for preschoolers who are homeless, more information around how we identify and track homeless children and youth, more information about the types of professional learning opportunities that are available for educators to support homeless children and youth, more guidance,
And so in response to all of that feedback, we have added actions and details regarding how do we heighten awareness around homeless preschool children?
How do we do data and reporting on these children?
What kinds of opportunities are available?
You'll see in general, we were pretty responsive to the feedback for that section as well.
So that's the August draft.
When we put the draft in the memo on August 8th, we encouraged stakeholders to send feedback on the draft to the ESSA office for inclusion in the September ESSA item.
And this table on the screen presents a summary of the feedback that we received by August 25th.
Perhaps it was 28th, which was the Monday.
Give people a little wiggle room.
As you can see, we received nearly 200 emails from the visual and performing arts education community.
And we loved them.
Most of these communications were form letters requesting that arts education be highlighted more often in the plan.
We received another 146 communications, again, mostly form letters from stakeholders who objected to the definition of ineffective teacher in the August draft.
These communications expressed concern that intern teachers would be considered ineffective under the definition in the draft and that this might have implications for California's teacher shortage.
We received a handful of communications on other topics, generally falling into two categories.
Stakeholders who thought the plan could better highlight specific programs, requirements, and activities.
And stakeholders who had remaining concerns around the accountability system and the system of support.
Mostly just wanting to know more.
So based on this feedback, the CDE proposes an attachment to two revisions to the August draft.
First, we recommend a change to the definition of curriculum frameworks in the plan glossary.
That's on page four of the draft.
We also recommend changing some language in the access to educators section on page 51 of the draft.
And beyond the stakeholder feedback, we recommend that you revisit the conversation around the Title IV Part A state-level activity funds.
Recall we had that conversation regarding how to distribute the LEA subgrant at the July meeting, but we didn't determine how to use the state-level activity funds.
So I'll cover each of these very briefly, and then we'll pause for questions.
So first, the definition.
The August draft references the core curriculum areas as defined in the California Education Code and discusses board adoption of frameworks in those four core areas of math, English language, arts, science, and history, social science.
But as you know, the board adopts curriculum frameworks in subjects beyond the four core curriculum areas.
So we propose to signal the state's support for a well-rounded education by updating this definition to include all of the content areas for which the board has adopted frameworks.
The ineffective teacher definition in the August draft was developed to align with LCFF priority one and references teachers who are appropriately assigned and fully credentialed.
This language raised concerns from stakeholders regarding intern teachers and the potential to exacerbate California's teacher shortage of this group of teachers is included in the ineffective teachers category.
Some CPAC members also expressed this concern.
Staff recommends revising this section of the plan to focus on whether teachers are misassigned or teaching without a credential, removing references to the full credential.
On to Title IV state-level activity funds.
So here's another fabulous graphic.
As you can see, as with most federal money,
Whenever I talk about money, member Burr perks up.
What you got on there?
These are really small amounts of money.
You're really gonna... As you can see in this graphic, as with most federal money, the bulk goes to local education agencies and a small amount, in the case of Title IV Part A, 1%, is held at the state for administration of those funds.
For Title IV Part A, 4% of California's allocation, roughly $1.9 million.
The gray segments on this chart can be used for state-level activity money.
At the July meeting, you determined that the LEA subgrants would be distributed via formula, and these local funds will be used for well-rounded education activities, and there are a great number of them listed in the statute, safe and healthy student activities, and activities that promote the effective use of technology.
The state will use the roughly $460,000 of administration funds to distribute and monitor the local use of funds.
The state activity funds can be used in accordance with SS section 4104B, which is coming up on the next slide, or they may be transferred to another program.
It should be noted that Title IV Part A funds are subject to federal equitable services requirements.
Per ESSA statute, before a state or local education agency transfers funds from a program subject to equitable services requirements, it must engage in timely and meaningful consultation with the appropriate private school officials.
So that's something just to bear in mind.
If you elect to transfer these funds to another program, the state will need to conduct consultation with private school officials first.
So here's section 4104B from the ESSA, the uses of state activities funds under law for Title IV.
As you can see, leaving these funds in Title IV would permit the state to go beyond simply monitoring the funds.
to providing training, technical assistance, capacity building activities to support local implementation of Title IV-A.
ESSA and LCFF share that commitment to supporting a well-rounded education for all students and to supporting the whole child through improving school conditions for student learning.
And as some would be quick to say, $1.9 million is not a huge amount of money relative to California's total annual education budget, but it would permit the state to support the type of school climate activities that many Californians believe are at the heart of student success.
Title IV funds may also be used to support the implementation of state standards if you elect to leave them in Title IV.
I know that's a big priority for our work.
So with that, I'm going to take a breath.
These are the three proposed revisions contained in attachment two of the item.
This is a good place to pause for questions or discussion before moving on to the revisions that are not presented in the item.
You want to pause now then?
All right.
Let's have our first pause.
We'll have another pause.
I just wanted to address a couple of things on the substantive changes.
So I do appreciate the change to be inclusive of all the frameworks that the State Board has adopted.
I think that is, again, our commitment to having a broad course of study.
And then also the
So on the ineffective teacher piece of it, that was the item that had the second most comments on it.
So the state's LCFF priority reflects the state's preference that every teacher is well prepared by way of earning a full credential and who is appropriately assigned.
I think we all know, also all recognize that a full credential does not equate whether a teacher is
effective or ineffective.
And for that type of determination, we need additional data points and information, including the local context, as many of our stakeholder feedback has pointed out.
Nevertheless, we're required to respond to the state plan template that defines ESSA's ineffective label, which is a negative frame.
and which could mischaracterize or even malign anyone who's working towards earning a full credential.
We have several types of credentials in California, including CTE, preliminary, interim credentials, which are perfectly valid for the positions for which those teachers hold.
Therefore, I support the change that we have made.
And I think that is that the change we've made to drop the word full from the credential.
Additionally, just want to reiterate one more time and confirm charter schools flexibility under California law for teachers who teach a non-core, non-college preparatory courses and confirm that the teachers
under this charter option are not considered ineffective under the state plan.
Okay, any other comments?
Board Member Rucker, next.
Okay, so I'm going to begin by picking up where Board Member Sung left off, but I do want to say both the May board meeting and the July board meeting were really emotional meetings for me when we had this conversation on this item.
And I want to tell you, I want to thank the staff and all of the groups that worked on and dipped their spoons
into the pot and stirred up the pot to create this draft because it is significantly and qualitatively better.
And I do appreciate that.
I want to begin by saying that.
As it relates to the issue about ineffective teachers, I'm a real stickler for terms of art.
So when it comes to the intern, the piece of paper,
that puts interns in the classroom.
Is that called a permit, an authorization, a certificate, a credential?
We want to make sure we're saying what it is because we don't want to call it a credential if it really is a type or category
of state certification.
So, when you are making this particular revision, if you could simply say appropriately, have the appropriate state certification rather than appropriate state credential if the intern certificate, if the intern paper is not actually called a credential, I would ask you to check on that.
The other piece, and I know we don't, that's not something that was really covered as well as we would like to do,
on the issue of teacher effectiveness is also the issue of distribution.
There's a clear intent that students who work in particular schools are not taught, you know, have the same opportunity to be taught by well-trained and well-qualified teachers.
And so there is this issue of the distribution question because interns tend to be placed collectively and as a class in a particular class of schools.
And so the thing that our plan does not really address is how districts would be held accountable for the distribution and placement decisions that they make with these interns.
That's not a conversation we can have here, but that does go a little bit further
with the work that I hope will happen on the accountability side of the LCAP.
Because the problem is not that we have intern teachers.
Let's be clear.
An intern teacher is just as qualified as a first-year teacher who graduated last week from UC Davis.
I graduated from Davis, by the way.
So, they're just as qualified because they know just as much.
Teaching is not something you spend a year in college learning to do.
That is a skill that you develop and grow into over time.
So, we can accept that idea, but the fact is, interns tend to be collectively placed at some of the lowest performing schools, at some of the hardest to staff schools, in some of the hardest to teach subjects, and with students who would be considered
our priority students.
And so the plan still does not really address how we will deal with distribution decisions that frankly districts make that are poor.
But I am hoping through the LCAP processes, those are going to be the schools that I'm quite certain will be identified for intervention
And I'm hoping the county, this is one of those hard questions that I did not want to, I was holding off until this item.
This is one of those hard questions that I didn't hear any county offices bringing up that they were going to discuss because that's the reason why some of the underperforming schools they have in their county are underperforming.
And I want to know what agency they have to tell districts cut that crap out.
So those are the kinds of things and hard conversations we have to have in a different venue.
The other thing that I want to say really relates to what approving this board item means.
There's a couple of other things in the action, in the recommendations you're making for action that I think need to be clarified.
As part of the process of developing the state plan, we previously approved a transition plan.
And as part of that transition, approving this board item means we then suspend or even nullify the work that's been going on in districts to implement that transition plan.
That needs to be clear, I'm hoping.
And then for schools that were in certain stages of program improvement or corrective action,
The state in their transition plan spelled out what the ongoing work districts were supposed to be doing while the transition plan was in place and up to and until the state's ESSA plan was approved by board action.
So, is approving this state plan going to suspend that work as well?
I think that needs to be clarified because districts with schools, districts and schools that are in some form of program improvement or corrective action whose status is frozen.
and they were supposed to continue planning and continue developing capacity.
Once this state plan is approved, what are they supposed to be doing with that work?
And what is their new status now?
So, approving this state plan has an impact on those things.
I think we need to make sure we clarify what our vote to approve this plan will mean as it relates to those two things.
Okay.
Don't, no need to respond to that?
Well, my understanding and I know that Carrick and his team have been having conversations about how we transition program improvement into
the non-program improvement era.
My understanding of the transition plan that you approved, I believe, in May of 2016, was that that plan was for the 16-17 transition year.
And ESSA is in effect for the 17-18 transition year.
And I could look over my show.
Yes?
I'm counting too.
So I don't know if you, have you, have we determined with conviction about the status of program improvement for this, which is clearly another transition year.
Last year was the last year of NCLB.
We are without, whether or not you all approve, ED hasn't approved, so I would offer that there's another kind of transition in there until ED approves.
No.
Well, no.
My understanding in our action was that transition plan and the guidance that I read from ED said that that transition plan was in place until the state submitted their approved state plan, that they didn't have to wait on what they were going to do on that part.
So that's why I'm saying our action has an impact on two other decisions the board has made.
I want to make sure we're clear.
on how that action relates to that transition plan.
So we're not taking, so that people are not... No, it's important.
I agree.
Ortiz Lacombe.
Ting, I don't know if you were going to point this out.
There was two revisions that I suggested, and I know that we have them in front of us.
One of them, page 29, included under the LPI baseline.
Are you going to cover that?
Yes.
Right after this little pause for these three, we're going to go into the next three that weren't in the item, but were the ones that you suggested.
Okay, so then those we have them and you'll describe them.
I also asked staff to look into incorporating specifically calling out the EL roadmap under Title 3 in discussing developing resources for LEAs to support ELs.
And so I know that staff will be working on some language and bringing that forward for the final motion as well.
Thank you.
So you want to include those in your next part?
I'm a little lost as to why we're pausing now and having board discussion.
I apologize.
We had an item that had these three proposed revisions.
We also need to talk about the Title IV question.
And I thought rather than having those three revisions, which people have had a chance to really look at since the item was posted, and then go into these smaller, less substantive conversations afterwards.
Because the next set are kind of corrections as opposed to things that require big decisions.
I'm happy to continue and then have more conversation later.
Let's bring it all out.
Yeah.
Sure.
Okay.
Just trying to parse it out.
So here are additional suggested revisions.
I want to share with you a few revisions that were not presented in the item, but I think everyone in the room has the handout now that has them.
So we want to make sure we're getting very close to submission.
So we want to be very clear on what it is we're proposing.
Two of them are corrections to language in the plan that came to our attention after we posted the item.
And the third proposes new language to address a new plan requirement.
Because these revisions were not included in the item, we've prepared a handout so everyone can see very clearly what it is we're proposing.
So on page 29, we propose to update the language to reflect the English learner progress indicator will be calculated using the number of reclassified English learners, not reclassification rates.
So the top part of this slide, and you'll have it on your handout as well, shows these proposed revisions using the format that we've consistently used
for updated drafts to ensure accessibility.
But it's a little bit hard to read.
So at the bottom of the slide, the new proposed language post-revision is provided.
But you can see those on the handout.
The first one says page 29.
On page 39 of the draft, we propose one change.
Schools graduating fewer than 67% of their students will be eligible for comprehensive supports in addition to the lowest performing 5% of schools, not within that 5% of schools.
And since that's just one change and relatively legible, we didn't put the whole amended on this slide, but you do have it in your handout.
And then we propose to add new language to the plan to address Appendix B.
Appendix B is a relatively new addition to the plan template.
On July 24, after your July meeting, ED released this new plan requirement for a 30-day public comment period.
States must provide a written response to provide assurances that the state will ensure equitable access to and participation in its federally assisted programs for students, teachers, and others who may have special needs.
Specifically, Section 427 of the General Education Provisions Act highlights six potential barriers to access and participation.
Gender, race, national origin, color, disability, and age.
The public comment for this new requirement ended on August 23rd, so this is all happening very recently.
And we have not yet been officially notified by ED to include this appendix when we submit the plan next week.
But it is part of the plan template that is currently posted on ED's webpage.
And both our federal liaison in Washington and our colleagues at the Council of Chief State School Officers
are confident that this new appendix will be required and that it would be best to submit it along with the rest of the plan.
Fortunately, and this is an assurance primarily, California law provides established steps to ensure that students, teachers, and others in public schools are provided with equitable access to and participation in federally assisted programs, well, all programs.
Under Section 200, all persons in public schools, regardless of disability, gender, gender identity, we go beyond the federal requirement, gender expression, nationality, race or ethnicity, religion, sexual orientation, or any other characteristic contained in the definition of hate crimes, have equal rights and opportunities in the educational institutions in our state.
I'm not going to read all of the relevant code.
Again, you do have it in front of you.
But section 250 requires any educational institution receiving state dollars to provide an assurance to the issuing agency that it will comply with the anti-discrimination provisions in this chapter of education code.
And section 260 states that school district governing boards have primary responsibility for ensuring that programs and activities are free from discrimination.
And section 262.3a describes the process for appealing to the CDE any actions that are taken at the local level.
So, staff recommends that we revise the plan to include the relevant excerpts of education code as shown on these slides and on the handout.
To be very clear, we are not proposing to provide any new language beyond what is provided on this handout, which is fundamentally a restatement of the requirement and the relevant excerpts of code.
So those are the three that you did not see before today.
And there's our recommendation.
So I'm going to stop talking.
And we're going to take a break.
So let's come back at five at three.
Okay, the board will reconvene and so
The board will start then with board member questions and issues.
Board Member Sun, do you want to begin?
Yes, go ahead.
Board Member Sun, our federal liaison will begin.
OK, so just a couple of things before we go to public comment.
I just wanted to well, first of all, I want to underline what board member Rucker said that around our continued work and commitment to the work on the LCAP regarding instructors and effective teachers in the classroom for all of California's students.
And then just after the public comments, I will be making motion on the suggested some of the substantive changes as well as the technical changes.
And in addition, regarding the E-English Language Learner Roadmap to be included in a section of the plan as well.
Okay.
So, Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
So I want to acknowledge that the plan has come a very long way and there are certain areas that have been really strengthened.
And that's not an endorsement, but it's an acknowledgement.
I also have to say that.
And I think I recognize the hours and the work that went into it.
Putting together those stakeholder meetings is not an easy task.
We know that many states have skipped out on that very important component because it is very labor intensive.
You know, I want to go back to one thing that it will be of no surprise to anyone.
When you mentioned that this is a grant application, I'm very acquainted with grant applications.
I'm in the non-profit world, so I have to get very, I have to write these several times a month.
And I also, we also sub-grant to some of our affiliates.
So, I also know that process.
I think part of the disconnect that I've had along this process for the last year and a half is that I don't see this only as a contract, only as a grant, because ESSA is rooted in civil rights.
And I think that we need to make sure that we acknowledge that, even if we want to focus on the California way
on LCFF, we need to acknowledge that this is rooted in civil rights because the rest of the country is already forgetting about civil rights.
So it is our responsibility to say that even though it's only a small little green band, it's meant to bring equity and parity to students that have historically underperformed.
And I think that perspective is what has shifted the conversation between where I stand and where maybe some others stand.
And in the spirit of that, one of the things that has been a bit of a heartbreak for me is that we haven't addressed, not even at a minimum, in a minimum way for a grant, the notion of narrowing achievement gaps, the notion of setting interim growth targets, the notion of how will we accelerate the growth of those subgroups lagging furthest behind.
And I don't think that if a reader or if I had received this grant, I would say, yes, they met.
They checked that off.
They wrote the basics of it because we didn't.
What we said was we have this five by five and districts can use it or schools can use it.
my last round of comments was, can we at least make that language stronger?
Can we say will, shall?
And it's been a year and a half where I've asked statewide methodology, let's say really concrete targets, to now just asking the basics.
Can we just strengthen the language?
And even that hasn't made it to this final version.
So,
I feel that because of that, we haven't addressed the question.
And I said it before, it doesn't have to be here because I know how people feel about this contract.
But it hasn't been codified anywhere else.
You know, this plan will outlive all of us here and hopefully this administration in D.C.
as well.
because it won't be reauthorized.
This bill, this law will not be reauthorized for another 10, 15 years.
And so what we, our good intentions, because I know we all have them, won't matter if it's not documented somewhere that we committed to narrowing achievement gaps in California for California students.
LCFF tells us that we should, but it doesn't tell us how.
And I think that ESSA allowed that opportunity to say, and this is exactly how we're going to do that.
So that continues to be a disappointment.
And I'm sorry, I really apologize to folks that looked to me to help move this along.
I wasn't able to.
Thank you.
Yeah, OK, we'll move to public comment.
May we come back to that after the public comment?
And if the staff is sure they understand what you're, what they need to answer, right?
Okay.
All right.
We'll have public comment.
That'll.
Would the following people please line up?
Tony Rice, Eric Premack, Shanti Ezrin, Celia Jaffe, Sorret Kaminski, Doug McCray, Enrique Rocho, Isamar Orcs Gonzalez, Edmundo Litton, Mary Perry, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, Shelley Spiegel Coleman, Carla Herrera,
Roberto Viramontes, Ashley Lautzenheiser, Kyle Hawker, and Michael McKibbin.
I'll call other names in a moment.
Go ahead, yeah.
Thank you, Tony Rice.
On behalf of the Regional Economic Association leaders, the REAL Coalition, an association of California's most influential business and economic development entities, representing 20 member organizations and up to 15,000 employers who collectively provide up to 3.9 million California jobs, we write this important concept, California's Every Student Succeeds Act State Plan presented today.
ESSA recognizes that educational improvement will increase students' ability to succeed in the 21st century global economy, fostering such skills as critical thinking, complex problem solving, effective communication, collaboration, and the ability to learn independently in a rapidly changing world.
California has designed a robust and meaningful set of indicators that stakeholders can use to drive performance over time, enabling our students to shape and own accountability and empower school districts to create cultures of leadership and performance.
This will also encourage attracting, retaining, supporting, and unleashing an effective teacher and educated force.
Thank you for your dedication to the development of our future workforce.
We stand ready to work together to support a strong, excuse me, economically competitive California.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
We appreciate some of the changes, including a reference to charter flexibility under teacher credentialing.
But given that we've had about a 10 year plus problem with CDE recognizing one of the key forms of flexibility with respect to assignment monitoring,
The lack of specificity in the state plan on that issue remains a very serious issue to us.
We will, if that's not addressed explicitly in the plan, we do plan to vigorously oppose its adoption and we would encourage you to amend the plan to reflect that specific flexibility.
We also remain confused as to how the charter flexibility with respect to goal setting and the LCAP aligns with identifying the lowest 5% performing schools and whether we're going to align to the charter flexibility there.
The federal law is quite explicit that these plans need to respect the state law flexibility accorded to charters and as it's currently drafted, as I interpret it,
That flexibility is not there for charter.
So we are very concerned about those and ask that you amend the plan to explicitly recognize those.
Thank you.
Celia Jaffe, State PTA.
PTA supports the board's approach to the ESSA State Plan.
We don't want the state's innovations in education to become limited or hedged in by federal requirements.
We don't want the tail wagging the dog.
CDE and the board have been very responsive to stakeholders and have changed things all along the way in the evolution of this system.
And we'd rather come here to the state for changes and improvements rather than to the feds.
So we're happy with this idea.
The caveats are to stay true to the priority of pursuing equity and to the priority of continuous improvement of the system as a whole.
So I want to start by saying thank you for recognizing that effective teachers come from all backgrounds, including intern teachers.
I'm Isamar Ortiz-Gonzalez.
I teach in Sacramento for Natomas Unified School District.
This is my four year serving students in the classroom.
And I started as an intern teacher.
And so I just want, and knowing that the data says that close to half of intern teachers are the most diverse or come from the most diverse backgrounds, just wanted to reiterate that it's very important for teachers to reflect the background of our diverse students as well.
And just a quick example, my first year as a Spanish teacher at an elementary school, teachers, students were at first very hesitant to admit that they spoke Spanish or were very unwilling to speak it.
And then by my second year, a lot of them were proud just by the fact that they liked me and they thought it was cool that they could communicate in their native language, whether a teacher.
So just a quick example.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Edmundo Litton from Loyola Marymount University.
I'm a professor and my main responsibility is to run the intern programs at the university.
So I support the state plan, which designates effective teachers as those who are properly assigned and are teaching with a credential, including an intern teaching credential.
In the last 15 years, I have been truly honored to support many intern teachers as they serve the use of the state, especially during a time of a teacher shortage.
With the support of the university and our employing districts, my interns have demonstrated that they are strong teachers.
They work on a daily basis to make sure that every student has the ability to succeed under their care.
Because intern programs have created the most diverse teaching force, our intern programs have also been able to become role models.
Our teachers have become role models for our students.
to say that my intern teachers are ineffective ignores the many successful outcomes I've worked with their students.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Sean Tiezrin, Alliance for Children's Rights.
I'm here to highlight the feedback and written public comment that we provided in partnership with the National Center for Youth Law with respect to foster youth and the state ESSA plan.
In short, we were disappointed that the foster youth assurances under ESSA were not included in the state plan, particularly since foster youth continue to demonstrate the poorest educational outcomes of any student group in the state.
However, we applaud the fact that the board is committed to consider additional policies that address ESSA requirements not covered by the state plan template and further align state and federal accountability requirements.
The draft LCAP addendum is one such policy tool that offers a key opportunity to align federal accountability requirements related to foster youth with LEA's broader LCFF goals related to foster youth students.
We suggest that including a prompt in the LCAP addendum related to school stability.
The inclusion of this prompt will ensure that all LEAs are meeting the minimum requirements of both federal and state law.
And furthermore, will support widespread implementation on the ground for one of California's highest need pupils.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Enrique Rocha with the Los Angeles Unified School District and we would like to commend and appreciate the work of the board as it relates to the ESSA state plan and including the revisions on the ineffective teacher definition.
As we would encourage the continued work on that definition and as the work moves beyond the ESSA state plan, we would urge the consideration of the ineffective teacher definition which
We recommend that it should not include the misassigned teachers, which should be categorized as out-of-field teachers, and also to base that definition on teacher performance and evaluation.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing the California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
And my comments are specific to tables 12 and 13 found in the state plan, specific to the equity data to be collected under ESSA.
These tables reflect the various definitions of teacher credential status that will be used for the purpose of collecting data that will provide information regarding the rates at which low-income and children of color
are taught by non-credentialed, non-qualified teachers.
Definitions include ineffective teachers, out-of-field teachers, and experienced teachers.
We are unclear as to what is meant by out-of-field teachers and whether that includes a teacher without an English learner authorization.
In light of the fact that the law requires teachers to obtain an EL authorization,
to instruct English learners, we recommend that the EL authorization be included in this out-of-field definition.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Shelley Spiegel-Coleman with Californians Together.
We want to address the designation of the lowest 5% Title I schools.
And what we want to say is that this really brings to us another demonstration of the unintended consequence of including four years of the RFEP students.
in the EL definition for academic indicators.
We've looked at the data.
Many, many of our low-achieving schools do not designate English learners as the subgroup that needs to be addressed because they turn out to be yellow.
And when we then looked at the disaggregation of the English learner only versus the RFEP, many, many of the schools that are yellow for EL indicators are red.
when you look at English learner only.
So we really have a problem with using that definition for the designation of the lowest 5% schools.
We hope that you will use the English learner only for when you're looking at designating the lowest 5% schools.
Otherwise, many schools will not take it seriously and will not be designated for the work they need to do with English learners.
Thank you very much.
Hi again, Carla Herrera, IQC, Emerita, and Californians Together.
Based on what we heard from Board Member Ortiz-Licon, we thank you for including the EL Roadmap in the appropriate places in the ESSA State Plan.
We agree this is necessary in light of the fact that the EL Roadmap is now state policy for EL students.
A good start would be including the Yale Roadmap in Table 14, California Strategies for Meeting Student Needs and Providing Effective Transitions.
This table lists the strategies California will provide to Title I LEAs in order to address diverse student needs, support successful student transitions, and prevent dropouts.
The Yale Roadmap includes
strategies specific to the academic success of ELs.
I'd like to quote the CDE news release number 17-52 paragraph 8 from July 13th.
of this year.
The English Learner Roadmap will also help California schools comply with the new Federal Every Student Succeeds Act, ESSA, and the state's local control funding, LCFF, both of which require specific assistance so English learners can meet the same academic standards as other students.
Thank you.
Would the following people please line up to speak?
Melanie Thomas, Ken Burt, Michael Flores-Gastineau, Shelley Whitley, Lorraine Richards, Angela DeRamos, Martha Alvarez, Colin Miller, Renata Sanchez,
Brian Rivas, Jan Correa, Kim Lewis, Rebecca Wu, Jacqueline Nader, Allison Osorio, Catherine Phillips, Swapnil Kalyankar, Samantha Tran, Terry Burns, and Darcelle Sanders.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Sarek Kaminski, Policy Director at CCESA representing the 58 County Superintendents.
We commend staff for their outreach and gathering feedback from the field and support staff's revision in the definition of ineffective teacher to meet a teacher that is misassigned rather than including teachers with interim credentials under this definition.
Thank you, Member Rucker, for asking about the appropriate terminology.
The CTC has authorized and validated a number of alternative paths
to obtaining a clear credential and the district intern credential is one such track.
To be granted this type of credential, both the teacher and the LEA must fulfill a number of requirements that adhere to CTC program standards and regulations.
To qualify for the intern program, all participants must complete a required minimum of 120 intern
120-hour intern pre-service preparation or six semester units of coursework and child development and methods of teaching, possess a bachelor's degree, satisfy the basic skills requirement, meet the subject matter competence requirement, meet the U.S.
Constitution requirement, and obtain character and identification clearance.
Labeling teachers that hold a district intern credentials ineffective at the state or federal level is inaccurate.
We appreciate staff's responsiveness to stakeholder feedback.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Doug McRae, Retired Educational Measurement Specialist for Monterey.
A four-page set of comments on assessment and accountability were put in the special department electronic folder on this topic.
A condensed version went into the State Board various items header.
The highlight for accountability for me was that we won't know until at least January how well the California's plan will handle the ESSA requirement to identify the lowest 5% performing schools, Title I schools.
Jury is still out on this high-profile aspect of the accountability plan.
And frankly, I think likely there will be many anomalies and nitty-gritty technical problems when we get to that in January.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Roberto Viramontes with the Learning Policy Institute.
Thank you so much for all your work on the ESSA State Plan.
I'd like to offer some comments with respect to ensuring all students have equitable access to excellent teachers.
We appreciate the board's commitment to report at the state, district, and school levels data on the percentage of teachers who hold preliminary and clear credentials, who hold intern credentials, who are misassigned, and those who hold emergency type permits and waivers.
We hope that this data will be reported on the dashboard.
as they are consistent with priority one of LCFF, so that stakeholders have access to key equity data, which is even more important during this time of significant teacher shortages.
Research shows that the share of teachers who have not met subject matter in teaching qualifications is strongly associated with teaching ineffectiveness as measured by student achievement gains.
With defining ineffective teacher,
We are comfortable with the revised definition, though we know that this revision creates a misalignment between the state accountability system, priority one, and the federal one.
As we commented in July, we recommend that California collect and report additional data, including teacher survey data, which can measure school leadership quality, teacher professional learning, and data on teacher turnover and absences.
We look forward to working with CDE and state board staff to explore how they can be incorporated into California's accountability system.
Thank you.
Hello and thank you both for allowing me to speak today and for updating the definition of an ineffective teacher in the September 1st draft of the ESSA plan.
My name is Melanie Thomas and I'm in my eighth year of public education.
I am a 2012 Teach for America Sacramento alumni where I taught with my intern teaching credential.
Currently, I'm the special education coordinator for Kairos Public Schools in Vacaville, where I both directly supervise and I hire intern teachers.
As an education specialist intern teacher, I worked relentlessly to ensure that in my first year of teaching, at least 90% of student IEP goals were met and 100% of IEP meetings, assessments, and evaluations were held within the legal timeframe.
I now have the privilege of overseeing two intern teachers who are some of the most dedicated, passionate, and hardworking teachers I've had the honor to work with.
Due to their hard work, our school site is aspiring to become a model of special education inclusion in our local area.
We support multiple pathways into teaching to serve all students and to improve all schools.
I urge you to adopt the definition with the change language.
Good afternoon, Marta Alvarez on behalf of AXA, the Association of California School Administrators.
AXA commends the state board in their continued work in ensuring that California's law, LCFF, and other underlying statutes are what's informing the federal work on ESSA.
So we fully support the state plan in the direction that it's going, and it will be approved today to go to the federal government.
We also just wanted to echo comments made by the other speakers regarding the ineffective teacher definition.
We hope that conversation will continue in how do we report that data in the future.
We look forward to continue to be part of the discussion about the lowest 5% of schools and how the work ties back to supporting school districts will be supporting those schools.
And lastly, we really want to give our appreciation to the staff who has been working on this for the last 18 months.
To quote Chief Deputy Price, he has mentioned in the past, if there was an LCFF Hall of Fame, Barbara Murchison's name would be on it.
So thank you very much for the extensive work.
You have done an excellent way of modeling what school districts are doing to engage their communities.
Now you're just doing it at the state level.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Jan Correa with the California Association for Bilingual Education.
And I just want to begin by saying how much CAVE, as well as a member of the California Together Coalition, we support the statements made by both board member Ortiz-Lincon and Rucker on issues regarding the closing the achievement gap.
So thank you for those comments.
My statements today are regarding the translation issue within the plan.
Table one states that teachers may translate the directions and test items in the language of instruction.
And I'd like to state that in the spirit of and direction of both Prop 58 and the English Learner Roadmap, that the state of California should provide the translations of the specified assessments identified in Table 1 in order to establish consistency statewide and to ensure that no one goes beyond the language of assessments.
Not providing the assessments or the translation of the assessments may create a disincentive for teachers to use this support and sends a message that it's not important and optional.
CABE recommends that the state plan includes a statement, teachers shall use to provide the translations of test items and directions corresponding to the language of instruction.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Kim Lewis representing the California Coalition for Youth today, and I want to applaud the board and staff for the work and revisions done to the section on the Education for Homeless Children and Youth Program, the McKinney-Vento Act, and incorporating a lot of suggestions that CCY had provided to the group, especially with the call out for unaccompanied homeless youth who do not have parents with them at that time, and so challenges of getting through enrollment and access can be
much more difficult for them.
And then I want to also say that, you know, I want to ensure that the Office of the Statewide Coordinator with all these duties and tasks that are included in this part of the plan has enough capacity to ensure that we are meeting those parts of the plan and be able to exercise that because California has been a real leader in championing, removing barriers to access to education for homeless children with a lot of recent passage of bills.
and additional activities.
So school tends to be that one place for youth where they have that continuity even if they are homeless.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Colin Miller with the California Charter Schools Association.
I wanted to just address two specific issues that we raised in our letter in July and again this month.
With regard to the credentialing issue, we do appreciate the change to address intern teachers.
We also do appreciate the addition of the note regarding charter school flexibility.
However, I think I just heard Dr. Sun clarify that indeed that footnote means that charter school teachers that are hired under that flexibility will not be identified as ineffective.
And I wanted to be clear that that's the intent because the language is not exactly clear.
On the charter accountability piece, we did offer some language that we think is very simple and clean that would address the absence of any recognition of that section in the response to the prompt.
There's a very specific prompt in the plan requirements regarding charter school accountability and flexibility.
It was not addressed and we do think that it must be addressed or else you'll have a
not only an incomplete but a non-compliant plan.
So we want to make sure that that gets taken care of.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Rigel Massaro, Senior Staff Attorney with Public Advocates.
I'm a former intern teacher.
I want to say that intern pathways are necessary and they're not going away in this time of teacher shortage.
At the same time, any teacher not included in our ineffective definition is by definition effective.
And California has rigorous standards for effectiveness in teachers.
We base effectiveness on a rigorous performance assessment.
And while interns are diverse and bring long-term educators into the classroom, they're not proven effective until they complete their program after one to two years of teaching.
They can become teachers of record after 120 hours.
Access to fully prepared teachers is a civil rights issue.
California defines fully prepared as a teacher who's completed a credentialing program and passed the TPA.
This principle is long recognized in California law, which requires transparency about student access to fully prepared teachers in our SARC and is aligned with LCFF priority number one.
Under California law, districts cannot hire intern teachers unless fully credentialed teachers aren't available.
Thank you.
My name is Renata Sanchez, and I am an instructional coach in San Jose, speaking as an individual.
I am also nationally board certified, a member of the California Instructional Leadership Corps, vice president of my local association, and I began my journey in education teaching on an intern credential.
I want to thank the board for updating the definition of an ineffective teacher in the current draft of the ESSA plan.
Living and working as a teacher in the Bay Area has been incredibly challenging.
Attending a traditional program was never a financial option for me upon graduation.
I am so thankful I was given the opportunity to participate in an intern credential program.
As an intern teacher I worked in a title one school and I had 29 out of 30 of my fourth grade students reach proficient on the CST that year.
Valuing multiple pathways into teaching led to my success and the success of my students and I encourage the board to continue to support intern teachers as effective teachers.
Thank you.
Hi, Angela de Ramos on behalf of CTA and I wanted to officially pass the label of newbie liaison and introduce Michael Castaneda.
Good afternoon, Michael Flores Castaneda, representing California Teachers Association, and I'll also be speaking on behalf of my colleagues behind me.
I first want to express CTA's appreciation for the many months of dedicated efforts by the State Board and CDE staff in drafting this plan, as well as for the opportunity to respond today.
As the chair of CTA's Special Education Committee, I was fortunate enough to be on the work group that reviewed the plan, representing the interests of our most vulnerable students and their educators.
Of the notable improvements in the current draft, the most significant is the renewed commitment to continuing to pursue a single coherent system that avoids having separate state and federal accountability structures, though many details must still be ironed out.
All of our comments on the latest draft are in the letter that you received today.
As you make your final edits, CTA respectfully recommends the board revise the proposed long-term goals and treat all green and blue cells as meeting or exceeding the goals.
The board should not allow ESSA to force California to adopt goals that are inconsistent with our LCFF system, thereby creating confusion.
And lastly, we strongly recommend that the board reject the last minute proposal to strike the word full before credential in the definition of ineffective teacher.
It is rushed, ill-conceived and misaligned with our LCFF and the statutory language of priority one.
We supported this section of the plan as it was written in the August draft, and we urge the board to continue with the direction it provided to staff in the July meeting.
Thank you.
President Kirst, I'm Brian Rivas speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
We agree with Member Ortiz-Licn.
We wish that you had approached this task with her suggested orientation that this was a way to pursue civil rights for low-income students and students of color.
So although this is not, my comment shouldn't be interpreted as a criticism of the staff work.
I think the staff did a great job, but we're disappointed.
We think this is a missed opportunity to weave together all of the disparate parts like school ratings and goals and supports and interventions to move the needle for students who need the most help.
With regard to the narrow dispute over the change in the definition for ineffective teacher, we agree with the recent change.
but we're still, I think, disappointed overall and think the definition of an ineffective teacher should take into consideration the effect that a teacher has on student outcomes.
We hope that you'll return to that work and consider improvements.
Good afternoon, I'm Jacqueline Nader with Partners for Each and Every Child.
Thank you for the opportunity to provide comment today and for the multiple opportunities that the public has had to weigh in on the Essence State Plan.
We know, however, that the work to create a strong accountability system for equity and excellence is not yet complete.
And so with that in mind, we would ask the board and CDE to continue to work with the stakeholders in this room, as well as the voices that haven't typically been heard in these kinds of policy discussions going forward.
And we have a few recommendations to ensure that specifically diverse families and communities are fully engaged and involved.
First, we would recommend that you publish a list of the decisions that have yet to be made or finalized, a timeline of those decisions, and guidance on how the public can continue to engage going forward.
Second, we recommend that you develop a comprehensive plan for deeper stakeholder engagement, particularly to reach historically unheard voices, reflecting back on the work that you've already done.
And finally, we suggest that you commit additional resources to build capacity for really deep stakeholder engagement at all levels of the system.
We look forward to working with you to support you.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon, Samantha Tran with Children Now.
Over the last four years, along with partners, we've shared analyses, put forward solutions, tried to change those solutions based on the board's direction, and have increasingly shared some serious concerns.
We continue to be strong supporters of the principles in LCFF and celebrate many of the aspects of that transformation that's occurring across the state with you.
We believe it's the right direction for California and because it's the right direction and we want it to be here for the long haul, the details matter.
In particular, our criticism of the ESSA plan and the state plan overall has been grounded in the belief that we can only serve kids and improve their outcomes if we're really willing to fundamentally see them and see our most vulnerable children in particular.
there are far too many provisions in the ESSA plan and the state's approach that obscures those realities.
Given how these processes work, we know it's far too late to change the plan that's about to be submitted.
So given that, we would just ask that as the federal government comes back and raises the issue of transparency that we address those quickly.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Catherine Phillips from Teach for America Los Angeles.
I'd like to thank the board for recognizing that effective teachers come from all backgrounds and all pipelines.
Non-traditional intern credential pathways are the most diverse pipeline in the state, enrolling nearly 50% people of color.
And at TFA LA, we're looking at closer to 75% this year.
We also produce high quality teachers.
A study of intern credential teachers in LAUSD by Harvard University found that interns were just as effective as other new teachers.
And each of the last three years, TFA LA interns have been recognized as rookies of the year, which means we're in the top tier of all the teachers at LAUSD.
We welcome the opportunity to continue to work alongside the more than 70 intern credential pathways in the state to grow, improve, and diversify the workforce in California.
Thank you.
Darcelle Sanders representing Teach for America California, which trains and supports 600 teachers and thousands of alumni educators across our state each year.
We would like to thank the board for eliminating the reference to intern credential teachers as ineffective.
Intern programs are the most diverse pipeline for teachers in California and produce high quality educators who see the potential in all of our kids.
I know this from our data, but I also know this from my experience teaching middle school in Oakland Unified School District.
I started as an intern teacher.
My mentor teacher was a California Teacher of the Year who was also a TFA intern teacher.
We were both women of color, both grew up low income.
We were mirrors to our students and windows to opportunity.
One student message stands out to me when I reflect on the importance of diversity in the profession.
It read in part, you gave me a Latino male that did not want to go to college the courage to try and achieve.
I finally got a 4.0 and I owe it all to you.
He owes it all to himself, but nonetheless, his words underscore the importance of a diverse workforce.
My story is not an exception, but the rule.
Intern pipelines are diverse.
Intern teachers are effective.
And with your support today, we will continue to help change the trajectory of our students.
We'd also like to submit written testimony from teachers and principals who are unable to leave their school sites and their classrooms today.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Terry Burns on behalf of the California School Boards Association.
I want to associate ourselves with AXS's comments and appreciation of all the work of staff, particularly in their outreach efforts to all the stakeholders above and beyond.
Very much appreciated.
We support the recommended change in the teacher definition and pursuant to our letter, we look forward to building that out even further on the lines that Ed Trust West was talking about, really looking at individual teacher effectiveness.
Finally, we look forward to a build out of the definition of the bottom 5% and the identification of the bottom 5% of schools.
We see that as an opportunity to take into account gap closure.
with different student populations.
CSBA believes that gap closure should be a key focus of this effort.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, President Kurst, members of the board.
Ron Rapp speaking on behalf of the 120,000 educators that we represent at the California Federation of Teachers.
First, I want to thank the board for their guidance and development of what we think is a high quality ESSA plan.
Thank you so much for that guidance.
We also agree with my colleague from AXA in terms of Barbara Murchison should receive at least a trophy, if not a medal.
and be in the Hall of Fame.
Thank you for developing a plan that is aligned with the California way and doesn't take us away from our vision for a high quality education system for all children.
Thank you for that.
And also we'd like to mention that we'd like to thank you for providing an opportunity for extensive input.
Barbara and her staff presented at several of our meetings and allowed our folks to
provide input into the plan and we're very appreciative of that.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I'm Ashley Lotsenheiser with Parent Revolution.
Thank you for the opportunity to continue to provide comment.
Likely, I'm echoing comments of other partners today who work directly with students and families in historically underserved communities.
Broadly, California's education leadership has a responsibility to address and close the racial and economic opportunity gaps that are so widespread.
in our public education system.
We still believe that the board had a responsibility to develop an ESSA plan that better identifies the lowest performing schools in the state and put forward real details with accompanying accountability measures on how to improve them.
All of this along a timeline that offers real hope of relief for the students stuck in these schools.
While we understand that multiple platforms and policy frameworks are at various stages of implementation, we remain concerned that the current ESSA plan does not properly identify the lowest performing schools in California, nor does it act with any urgency to put in place a plan to improve student outcomes.
Maximum flexibility without this accountability does a disservice to the students and persistently low performing schools who do not have years to wait.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Sarah Lillis with EdVoice and Board Member Ortiz-Lee Cohn, we share your disappointment.
I think as you all know, we've had many, many letters and comments.
We'd hoped for more in terms of meeting the requirements of the federal civil rights law, as well as the promise of LCFF.
But we do appreciate staff's responsiveness to our concerns about the definition of ineffective teachers.
We would, like our colleagues at CSBA and at Trust West and X, I'd like to continue to move forward about looking at other measures of effectiveness.
But we did want to confirm that in Title V of the California Code of State Regulations there is, they do establish the definition of a teaching credential in Section 80033.
So it is a
credential and as you heard from our colleagues from CESA there are extensive regulations tied to that and we would be concerned if we were to if we were to say that that is an ineffective credential that you're opening up that the legislation the CTC has has said that those teachers can be teaching students and you open up the state and the district to lots of litigation so we hope to continue to work on this to make it a meaningful measure of effectiveness but we appreciate this the amendment that the staff made.
Thank you.
Includes the public comment.
So I'd like to first talk to, turn to Board Member Strauss to comment on, we still have the Part 4A open and we have the question that, that Board Member Rucker asked.
So do you want to, are we ready to address the question that she asked or?
Yeah, absolutely.
Carrick, if you would come up and talk a little.
And we can turn to Board Member Strauss.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Carrick Ashley, Deputy Superintendent, Performance Planning and Technology Branch.
So it's not surprising that there's a little confusion because the federal government was very clear fairly early on in ESSA for the 2016-17 transition plan and what needed to be in it, and it was written
That guidance was directed mostly to states that didn't have a previous waiver, which of course California would be under.
So, when you approve that transition plan, it was pretty specific to Title I. There's been less
information from the U.S.
Department of Education about other titles.
But in terms of program improvement, it was pretty specific in our guidance to our school districts and schools was also pretty specific that it was a transition year, that that transition now carries over
We are not identifying any new program improvement schools for those schools that we're not even using the phrase program improvement schools anymore.
For those that were previously identified as program improvement schools,
The transition plan relieved them from the obligation of reserving 10% of their Title I funds and offering the school choice and requiring the offering of SES, the Supplemental Education Services.
And in lieu of that, they could continue those if they wanted, but in lieu of that, they were to provide some activities for schools, for students in those schools
that are designed to help improve student outcomes.
And so that continues during the 17-18 year.
As you know, some states have their plan approved and they have the option of moving ahead and doing something in 17-18.
For California, we could choose to move ahead and do something differently once we have an approved state plan.
But at this point in time, we're continuing with the transition from 16-17.
Board member Strauss, are you ready?
So I want to talk about the investment in capacity for teachers and leaders, because all of our work has been talking about narrowing the achievement gap, subgroup growth and improvement, which we know the first and biggest defining character is what happens in that classroom every single day.
And every and one and the second, by the way, is the role of the instructional leader.
That's the second one.
So what we've realized when we've been out talking to districts is continuing to invest in the capacity both of new teachers but also teachers at different stages of their career and leaders.
And because if we pass state policy and don't work on implementation and even
in Michael Fullen's research, he was talking about the implementation flaws and how we needed to really address that.
And so as one of the liaisons who works on the liaison work to the instructional practice, I just want to talk about why I think we should transfer to support the capacity and support of teacher practice and leader practice.
The communities of practice in both science and in math
bring together about a hundred educators in science and a hundred in math from regionally around our state.
We have a huge state.
We've heard today about districts as small as eight or 50 or a hundred.
And I think more than half of our districts in the state are 2,500 or less.
And then giant, giant districts.
And then the challenges of getting teachers and leaders into the field and staying persistently in the field.
And so the regional communities of practice are actually bringing our leaders together to build capacity with the expectation that they will go back and expand practice in their regions all over this giant state.
And so, but what districts are saying, and I know we hear this, is that
money is starting to get tight again.
The one-time money for Common Core is not there.
That the pension costs are increasing and so districts are finding less flexibility to invest in professional practice than they used to.
So, I think that what we know is it's not the one-shot deals.
It's not the two-hour meeting.
It's not the great faculty meeting that some of us tried to run.
But it is ongoing investment in
And really, labor intensive coaching and capacity building, late lesson study, building over time is what we really know makes a difference.
So, I just wanted to say just as we're developing a health framework now, we have a math framework
that was the first that we did in this generation, then the literacy framework, then the history and science framework.
And we're discovering that we have teachers who don't know what these frameworks are.
They just bought a book and they're teaching the book.
And so what we realize is that some of the reasons that I believe and that I see out in districts where our math scores are not what we hope is because the book wasn't necessarily aligned to the new standards.
It was stamped Common Core, but maybe not as aligned as it could be.
And so teachers often in secondary teach the book and didn't need more time to really understand our frameworks and what resources they have to support the frameworks and what they need to do to develop.
All that takes time.
And so I know we're going to talk about some of our needs.
I believe the continuing focus on mathematics is critical in our state.
It's a gateway and a gatekeeper for kids going forward.
I believe the next generation science standards people are embracing, but that's hugely different.
Major shifts we're going to need, I would say 10 years at least of investment.
And overall, the support for English learners in our state, in all of our instructional strategies.
In every one of our frameworks, we're layering that in, and yet we go to districts where teachers haven't seen that, that don't realize that there's integrated and designated ELD as part of our expectation.
So all that means is that I believe that we should support moving money to support professional capacity building for teachers and leaders to sustain the work.
So let me just also support separate from that piece.
I support the change in the language on the intern credential.
I think we heard a huge amount of testimony and letters to support that.
I think that's really important and I support
the inclusion of the English Learner Roadmap that we've been talking about.
And it was a wonderful celebration at our July meeting.
But I think we have so much work to do to help everybody understand a first core instruction is for all kids.
That's all teachers for all kids.
That's English learners, that's special needs that we need to help our teachers have those strategies before they're set out to designated support that's separate from the core classroom.
And so we're going to need a lot of support on those resources.
And then our curriculum frameworks that we work so hard to develop and vet and get public input and then are not a regular practice of some of our classrooms in our schools.
So again, I support the supporting of investing in teacher and leader capacity for professional development and moving some of those funds to support that, the intern credential, the frameworks and English learner roadmap.
Thank you.
So you're supporting moving the Part IV-A to Title II?
Okay, moving Part IV-A money to state administrative money to...
Okay.
So I guess my passionate plea was that we need to invest in our capacity building and that the way to do that is to put that money in Title II, Part A. The Chief Deputy wants to speak.
He has a different point of view.
Thank you, President Gerson.
And I first wanted to start out by thanking all the wonderful stakeholders that came out to present to us today.
Really appreciate all the feedback and comments
Not only today, but over this last 18 months, your outpouring of ideas, suggestions, feedback, comments has just been wonderful and super appreciated by the superintendent.
I also want to have first claim, if I can, on the person who does the induction speech when Barbara is inducted, the speech of introduction when Barbara is introduced to the LCFF Hall of Fame.
I think when people around the state hear this thing called the ESSA State Office,
they visualize like tens of people who are upstairs on the sixth floor doing all this incredible work because of all the output and incredible volume of work.
But in reality, just want everybody to know, it's two people, Barbara Murchison and Joy Kessel, and they've just done extraordinary work over these last 18 months.
So on behalf of basically all of California, Barbara and Joy, thank you so much.
Relating, I wanted to primarily address
the issue of the Title IV Part A Student Support and Academic Enrichment Grants, which is still an area where the board needs to make a decision.
And if you look at page, I believe it's page 29 of Attachment 2, there are two options that are laid out for the board in looking at those funds.
So option one would be to promote student access to a well-rounded education.
And it reads that California would use a portion of its Title IV Part A, Subpart I state-level activity ones to build the capacity of California educators to successfully implement state academic content standards.
So let me just make a parenthetical.
comment here, Board Member Strassel, I think that we can accommodate your intent, which I think is awesome and we would all support under option one.
It also says that, in addition, California will use a portion of its Title IV Part A, Subpart I state-level activity funds to support LEAs to improve school conditions for student learning.
And it directs us to that portion of the plan.
So the, you know, the
When we talk about small amounts of resources here, we're really getting into very small amounts of resources, but there's still critical leverage points that we can use as a state to accomplish our objectives.
And one thing we've heard about earlier is that
One of the things that we've done here at the Department of Education under the superintendent's leadership is realigned to maximize our internal resources.
And one of the most of many, many exciting activities that have come out of that have been the work that CDE and CSESA and the State Board of Education have worked to promote and promulgate these standards collaboration committees, which I know Board Member Strauss participates in, which have just done an extraordinary job
of promulgating and building capacity around state standards.
And we're going to hear more a little bit later on today about another area where we hope that some new state funding can help to further that work even further in the area of history and social sciences.
So when I discussed this with Superintendent Torokson, he felt that option one, which is again described on page six of attachment one,
represents the preferential path for the ESSA State Plan for three primary reasons.
Number one, it really, it kind of optimizes the spirit and furthers the spirit of LCF in terms of our commitment to multiple measures.
We've talked about this a lot over the past few months, over the past few years, and today.
In light of, and I thought board member Burr's comments earlier were the most cogent in terms of thinking about, we need to be thinking about all of the indicators that we have and all the priorities that we have.
And up until now, we've been moving this system forward without investing in a couple of those areas as much as we probably should have.
And that would include the area of school conditions.
and climate priority six, which we also spoke to earlier.
I believe that option one also better realizes the spirit of LCFF's commitment to the whole child as we think about the different areas that we want to address.
And I think the universal recognition that we heard earlier that school climate, which Title IV-A specifically addresses, is absolutely fundamental.
including not only student climate and school climate, but teacher climate.
And then lastly, I think the third major argument in favor of keeping the Title IV-A state-level activity funds
in option one in the area that they're designed for under ESSA would be that it provides us with greater flexibility.
We've been looking for flexibility.
We've been looking for ways that we can, and to borrow a metaphor from my old surfer days, which are long gone, is that
that LCFF provides the wave and we've got this ESSA surfboard.
We don't want ESSA to dictate where we can be putting our funds and how we're furthering our LCFF objectives.
With option one, we've got a ton of flexibility because the ESSA language specifically allows us to utilize those state-level activity funds to build capacity for our California educators and to further the promulgation of standards.
But it also would allow us the flexibility, if the board desired, to utilize a portion of those funds for things like the kinds of very critical school conditions and climate and whole child type activities that we've been talking about today.
The superintendent would urge that we take an option one approach.
I think that allows us to further the objectives that you've laid out, Board Member Strauss, while still allowing us as a state the opportunity to engage in some school conditions and climate work funded under ESSA in the future.
Okay, I think maybe we ought to get a motion on the floor of Board Member Rucker.
Well, I'm of two minds concerning this transfer of funds on this Title IV money.
In watching the work the federal government had done and the conversation the Secretary had with Congress when she submitted her budget, she basically had zeroed out a lot of that money.
And in doing that, it sent a chilling message across the country about what the administration's priorities are concerning the work that Title IV is intended to do in schools.
So, I want to remind the board what board member Lee Cone, Ortiz Lee Cone said about the opportunity to make sure that we are using this plan to address civil rights issues.
and to address and support and affirm the intent behind this civil rights legislation.
The community schools program that's listed in ESSA is intended to address that very important element.
And while we have a lot of work that does need to be done to fund the activities enumerated in Title II,
We can't abandon that particular priority either.
And so I think it is important to create, if the districts that came and testified today in a different item focused on the capacity development, the capacity building that they're gonna do.
That's what Title IV is about, and it happens in a number of different ways.
And the driver or the center of action or the locus of control where that work actually happens isn't just centered on the conversations the superintendents are doing among themselves, but in the communities where these schools
are actually working.
A corollary to some of the funding that's related to Title IV is funding for schools for promised neighborhoods.
And so that money can be used as a match for those particular competitive grants to support those programs and to implement them.
We're familiar with that particular program in this state because we had several districts when they received their SIG grants, they blended their SIG grants with their Promise Neighborhood Grant and they created and implemented a broader program improvement plan.
that incorporated work across the community in the neighborhoods where those SIG schools were.
So I think we have to understand not just what it is we're trying to fund and what it is we're trying to do.
I think we need to think broadly about what the entire plan
is supposed to do to give direction to the schools and districts about the things they should pay attention to.
Choosing to move this money is something we have great flexibility to do, but that's a kind of the salutary neglect that I talked about and criticized districts for previously, that we would actually be giving tacit agreement to that it's okay to do that.
Yeah.
Remember, we're talking about the 1.8 million dollars here, which is in the state, not the 21st century grants, not... Yeah, it's about 37 cents per student.
I understand.
Yeah.
OK.
I understand that's budget dust.
I'm just saying there is a message.
I got it.
But we're not moving all of the Title IV.
Right.
OK.
I'd like to get a motion.
So this is fairly complex because... Did you want to say something?
Okay, so.
Yes.
Sure.
To your point earlier, President Kirsch, you said that this plan is, you know, nested in a much, lots of other decisions.
To come are decisions about set-asides across the titles.
So, I'm not understanding why we have to make a decision about Title IV
right now because it's, at least for me, I would like to see what else is available, what other options, what other initiatives might come forward for those set-asides.
This seems kind of isolated to me.
Yeah, Barbara can answer that.
I think it has something to do with the template, you know, and the deadline.
There are two sections in the template where it specifically asks, and one's in Title 2a and one's in Title 4a, how are you planning to use your state-level activity funds?
Nobody knows.
The big money they did.
The big money in Title I, they put in another section of ESSA so it doesn't relate to the template.
I would have integrated the two if I were writing the law.
There are no state level activity funds for Title I.
So there's the required 7% for support and intervention.
And I'm not sure why they didn't ask for Title III, but this is our third template.
I don't know what made the cut or didn't as we moved from Template 2.0 to 3.0, but the template specifically asks states to describe how you are spending your Title II state-level activity money and your Title IV state-level activity money.
OK, board members.
Thank you.
So thank you, Barbara, for all your work on this.
And I also want to thank the stakeholders as well, who have followed this process for a year and a half and provided such great feedback.
I know that there are folks who are out there who are still disappointed with this, this plan.
And however,
must understand that this just because it's not the state plan is not fleshed out as much as you would have liked to have seen it that the state's commitment to closing the achievement gap and our commitment to California system of accountability and continuous improvement which is steeped in equity the work does not go on and I think from the previous three items we see how much work we
Have done and then we'll continue to and there is a commitment I think from everyone along this around this dais to make sure that happens So with that I'm going to start with my motion in three chunks one starting with just the technical changes And then we'll move forward from there.
So the first motion is
is to move CDE's recommendation to make the technical corrections to the draft plan identified during the staff presentation and to add a response to the new appendix B as follows.
And I think many of you have it in front of you.
So I'll just read on page 29, revised to read.
The ELPI baseline data is based on student progress between the 2014 and 2015 CELT administration and the number of students reclassified in 2014 for status compared to the student progress between 2013 and 2014 CELT administrations and the number of students reclassified in 2013 for change.
Then on page 39, revised to read, this performance level will be used as part of the criterion when determining schools under consideration of a comprehensive support in addition to the lowest 5%.
And then three, four, the new appendix B, add the proposed language reflected in the handout distributed by staff, which everyone should have received.
Okay, that was the first motion one.
Do I have a second for that?
These are largely technical.
Any board discussion on this?
Okay, all those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, that carries unanimously.
So motion two, move to revise the draft plan to insert language referencing the California English Learner Roadmap in the discussion of SEA support for English learner progress under title three on page 82 as follows.
Additionally, in response to a recent voter-approved ballot initiative, the California Education for a Global Economy Initiative, Proposition 58, and other changes in state and federal policy related to English learners, the California Department of Education will issue
the California English Learner Roadmap.
This resource will include guidance on how LEAs and schools can implement and strengthen comprehensive evidence-based programs and services for all profiles of English learners that enable the access to college and career-ready learning, as well as opportunities to attain the state seal of bi-literacy.
Okay, that's motion two.
Do we have a second to that?
Second, Ortiz-Lacon.
Board discussion?
Hearing none, raise your hand for that one.
Okay, that carries.
I made the motion.
Okay, motion three.
Okay, now motion three includes several items and
Let's see, I'm wondering, given some of the discussion on the Title IV, should I pull that out or just, okay, I'll just go through and then we can have a discussion on it.
Okay, move, I move that the State Board approve the ESSA State Plan for submission to the Federal Department of Education on September 18th, 2017, with the changes covered by Motion 1 and Motion 2, and the following substantive revisions.
A, revise the definition of curriculum frameworks in the glossary on pages 3 through 4 as specified in item attachment 2.
Revise the section on disproportionate rates of access to educators on page 50 through 52 as specified in item attachment 2.
Revise the section on state-level activities for Title IV, Part A, student support and academic enrichment grants to state.
California intends to transfer the Title IV Part A state-level activities funds to Title II Part A to support state-level activities under Title II Part A beginning in the 2018-2019 fiscal year, subject to meaningful consultation with all relevant stakeholders around the intended use and any equitable distribution requirements.
And I'm making that motion because while I hear the superintendent's recommendation, I feel that we do still have a lot of work in the core supporting our educators and
It's a matter of do we spread out the money a little bit more or do we double down on a specific area?
And we're not really doubling down because it's not a lot of money, but it is concentrating our funds to hopefully get more work done.
And then the last piece of this motion, very long motion three, is delegate authority to the State Board of Education Executive Director to approve the final revisions directed by the SBE under number one above and correction of any typographical errors.
Okay, is there a second to that motion?
Okay.
Any further discussion on that motion?
All right.
I think you ought to call the roll on this because this is the overall approval of the Tulsa State Plan.
Okay.
We'll do this in alphabetical order.
So we have Sue Burr.
Aye.
Jayden Gray.
Bruce Holliday.
Aye.
Mike Kirst.
Elisa Ortiz-Licon.
Aye.
Patricia Rucker?
No.
Nikki Sandoval?
Aye.
Eileen Strauss?
Ting Sung?
Aye.
Erin Valdez?
And Trish Williams is absent.
So the motion passes.
The motion passes.
All right.
So we are done with the ESSA.
That is the ESSA state plan.
So we'll do that.
Okay.
So now we're going to move to the waivers and it's in three parts.
These are consent votes, two consent votes and one individual action that will be pulled out, which is waiver 19.
So I'd like
Motion on waiver consent votes on waivers 1 and waiver 3 through 18.
So moved.
Is there a second?
Second on that.
Patricia, sorry.
One second to make sure we have the order correct.
Just please one second.
Did you get the revisions?
No.
No, you didn't read it that way.
I didn't think so.
Okay, the waiver consent vote.
Waiver one, W3 through W13, W15 through W18.
So moved.
Second on that.
All right.
All those in favor, vote.
Okay, now we need Rucker recruitment.
Okay, there'll be no staff presentation on this.
It is only separated out because of recruitment of board member Rucker.
So I need then a motion to approve this.
So moved.
Second.
Okay.
All right.
So all those in favor of that, raise your hands.
Okay.
Now we have two waivers for individual action.
Waiver 14 and waiver 19.
And we will have staff presentations on those.
So who is presenting for the staff on Waiver 14?
Kristen.
Kristen Wright.
I never saw this.
Yeah, they just handed it to us.
It's brand new.
President Kirst, members.
I'm Kristen Wright, Director of the Special Education Division.
Nice to see you.
This is nothing new for you in the sense of this is a set of RSP teacher caseload waivers and
essentially we're looking at four separate waivers and these essentially are what you've seen in the past which is within that 32 student caseload and we have a recommendation with conditions which include
having the right kinds of support to those teachers.
As you know, I just wanted to point out that you're all very painfully aware of the shortage that we're facing in the state.
And I think there is promise around the conversations that are happening at the Commission on Teacher Credentialing.
There are solutions that are being discussed.
In the meantime, as my staff goes out to monitor,
This is typically how these waivers come to us.
They're not people calling in to ask for a waiver.
They're typically either a complaint has come in and part of a corrective action is that they come before you and ask for a waiver or we've done a monitoring visit and there's been a larger caseload and that's another recommendation coming out of our monitoring visits.
So, just wanted to point that out.
So, if there are not any other questions, our recommendation again is approval with conditions.
Thank you.
Is there public comment on this one?
Angela Daramus from CTA.
Hi.
We're asking, CTA is asking for this item to be pulled from the consent calendar.
According to state, to Ed Code 33051A7, state board makes an exception to waiver approval when the exclusive representative of employee was not a participant in the development of this waiver.
In this case, Moreland Teachers Association is the exclusive representative and they were not a participant in the development of this waiver.
Accordingly, CTA is opposing this on the basis that is not in the best interest of Moreland students, nor does it fit in with the collective bargaining agreement.
For these reasons, we ask you to remove this item from the consent calendar.
Yeah, it is removed.
That's why we're discussing it.
Right, exactly.
Yeah, so we're, yeah, we understand and you gave the reasons that you're opposed.
Do I have a motion on this?
I guess I have a question before making a motion.
In the waiver itself, it does say that the association was consulted.
There was a position of neutral on the waiver.
They were not.
So if you could just clarify that on Moreland.
So the information that we received from the district that they submitted to us for the waiver said that there was a neutral position and it gave a date and the name of the person that they talked to.
So I'm happy to look into additional information if the board so would like me to do that.
But that's the information that we were provided.
Board Member Rucker.
My understanding because this was forwarded to me and I attempted to send it to Judy.
I'm having problems with sending this.
My understanding is that the association was not consulted.
That in fact, the superintendent has told the association that they are not required to consult with them on these waivers.
And so what the, so what's written on the form and what the association has that was actually told by the superintendent is two different things.
So I don't believe the association and I'm, I don't believe the association intends that the entire waiver item for the other three LEAs listed would be held.
They're asking that the waiver request from Moreland be removed from board action today so that you would have an opportunity to look into it.
And we're happy to do that.
OK, so then I would have a motion.
Go ahead, Member Sandoval.
Yeah, so I looked at the other ones and what I would like to do is in this particular waiver 14, remove Moreland from the list.
And I would move approval of the CD's recommendation to grant the waiver requests for Claremont and Jefferson.
But remove Moreland for further.
OK, is there a second to that?
I'll second it.
Okay.
Further discussion?
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay.
That carries.
Waiver 19.
Charter School Program, Baldwin Park Unified School District.
Good afternoon Board President Kuerst, Chief Deputy Superintendent Price, and members of the Board.
I'm Cindy Chan, Director of the Charter Schools Division at the California Department of Education.
Item W19 includes a request by Baldwin Park Unified for a waiver on behalf of their Charter School Opportunities for Learning in Baldwin Park, a non-classroom based charter school.
give you really brief background on this for the new board member and just to kind of give you recollection as to these types of waivers that we bring forward to you.
There was a specific case in Shasta County that was litigated involving a non-classroom based charter school operating resource center outside the geographic boundaries of its authorized school district but within the same county.
The school district where the resource center was located filed suit contending the location of this resource center was in violation of California law.
Fast forward to January 2017, the litigation was appealed.
The Third District Court of Appeals court opinion of Anderson Union High School District versus Shasta Secondary Home School, which we refer to as the Anderson decision.
became final at that time, which held that geographic restrictions pursuant to specified statutes apply to non-classroom-based charter schools operating resource centers.
Thus, in order to ensure compliance with the court opinion, a non-classroom-based charter school resource center must operate within the boundaries of its authorizing school district unless an exception applies.
Additionally, the charter school may establish a resource center in an adjacent county.
The mid-year timing of this final decision, however, was thought to be problematic for some schools to come into immediate compliance.
Therefore, in March of this year, this board approved Waiver Policy 1701-01, entitled Non-Classroom-Based Charter School Resource Center Location.
So regarding this request, Baldwin Park Unified as the chartering authority is requesting on behalf of OFL Baldwin Park to allow the non-classroom based charter schools resource centers to operate outside of its geographic boundaries but within the county.
There was one waiver request submitted by the district that includes seven resource centers for this charter school.
Five are included in waiver item 17.
I think you moved that one on consent.
as those resource centers, those five resource centers for the charter school met the policy criteria.
However, two in our review did not meet the criteria and so we've pulled them out of the other item and included it separately in this item.
That way the other item is very clean and it follows the waiver policy that was approved.
Consistent with the policy, Baldwin Park Unified submitted the following information as detailed in Attachment 1.
They provided the address of each resource center, the school district in which each resource center is located, the date each resource center was established, and the number of students attending each resource center.
In addition, they also provided the discussion for the need of the waiver.
In our review of the policy, we determined that two resource centers did not meet the criteria.
And I'm going to break them out because they're very similar in terms of their location.
The first one, 3939 Atlantic Avenue, suites 101, 113, 114, 116 in Long Beach.
The resource center was established in 1999.
It's located in the boundaries of the Long Beach Unified School District.
and in 2016-17 served 228 students and staffed 16 employees.
The facility that they operated in was leased from a third party with plans to relocate in April 2017.
This resource center was closed effective April 14, 2017.
Therefore, we find that the waiver request for this resource center, 3939 Atlantic Avenue, does not comply with the policy since the charter school no longer operates the resource center and pursuant to the policy, the waiver shall not be retroactive.
The second resource center in this request, 3501 Atlantic Avenue, also located in Long Beach, was established in 2015 with the intention of expanding the 3939 Atlantic Avenue Resource Center, the one I just mentioned.
It's also located in the boundaries of Long Beach Unified, and it was opened for students on April 18th, so three days after the other resource center closed.
The students and employees from the 3939 Atlantic Resource Center were moved to this one.
Because the 3501 Atlantic Avenue Resource Center began operationally serving students subsequent to the policy approved by the state board on March 9th.
The waiver request for this resource center does not comply with the policy because the policy applies to existing resource centers and this one was operated after that day.
However, we find that the charter school operated the 3939 Atlantic Avenue Resource Center during the effective period of the policy and that the transition to the 3501 Atlantic Avenue Resource Center, both located within the same district, Long Beach Unified, occurred within a reasonable time period.
Therefore, we recommend approval.
of the Charter School Resource Center identified in Attachment 1, specifically 3501 Atlantic Avenue in Long Beach with the following conditions that's pursuant to the policy.
The first one is to require the Charter School's governing body to approve a transition plan that details how the Charter School's Resource Center will come into compliance with the Anderson Court decision.
Two, pursuant to Education Code Section 33051B, the waiver shall expire on June 30, 2018 and shall not be retroactive.
Three, require the charter school to submit the transition plan to the authorizing school district, Baldwin Park Unified, and to all school districts identified in Attachment 1, and in this case it's Long Beach Unified.
where the resource center is located within 30 days after approval of the waiver.
Four, require the charter school to provide a status update to parents.
And five, if the authorizer has not visited the resource center identified in attachment one pursuant to education code section 47604.32,
A2, require the authorizer to visit the resource center within a reasonable time frame.
So that concludes my presentation.
I can answer any questions you have.
Are there any questions on this board member?
As I understand, there's no monkey business going on here.
They are going to have to comply with the Shasta ruling just the way all these other organizations are.
And they just got trapped in this situation, timing situation of a planned move
from one facility to another, but it does not change our basic waiver policy and the basic obligation of this organization.
And therefore, I would move the staff's recommendation.
Is there a second?
Second.
Okay.
Any board discussion?
Is there any... I'm getting hungry again.
I just wanted to... He gets up early.
I go to bed early.
So I apologize for the record.
Yeah.
Any public comment on this?
If not, all those in favor, raise your hands.
All right.
That carries.
Thank you.
So now we're on to proposed consent calendars.
And as far as I know, there is no
None of these have been polled.
So, first of the proposed... Wait.
Oh, yes.
Okay.
We have some abstentions.
Proposed consent.
So we have some.
All right.
So we have proposed waiver consent calendar includes.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yes, we have.
Yeah, there we go.
We have three of these because of recusal.
So the first consent vote for item five.
Sue, Ting, Karen recusal.
So item five.
Okay.
And we're voting on.
consolidated applications for Menifee Union Elementary, Natomas Unified and Oakland Military Institute.
So these are these are proposed consent items.
And we had some board members need to recuse.
But they're out.
All right.
All those.
Is there a motion?
Since I was associated with OMI in the past, is that a concern?
Great.
Then I move.
So move.
Second.
Is there any board member discussion?
Okay.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
We're going to need.
Okay.
We have all of us.
That carries.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now we need a second consent vote for item five.
And these are
Eileen and Feliza.
And these are for the county school district codes.
Patricia.
Yeah, Con Apps, but... Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
These are for Con App items submitted by LEAs as noted in attachments.
Everything but those three.
Okay.
All other consolidated applications.
So moved.
Second.
Second Sandoval.
Any board discussion?
If not, it's consent.
Raise your hands.
Okay.
Those go.
And now we have the consent vote item six through sixteen.
No recusals needed for this.
We do have public comment on nine.
Okay, public comment on nine.
And on fourteen.
It's nice to see the staff now including in the application process acknowledgement of school board members as practitioners.
We bring some really valuable experience to these committees, I believe.
We're glad to see that as a consideration.
Thank you.
Item 14.
Is this on?
Which item are you seeing?
14 or later.
Speaking on item 14.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
We're concerned about the recommendation to cut the funding for the Twin Ridges Charter School, tiny charter school up in the
up in the foothills above Grass Valley.
They have been building up their budget reserve because they serve, one of the major populations they serve comes out of the Beale Air Force Base and depending on deployments and other stuff, their population can go anywhere from 80 to 160 kids.
And naturally, riding that fluctuation is kind of difficult for them.
Beefing up their reserves cause them to miss the 40 and 80 percent expenditure targets that are normally needed.
We think that that's a lousy reason to cut their funding, particularly by 30 percent.
And we think that this is a type of policy that you folks have spoken about before.
It all comes out of regulations that are within your control.
And there's been a lot of talk about fixing the regulations so we don't give bad incentives to schools to make bad financial decisions, but currently the regulations do.
And we think, number one, we would recommend full funding for this school.
Number two, we would urge you to crack open those regulations.
They've been festering for years and giving schools bad incentives.
I hate to have to tell my membership to spend down their reserves, particularly when we're likely to have a recession sometime in the relatively near future.
Thank you.
Board Member Holliday.
I appreciate Mr. Premak's comments, in particular, his point number two.
Once again, I do agree that these regulations are outdated, that they're awkward and that they do not serve children as well as they should.
That being said,
I disagree with his first point in that the ACCS met went over this item very carefully and in their conclusion they felt as though there was ample opportunity for this school to appeal this decision to the CE and prove that they have currently met the spending requirements
and are continuing to, this is all based on prior years of spending.
And so once again that they are in compliance and that it is with that assurance that they will likely not receive
If they go through this process and are successful, which likely that will be the case, they will not actually have a reduction in their spending based upon the timing.
So, the ACCS looked at it very carefully and decided to go with the CDE recommendation and that's why I agree as well.
Okay.
Are you willing to make a motion?
Well, let's see.
We have two that we've heard.
So, are we ready for a motion on all of the proposed consent items?
So move.
Okay.
Second.
Any further discussion?
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, that carries.
So we're done with proposed consent and we're on to our final item, which is item 17, State Board Projects and Priorities.
So I need a motion to approve the minutes.
Move approval.
All right, all those in favor?
Okay, then I'm going to go down the usual list here, starting with next generation science standards, Strauss.
So the early implementers of Next Generation Science Standards do a summer institute for teachers.
They also do it for admin leaders.
So they had a, I was in Dublin, Northern California on July 27th and in Palm Springs on August 3rd.
Great energy, really excitement.
The K-12 Alliance did an amazing job of leading the work and just one comment out of
I just did an update on where we were in science.
But I think one of the things I saw was so effective.
They're trying to help leaders understand where the shifts are in science.
And so science coaches are taking principals and leaders through classrooms, coaching them on how to find
the practices and find evidence.
So it's really a great coaching strategy to grow the leader skills to recognize that.
So that was a very, very exciting process.
And then I'll just add,
on August 16th, the Math and Science Collaboration Committee.
So there's a larger community of practice that I talked about before that's 100 science practitioners and 100 math, but this is the 35 or so.
And they met together in San Diego, and they're actually pushing very hard to have math and science begin to work together more collaboratively and have their meetings on the same days.
so that they cross-fertilize the work.
And so they talked about high quality math instruction, high quality work at the county level.
What does it mean for standards implementation for both science and mathematics?
So very, very exciting.
Their next meeting is October 18th and 19th up here in Sacramento.
OK.
Charters, holiday.
That will be tomorrow.
OK.
California Teacher Commission, Straus.
So just real quickly, the CTC met last week and I just want to bring up, and probably Member Sandoval is aware of this, but as a result of the 2016 research report on special educators, there's a lot of talk about and work on updating the credentialing requirements and training for
teachers who teach students with a variety of disabilities.
There's been strong work by the work groups and two recommendations and there's not agreement right now from the work groups.
And basically there's an agreement there should be a common core or what they call a common trunk of coursework that all teachers have.
special ed and regular ed, but there is a discussion about whether there should be a double credential required for special educators when in fact we're having a hard time getting people into special ed and the length of time and the work and also talking about the need for induction standards and work around this.
So there will be a study session at the October CTC meeting where they're going to try in a public session to bring both work groups together and come to an agreement.
but for people who care a whole lot about special ed and understand how important it is to credential and train teachers.
There's not an agreement right now and they didn't want to rush the decision.
They did expand early childhood from birth to kindergarten.
So, that happened as well.
And so, I'll bring you up to date as more information comes.
Okay.
CCEE Burr.
You heard a lot about CCEE this morning, so I won't bore you with the details except to say that our next meeting is Wednesday, October 4th, here in this room.
Invite anybody who would like to come.
It's always a good opportunity to hear, especially from what's going on in the field.
I would like to take this opportunity, President Kirst, in my role as the chair of the screening committee for the State Board,
We're in fall recruitment season.
And so I just want to make sure people are aware that we're recruiting for three advisory committees.
The first one is CPAG, the California Practitioners Advisory Committee.
And we're looking for applicants who meet one or more of the practitioner categories of education researchers, teachers from charter schools, or representatives of private school children.
And the deadline for application is Wednesday, October 12th.
We're recruiting for a parent member for the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools.
So we're looking for an individual who is a parent or guardian of a student who is currently attending a charter school and representatives of the District Governing Board to serve on the ACCS.
The deadline for that is Thursday, October 12th.
We're also recruiting for the Instructional Quality Commission.
We're looking for four appointments from currently practicing teachers and or leaders with experience in special education, elementary grades, mathematics, and or ethnic studies, which is a new piece of work we're doing.
And those applications are due Wednesday, October 11th.
And finally, I always like to do this on the first meeting of our student board member.
We're recruiting for the next student board member.
As you know, it always happens in conjunction with the state student leadership convening in November.
So, we're looking for student members who are interested in being on the state board.
And that deadline is Thursday, October 12th.
So, make sure that you let people know because we like to have a robust set of applications for all of our committees.
Thank you.
Okay.
California Practitioners Advisory Group.
So, the member Valdez and I attended and a lot of the items we gave feedback on, on today's accountability items.
Do you want to comment?
I just will reinforce that there was a strong feeling about the surveys being every other year versus... On climate.
On climate.
That definitely came up.
Okay.
English learners, Ortiz-Lacombe.
There is a meeting for the EO roadmap.
I believe it's at the end of the month.
Unfortunately, I will not be able to attend as I will be in Nashville.
But I think that it would be a great idea if board member Valdez attends.
That meeting will be to provide guidance on how to implement the policy we adopted proposition.
I'm sorry, the EO roadmap.
So that will be building towards the document that LEAs will receive.
Thank you.
Okay.
Environment holiday.
Well, I don't actually report on the environment.
If I did, I think I would report that she's pretty upset these days and the result we're seeing.
But instead, I report on the Environmental Literacy Steering Committee and the efforts to infuse environmental literacy across the disciplines in the state of California.
And in that regard, once again, we've recently seen how terribly environmental literacy is important, especially to underserved, low-income communities who are almost always the ones who suffer the most in an environmental disaster.
But the good news is that thanks to the state legislature and Governor Brown, another significant step has been taken on behalf of environmental literacy, and that is through an allocation
of $4 million for the Superintendent of Public Instruction to provide grants to a local education agency or consortium of local education agencies to establish the California Regional Environmental Education Community Network known as CREEC.
And this funding allows CREEC to implement a new vision, a new mission, and a new strategy for environmental literacy throughout the state.
That's good news.
IQC, ELA, ELA Strauss.
So there's a collaboration committee for ELA, ELD that's also been meeting and that group meets again October 12th.
They're talking about looking at the framework and grounding practice, looking at resources for foundational skills, looking at a system to support alignment with materials and the framework, which I talked a little about before.
And then some lessons they're learning on implementation that in professional development, bite-sized chunks seem to work the best, that we have to build capacity, that teachers have to own the work, and that leaders have a responsibility to lead literacy improvement, and that we really are focusing on good first instruction.
So, really an exciting group of people.
Again, it's about 35 people that meet together.
and we're talking about next steps.
I just want to add on, because it's not on the list, the Social Emotional Learning group met on Monday and Deputy Price was there as well.
It's an exciting group.
We're part of a state, used to be eight states.
I think we're 19 now in a national consortium on social emotional learning.
And we're looking at practices that promote strong learning with guiding principles and to develop a compendium of resources.
And this group meets again on January 22nd.
And in between the meetings, they do have calls and planning sessions.
So Deputy Price might want to add to it, but it was a really exciting talking about how to integrate it, how it works with our work in school climate and teacher practices to support it, what things we need to do for teachers and
school leadership Hey IQ see the health framework Ortiz Lacombe
Yes, and I want to thank Stephanie for providing talking points.
I did give extensive feedback on the chapters and I have to say I'm very proud of the framework that we're developing.
It's very comprehensive, very progressive.
We discuss health disparities and looking at not only the physical health but also the environment and what contributes to some of the health
issues that we see in communities and in particular communities of color.
So I want to say that I'm very proud of what we're working and working with.
In terms of the Health Education Curriculum Framework and Evaluation Criteria Committee, they are meeting next week for the fourth time and please feel free to submit or attend.
And if you want to submit comments, healtheducationframework at cde.california.gov.
Thanks.
Okay, IQC History, Social Science and I asked board member Rucker to talk about the money we got for implementing this from the legislature, which was not in the governor's budget, but we're happy to have it.
And so this is quite interesting and she's going to talk a little bit about what's been going on with this.
This is a whole new grant program.
My microphone says it's on, so I hope you can hear me.
I need a big strong man to come and turn on my microphone.
It's on now?
Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you, whoever he is.
So I'm very excited to be here today to talk to you about this money.
And I get to be the person who's the bearer of excellent news.
And in saying that, I will say any hard questions you have, they go to the department staff, Stephanie and Tom.
But I'll answer the easy question and tell you about the funding.
In the time that I have been on the board, the legislature has given a very clear messages about their intent in implementing the changes in the curriculum and the direction this board has tried to go in improving and changing our school program.
The first time we saw that was the funding that they gave to implement and develop a statewide plan for implementing the Common Core.
and then they gave funds in the budget that were a line item to support LEA initiatives for providing training to teachers to implement curriculum in English language arts and mathematics.
Since that time, and in my time on the board, we have worked together to create a new English language arts framework, a mathematics framework, and with the rollout and the implementation of those frameworks, our department staff has been notable
and received a great deal of praise for the rollout activities that they created in support of doing this work.
So here we are today.
The legislature provided specific language within the Budget Act and it asked the state superintendent to contract with the County Office of Education to coordinate the work to develop professional development activities in support of the implementation of the history social science framework.
The legislature in particular calls for professional learning activities and resources aligned with the framework and the health education framework.
So, Board Member Ortiz-Lincoln, I want you to know we're hooked up.
Specifically, the opportunities and resources should focus on but not be limited to a number of different topics.
What's notable about and very important about the social science framework is not just the controversy behind the development of the curriculum, but in some of the ways it attempts to resolve
or create some consensus around how to have conversations about these issues.
The health framework has also chosen to step into that controversy pool by identifying some very hard to teach and hard to talk about subjects and bringing it into the mainstream of instruction for students.
So choosing to fund these activities and to fund the rollout and support of professional development for these frameworks is the state's very clear fingerprint, imperator on how to do this, but also to create leadership and guidance on this curriculum, not only as a subject, but for a topic that actually will frame not only our way of thinking,
but inform an entire generation of students who will matriculate through our school system and then become those who become the policymakers later on.
So this is our fingerprint on the future.
In providing these resources and in providing this training, it also gives the opportunity to be innovative.
So it's not just about in-person training.
It's about the way we grow the resources that are available to teachers, both online and in other ways that the information can be delivered.
This is an opportunity for LEAs to participate in professional learning that not only enhances their knowledge, but also builds capacity to create an understanding about the instructional shifts in both content areas.
Teachers now can recite from memory.
What are the instructional shifts for teaching math?
What are the three instructional shifts for teaching English language arts?
There were some very clear instructional shifts in the history of social science framework that is anchored in not just teaching history, but in teaching content across the subject areas so that we are integrating the work that we do.
This funding further provides the ability for districts to take advantage not only of the current research, but also opportunities for as it relates to the health framework to have an impact on the conversations about school climate and other issues that directly relate to how students see themselves and their work in the school and how the issues that are being developed in that framework matter to students in the school.
Currently, there's an established partnership between the Department of Ed, the CDE, and CSESA that has created collaboration committees in the four subject areas, science, math, English language arts, and history, social science.
The history, social science collaboration committee has developed framework rollout events and have already conducted a number of events with attendees ranging from 200 to 500 at each event.
This funding allows the continuation of collaboration committees to do a deeper dive into the history of social science framework topics and to provide ongoing professional learning through the collaboration committee, through the community of practice events, and through the framework events, and also to develop something that we haven't seen in our adoption before.
But to curate
aligned instructional resources so that for history of social science, the adoption is actually a living element in the support of what teachers do in the classroom.
So you heard earlier with teaching math, teachers use the book in their implementing curriculum.
The goal and the hope in implementing history of social science is it's not just going to be centered around or anchored with the book.
Going a little further, as we look at the health education framework, it's currently in development, as you just heard in the presentation from my colleague, Board Member Ortiz-Lincon.
The committee is meeting for the fourth time next week.
The chapters drafted are in the process of being revised.
This funding presents a great opportunity to build the network of health educators
and create a collaboration committee modeled after the current process we have in place.
We have good models of practice and good ways of doing this work, so the health education framework will have the advantage of stepping down a footpath that's already well-tread, well-worn, and has worked quite well for us.
Community of Practice events and the Health Education Framework rollouts will be developed through that similar committee collaboration process with the help of the Health Education Framework.
And that will include likely some updated legislation like the California Healthy Youth Act, violence prevention, and sexual harassment.
Establishing a Health Education Collaboration Committee will build capacity among our County Offices of Education and our LEAs.
Finally, I will overall for me seeing this item in the budget was very exciting.
People ask how did this happen.
Somebody asked nicely and this is one of those times when I usually say it seemed like a good idea at the time.
I don't mean it.
This time it was a good idea at the time.
LEAs across the state will benefit.
It's an opportunity for teachers and our students to change the way we do teaching and learning about history, social science, but most importantly, to build a foundation about how we approach health education that can actually inform some of the conversations around our LCAP.
So I stand here to answer any questions you may have.
Yeah, the amounts of money, there were specific amounts.
I know it was 5 million was earmarked for the online resources.
And that was to be done by the California History.
There was even a designated grant for that.
Yeah, it's a total of, it's a total of ten million dollars in the budget.
And yes, a significant portion of it is set aside for a specific development of specific online resources.
The department is actually going to be doing the work with that in collaboration with that contractor.
Yeah, and then the other parts of this, it's not online.
The amounts of money, again, Mr. Adams is here from the California Department.
Yeah, Tom Adams, Deputy Superintendent, Teaching and Learning Support Branch.
Actually, there was $5 million that went to the California Historical Society to work with the California History Social Science Project in terms of developing some California specific resources.
So that's a separate $5 million pot.
And what's the other pot?
Then you have the 10 million dollar pot, which is to actually support the implementation of the history social science framework and the health framework.
Yeah, that's a lot of...
Well, let's keep in mind too, this is Prop 98 fund.
So, there does have to be an LEA designated to help carry that out.
It's not part of the state operating fund in terms of the department.
So, we will be looking for a partnership on that.
Okay, good.
Any questions?
If not, thank you.
So, shuffling papers here.
Where is the next one?
IQC next.
Yeah.
So I'll just make one comment on mathematics.
I think those of us in the field realize that we need to continue to focus on all of our instructional practices, but that mathematics is going to require additional look and rethinking what we're doing.
So there's a subcommittee that's going to be
meeting to look at where we've seen promising practices and what we can learn about it as we know that LEAs are struggling with math progress.
And so that'll be a priority that we'll report as we work for next step.
Yeah, I'll be working with that committee on a separate and related item tomorrow.
The board is going to be taking action
on an item concerning regulations for an interim adoption.
A lot of us are concerned and remain concerned about the criticism that the board received concerning the recommendations for the mass adoption last year.
And part of that was in the way the process worked and how the criteria was used.
in developing that particular work.
And so in looking at those regulations and in looking at that board item, it's not an opportunity to revisit the adoption.
It's an opportunity to think about our relationship with the publishers who did this.
and to look at those, how those regulations can guide or allow the republishers of the materials we did adopt to respond to some of those concerns.
So that work is ongoing and that work will continue for the math framework and for the math curriculum itself.
Okay, IQC Strauss.
I think just to know that people are continuing to help do readiness and understanding of the science framework.
The materials will be reviewed next spring and summer.
That'll come back to us a year from now for and what I've shared with districts is that gives you time to become a good SUMR and understand the standards so that when you look to adopt materials you understand
what you're looking at.
So that's where we are right now.
There'll be continued work on it.
And regions will be doing more activities this year as the second year of the collaboration committees.
Joint Committee on Workforce Pathways.
Great.
So we will be having our fourth meeting tomorrow.
I mean, sorry, Friday.
And so we have thus far really just kind of taken a reconnaissance of the lay of the land, what types of CTE preparation programs are out there, how they're laid out, what are some partnerships.
We've looked at what does a pathway look like from a student moving through.
the different levels and then we also had a great session last time around data systems as board member Rucker had referred to as well and the lack of alignment or there are information out there that we really could do a lot more in making sure that we have data that is more cohesive aligned and will provide all the agencies more information that they need.
So we are hoping to adopt some principles out of the work.
And we're looking at some draft principles, we're hoping, by December, by our December meeting.
And then from there, those principles will provide some guidance to us in how we will continue to work K-12 and the community colleges will work together in more cohesive pathways for our students to move into the workforce.
Special Education, Sandoval.
Before I address special education, I just want to follow up on the history of social science because I did attend some meetings.
I just wanted to report back.
Okay, good.
So I observed some of the materials review sessions in late July, and I just wanted to acknowledge the commitment of the reviewers at the time and the care that they've invested in this process.
And I also attended the public hearing on materials adoption on August 17th, and I heard testimony from more than 75 members of the public.
I've got a lot to say.
And some of the most compelling testimony was the youth voices, and particularly as they spoke about hostile climates on campus and the ignorance, unfortunately, that is still very much alive and well.
And queer students, students of color still facing really just the residue of not having good information out there.
So I needed to acknowledge that.
And just the responsibility that we have to make sure that our materials are not only factually accurate, but that the images and the graphics associated that help tell the story are sensitively curing, which actually relates to your, this repository and these resources for teachers, so they have good information that's been vetted.
And so I just wanted to make that point.
And I think that it's really evolved in a positive way.
And I look forward to more discoveries in our November meeting.
But we still have some things to do to address the public's concerns for sure.
And towards that end, the work that's happening with the frameworks already, the adopted history social science frameworks,
On October 9th on Indigenous Peoples Day here at Sacramento State University for this year, this campus is convening a California Indian Curriculum Summit.
And so the intention for this gathering is really to provide
third and fourth grade teachers with some very carefully vetted, by California Indians, curricular resources, not only address the common core state standards, but the newly adopted history social science framework.
So there are things happening.
People in California taking leadership for really creating new curricular models and resources that will help teachers tremendously.
So I just wanted to address that before I gave the special education report.
I attended the Advisory Commission on Special Education and we heard a report on the success of trauma-informed care and the educational challenges in our juvenile justice systems.
The student population among three facilities in the state is 600 youth in the juvenile justice system.
Half of these students have not earned a high school diploma yet.
So that's a big hurdle.
And then 30% of the 600 students are eligible for special education services.
So that's a very significant segment of that population.
Of the 600, 21% are English learners.
So we learned about evidence-based practices to address the trauma that these students, 90% of the students in our juvenile justice system report having survived at least one trauma.
Many had multiple traumas to report.
So that was a very important presentation for here.
And then we also heard a report on the dyslexia guidelines to assist general and special education teachers and parents identify and assess pupils with dyslexia.
And this really provides a starting point, the guidelines, which are published now on the CDE website.
And it will hopefully provide guidance and support to our teachers.
And then we heard from the California Department of Social Services on a more integrated approach to building systems of care for youth that involve education, mental health, public health, child welfare, and the justice system.
And one ongoing challenge used to be the linkage between social services and education.
So we still have, again, much to do there.
But there are three anchors that were identified to this work, and that's an integrated training plan,
integrated core practice model, and then interagency MOUs.
And they're very specific, measurable milestones that work, and that is an ongoing process.
And then we also heard an update on the competitive integrated employment blueprint.
And that's ways to increase employment opportunities for individuals with intellectual and developmental disabilities.
And that's a multi-agency effort between CDE, Department of Rehabilitation, and the Department of Developmental Services.
And there's a goal to establish local partnerships, at least 13 in the short term,
between LEAs, Department of Rehabilitation Districts, and regional centers in the next year, then there's a five-year goal to roll out more of these partnership agreements between 200 LEAs and their Department of Rehabilitation Districts and regional centers.
And the goal, of course, is working for pay for at least minimum wage so that people have an equal opportunity to make a living wage.
That was it for summer school for the arts.
It's summer.
So yes, it's summer.
I'm delighted.
Adrian Molina, who is an alum of the California State School, California State Summer School for the Arts, has written and co-directed Coco, which is a new Disney Pixar feature.
about Miguel who is a boy who dreams of becoming a musician and he goes on this extraordinary fantastic journey.
The filming in late November but the California State Summer School of the Arts Foundation is organizing a special pre-release screening at Pixar Animation Studios on November 6th and the proceeds will ensure that the school continues to provide the highest quality pre-professional training for emerging artists in California and the
The list is really a who's who.
Benjamin Bratt is one of the voices.
And there are others, too, that are fantastic.
And I also wanted to mention that the Visual and Performing Arts Standards revision is about to start.
There's an online application for the Standards Advisory Committee that will be available this month.
And the revisions will be based on the current National Core Arts Standards, which include the disciplines of dance, theater, music, and visual arts.
Okay, good.
That concludes that.
And I have a very happy ending to this long day.
That just now, you want to hear this Board Member Strauss.
Board Member Klaus and Board Member Burr were confirmed by the California Senate for new terms, so.
The Board is adjourned for today.